What is that noise? It sounds like the fire. Oh, there we go.
Oh, he's like, this world is free.
Whoa, this is too loud.
3 A believes it.
Brave.
Obviously, I've jumped into the game.
Oh, wait a minute.
Oh, wait, can I hear myself?
I can't hear myself.
Get the oof.
What am I?
Mommy's here.
I'm going to open it.
Hi, good morning. Good evening.
Good afternoon.
How is that all fit to scale?
Oh wait, that doesn't fit to scale at all, Roonlight.
Was that like that last stream?
It doesn't. Wait, why is this on top of the freaking thing?
No, don't do that. That's even worse.
Go below.
Why is there two Roonlight?
Is it the game capture's nice and loud?
Okay, no, that looks correct. I just need to do that.
Okay, Rinscape's just a funny-shaped game, okay?
It's going to be scoff.
It's just a funny-shaped game.
I'm too dumb for to figure out.
Is that a reflin?
Reflin, you're already in?
Other player has accepted?
Okay.
I'm like, that's a reflin, you're quick.
We are in World High...
Oh, it's replays.
Hi, Red E. Blink.
That's how I spell it.
Damn, reflins are shown off.
I'm not even freaking set.
Oh, this is my update for today.
No way, they have freaking Gangnam style
and freaking Rinscape 07.
Old school.
I don't know why I said 07 though.
Oh, my Gangnam style.
Sexy reflin.
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh.
Gangnam style.
Howdy-ow.
Good morning, good evening, and good after noon.
I hope you guys are ready for a cheeky endurance stream.
Hi, reflings.
Hi, Strawny, I guess.
Yeah, I hope you're ready for a cheeky endurance today.
I had a bit of business going on behind the scenes,
business, business, business,
so I hope to have quite a fun update soon.
I've just told the girls what the business was,
and someone's very excited.
I just read their message,
but I can't say or else spoilers.
Let me open up my inventory so you guys can see what's up.
Yes, we are business, business, business.
Honestly, it feels really weird doing straight-up business, business, business.
The only thing I'm used to is sponsorship people reaching out to me
and being like, hey, for a 60-second segment,
I will pay you this much.
This is what is going on.
And then I'm just like...
I can't.
But this time I got...
I will talk about it a bit more.
I'm going to ask permission if I can talk about it
because the person is associated with an agency that helped out to...
And if they're comfortable with it,
I'm happy to talk about it.
Obviously, nothing.
Azur got monetized?
Are you telling me Azur got monetized?
I went to bed and Azur wasn't monetized.
Sheevee was, which made me think within 24 hours Azur is getting reviewed next.
I just hope her massive fucking honkers don't...
I know Denpa isn't in here right now.
Denpa's just messaged me.
She's...
Sean, I know you have a lot on your plate.
Do you think AceMars is?
What do you need Denpa?
I won't charge.
Denpa...
I won't charge, darling.
Oh Denpa, you're so adorable.
Never charge friends.
Always do it for free because when you have friends like these,
life is good.
I have not even known Denpa for more than two weeks
and she's been nothing but a sweetheart to me.
Right, I am going to go to the bank and clear out all my fissies in the background
whilst I ramble to yours.
I have absolutely terrible news.
Just upshotting news.
I tried to take a Jobay,
but the Jobay wouldn't have come.
So I'm probably going to have to take a big steamer in the middle of the stream,
which I'm raging because I hate...
Right, I don't...
I'll always go for a shower after I do a big Jobay
because I can't...
Wait, should I just make a...
I think it would actually be faster.
Hold on, Refluence.
I think it's going to be faster if I take wood out and...
Do I even have wood?
Do I even have an axe?
It must...
I do have an axe.
Okay, then I need a tinderbox.
Okay.
I don't actually have a bit of wood.
Right, that's fine though.
We're going to go get it.
Right, we'll chop here and then I'm going to make a fire outside the bank for now
and eliminate all of my inventory.
Oh, tiny cuttles wants to trade with you.
What's your name?
Little baby cuttles.
Hi.
Oh, you already given me one.
Thank you.
Yes, I will be needing these.
Thank you very much.
The best way to ruin friendship is to get money involved.
I went until you learned about the development team drama.
Oh my God!
I've got a really funny fucking comment.
So, you know how I'm always telling you about like,
all I have on hand for wood right now,
your wood is more than enough.
Little Refling, I assure you.
A winky face, because we all know what we're talking about.
I'm a mod.
Oh, damn, bullshit!
I was talking about you.
I'm so scared.
I never streamed on YouTube.
Oh, you don't actually have to mod anything.
It's like customary to make you a mod
so that you stand out more in chat.
DEMPA, I'm so sorry.
I was just exposing you.
I just said that you wanted an ASMR script
and I'm offering it for free
because I would never charge you for that.
You're freaking sick of just not...
Wait, wait, wait.
Let me pick up...
I'm doing two things.
Right, let me finish up the...
Why did that only take out one?
Oh, it's not looking good.
Now you all know that I'm a RuneScape noob.
Oh yeah, YouTube custom.
Yes, you're learning right.
Use Tinder box on the logs.
Oh my God, you got a little cabbage head going on.
Okay, right.
Oh, I don't want to brag but I'm leveled to a fire making.
Right, we are going to just get rid of...
Not rid of, but...
But yeah, you don't...
Yeah, so as I was saying,
we got a little hate comment today on YouTube
but do you want to know why it's so funny?
It's because most of the comments were like,
vealers aren't going to last a month.
And then it went to two months and it went to six months.
Do you want to know what today's hate comment and quotation marks was
that I had to delete?
Vealers aren't going to last two years.
Motherfucker, if vealers last two years,
all three generations are successfully out.
I don't...
What?
Are you dumb?
I like how it went from not even going to last a week,
not even going to last a month.
Two years?
Two years, all three gents are out.
Vealers and I have succeeded in what I wanted to do.
Literally just multiplied the time dramatically.
And literally, it's a supportive message.
I'm like, nice try, but...
Wait, sorry, I think a reflim was trying to trade me.
Sorry, sorry.
I'm sorry, Brov, yet it didn't mean to not trade you.
What?
10,000 swordfish?
Isn't that not like 99 right there?
Am I going crazy?
Are you sure?
Oh my god!
Wait, wait, wait, another reflim?
Oh no.
Oh my god, reflim.
Alright, I'm getting drunk.
I'm getting drunk as a skunk.
Actually,
I think we're doing drunk stream near the end.
Helps make the job happen.
I literally got like,
freaking 10 kabillion.
Right, thank you, let's go for a job.
Let me drink that, let me eat.
Oh, love the little bubble sound effect.
If I ever make a song, like an actual song,
like a custom made song,
oh my god, 10,000 swordfish.
Oh my gosh.
Right, in order
to make this super simple,
I'm so sorry for anyone who like,
is really good at organizing their shit.
I'm not.
I'm literally just going to shove
all the fish items to the top.
Please don't judge me.
Right, I'm pretty sure that's all the shit.
Raw trout, you as well.
Raw herring, you as well.
And that's cooked salmon.
Oh god, what a bank.
Gee, gee, willikers, I sure hope no one
cracks into a skullfish.
I think members later, it'll get faster.
One morban, literally.
Right, shrimp, we're going to cook
all the shrimp right now.
Unless the fire is out, I think the fire is out.
Okay, wait, no, someone's lighting the beacon.
Gondor calls for aid.
We're just going to clean up our inventory.
I say that as if we didn't just get 10,000
freaking fish, thank you very much.
Desme, I'm glad I could help, thank you.
Bank tabs and shambles, I'm so sorry.
I know people are really good at like,
organizing their tabs.
I just couldn't, I'm just like, in and out, let's go.
She's a hoarder.
But she's our hoarder.
Vsucky is done for.
They can't compete with Vila,
literally.
I bet you Vila won't last until
Vila's stuff exists then.
Isn't it interesting?
It's cooking me right now.
Well, you might only last two years,
but that's still a year.
22 months, 30 days,
23 hours,
59 minutes and 59
seconds longer than he probably lasts
when he touches a woman.
Bro, literally, oh wait,
whoa, whoa, whoa, wait, did you just,
did you just roast him?
Thank you for the tip, Toria.
I was like, oh yeah, yeah, yeah, until you
I heard the very last sentence.
I was like, Brian?
Brian?
Oh my gosh.
That was,
I didn't expect that at all.
I can put this away because there's a kind
reflin makin' fires, right?
We'll do anchovies, we'll do
the...
No, don't eat.
Oh wait, they're cooked.
My apologies, such a fake
gamer, for I cannot hide.
Oh my god, reflies are like starting a
frickin' fire outside the bank.
Wait a minute, I'm not the rock
well uprising.
I was naughty.
I'm not there all the time.
I'm just, I'll put my hand up
and I'll say I'm not there all the time.
I had a little peek yesterday
about what you've all been
anonymously chatting about
and someone said,
yes, Johnny, I understand
Blackwell
headquarters.
And I was like, ah,
that's so fuckin' funny.
So yeah, your comment got me excited.
I just seen someone,
someone's like ritual posting
about Shoebe and it's like, I am nothing but trash.
Under Shoebe's foot and I'm like, yes, yes, yes.
Then the OG
Sands, I was checking the OG Sands out.
They were spoiling, I see.
Absolutely spoiling it. Hey, Johnny, off topic question.
What's your tip
for Germany, Scotland today?
Is there a football match on?
Use logs on fire to make
bonfire, we'll not go out.
Isn't that all RuneScape 3?
I don't think that's a thing here.
What about having
many fires?
Any thoughts on doing an Iron Man
so chat can't just give you everything?
V-Bop
you have far too much
faith in me. I'm not even going to pretend otherwise.
I know I'm not
supposed to name chatters,
but my guy,
you have far too much faith in me to think that I could do.
The only way I could do this on my own
is by picking up
dropped fish in Barbarian Village.
That is the only way I know how to do it.
Because I don't have the funds.
I don't know how to make money in this game.
And we'd be at this for hours.
Squidding me right now.
Since
strong debut, something about her reminded me
of a Pokémon.
It has been on the tip of my tongue for an entire week.
And I finally figured it looks
like a Cray Dilly if it was an anime girl.
A Cray Dilly? Hold on.
You're actually getting me a look up something.
A Cray Dilly Pokémon.
Oh!
I know them. They're in Groovy.
Kill things to make money.
Kill go-
Bro, goblins don't drop money.
The most expensive item
goblins drop is Goblin Mail,
which is 500 a piece purely because it's a quest item.
Thank you, Thierry, for the other tip as well.
Honestly, I could see that.
Yeah, the fossil type.
Goblins are the best.
You're trolling me.
I'm getting trolled.
There's no way you guys actually think that.
I got my first Bond via marbles on stream.
I wish you could do marbles on stream
on
thingy.
On YouTube.
But things are very slowly getting
integrated to YouTube.
But I
I definitely feel YouTube
is becoming stronger and stronger
for streamers.
And like
I think what we're saying
that discoverability
who dare at
DEMPO
I don't know if you're still lurking.
DEMPO goes, I didn't think that far ahead.
What do you think would be cute? I think she likes the kind of
creepier it is. I'll write some creepy stuff.
You were strong, we were rooting for Scotland today
for years. Oh, we're going to do shite.
But it's fine. It's fine.
The life of a Scottish
national
Wait, no, hold on. Nationality of a Scottish person.
Because we understand we're just terrible.
Although we're decent at rugby
I'll be honest, we're actually no rough at rugby.
But the fit ball
The fit ball, if you didn't know
and to say football
in Scotland, you say fit
like FIT. But no pronunciation
on the T. And then ball.
How?
I'm okay with that.
I feel like
YouTube could make discoverability so much better.
See, I think it does
enough. It's Twitch that has poor
discoverability. However,
people disagree with me when I say that.
And I'm like, oh, okay.
I actually thought
Shawnee literally never leaves
her arms until she may.
I just believe.
Bond lid, thank you for
coming. I remember.
Enjoy the emotes back.
The girls emotes have been ordered.
I do have a bit of bad news
about it though. The person
that I get them done by, they're like
it'll take me a month. And I'm like
excuse me?
A month? And they're like, yeah, a month.
Is that okay? And I'm like, I guess.
And then
they're like, oh, but
we've also put the base price up. And I'm like, oh,
okay then.
Okay, that's fine then.
And I'm like, okay,
that's just kind of the worst of all worlds.
But yeah, everyone else
is going to get emotes before me.
I'm submitting everyone else's emotes before me
because I don't think it's fair.
My reeflings, you know how
unbelievably well
behaved you are for me and how patient.
And it's nicer for the girls
to have something to celebrate
because you already know I'm going to be
here every day.
Oh, I was saying
that my first drunk stream
I'm not sure how much people
are going to like this. And I can already see
some of you typing and rolling your
eyes. Keep your eyes to the
front of your head. I don't want one eye
rolling to the back of the skull.
What was I saying?
My first drunk
stream was going to be
a
drunk apex, but I don't go
offline until we win.
But, okay.
How did you time that?
There's a stream delay. How did you
even time that?
Fucking reefling in game said
eye roll. How did you time that?
A 30
hour stream. Oh, I thought that.
But then I was like, would you guys rather
jellybean game? Some sort of drunk
multiplayer game.
So the stream is just never going to end, pretty much.
Apex. Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Everyone is like dunking on apex.
Well, there's other multiplayer games
we can play if you'd rather drunk
that. But I feel like drunk jellybean
is just going to be me like
please, please
please let me, let me
get to the past and first level
please
I don't want to spectate.
And I'll be drunk and hold up.
Why is so much fire? You had drunk
runes. How is drunk runescape fun?
I put the
shrimp on the
fire.
It cooks the shrimp
and my level
gets higher.
Drunk fire cave.
Oh, got drunk.
Accidentally achieved 99
fletching.
Runescape is never fun.
You drink every time you make an alcoholic
drink.
Don't let you get past level one
this time around.
That's what I'm worried about
the true endurance stream for real
for real. Well bank the bank
runescape is a job
but honestly, that's funny.
Oh wait, no, that's kik chuna
but you're unkik
true herring.
Castle wars is
for you play. Hydration, I need
to finish my tea.
Which
yes
I
I've
also planned out
the membership
streams for next week. Again
if you are unable to member, please don't
worry.
Dear little reeflings, I stream
every single day free access.
What movie did I pick?
I think I might have picked
Austin Powers
for the movie
question mark. How are you keeping this
up?
I don't know. I thought you could only have one
or she'll start leaking secret.
No, I shut off about all the insider
stuff now. I'm starting to leak it.
Well, I've not said anything that I've
regret saying. I don't
regret being like, yeah, we
don't need talent managers
because it turns out if you give
it a try.
Actually, I would like to expand upon that
point. Now that you've got me on that
subject, hold on a minute little reefling.
The reason why talent
managers aren't necessarily needed
is because these girls have streamed
and they have plenty of experience.
Who goes there?
And
to
go from independent
where you pick your streams and you pick
everything and then you're on a one week
interval every week to stream what you want.
It just doesn't make sense or it doesn't make
sense to me, okay?
So, yeah.
Sad I'm going to miss the first membership stream.
I mean, you can always go back and watch the VODs.
At any point you become
a member, you can access the VODs
on the membership
strums. I just need to
once I make
the lobbies for them,
I just need to make sure I do it for the correct
membership here.
Holy crap, we're creeping on the next level.
I actually don't know what level we are.
We're level 52. We're about to be
53. We're slowly creeping
up.
Wait, are they flirting? What's going on here?
Agility. Construction
and slayer.
Oh, we're all debating on what... I thought
runecrafting was unanimously voted the worst.
It's
stressful with a manager.
I just feel very strongly
that
I mean, obviously in my instance
the girls in that are happy for me
to say all of them streamed way longer
than me. Why would they need to come
to me for permission to stream?
It just seems rather odd,
you know?
It just doesn't make any sense.
Mooncrafting has
a minigame now. Oh, to make it faster?
I'm thinking of how many watch hours I need
to pack up when I get home though. Honestly though...
I've planned out
the
Elden Ring streams
but
I just realised I might have to delay it by a day
because of time zones. I don't know
if the DLC has a time zone release
but from being
an upside down land
whenever there's an ad for a game
and it's like, this game comes out on this day
and I'm like, well that's a lie
because it's not time synced
because I'm in the future, right now I'm in the future
it's 4am on the 15th
like I'm in the future, you know?
So I might have accidentally planned
my Elden Ring stream a day too early
before the DLC comes out
but then again
we could play it
early. Actually, no
there's not going to be a problem
with being able to be at the DLC anyway
because we're starting fresh
How's the future?
I mean
it's alright
I ain't got much of a quarrel with it
That's a lot of marks of grace
yes, that's going to be
a major endurance stream
back to back
I've planned 4 days
around it
it might leak into a 5th day
but I'm sorry to anyone watching that
Elden Ring isn't your thing
you know?
Arise, you tarnish
Do you have a save file ready?
No, I was going to start fresh
I was going to start from the beginning
yeah, because I like when you guys get to
hold my hand
through the stream
and someone said a marshmallow
and I was like, can we invade?
and I'm like, that's actually what we do
and then one reekling comes in
as an invader or enemy
and it means we can safely walk around
the areas and stuff
I didn't know if I should bring out the shock caller
so every time I perish
you guys get to shock me
I don't know if that's a bit too weird though
for what we're...
I feel like it's more going to be like nostalgia run
of all of us being like, I remember this
I remember that, I remember when we did this
remember when we did that
and then I've just got a shock caller going
every time
every time I mess up
I will probably be on here rinsking
during that, oh I need to finish my tea
I've been making my teas
with far too much honey, it's rubbish
alcohol poisoning
no, I cannot
drink and play rinsking
Elden Ring, there's no chance of that
the shock caller
is with Sin, I actually need to message her
because unfortunately
I need to delay that stream due to
obligations
because essentially week 3
is Elden Ring and then it would be week 4
Elden Ring with Sin and
I think that would
alienate
too many
supporters being like, oh god
get off that game already
you can do it, don't let
you get in the way
don't let yourself get in the way
honestly
I do have a fun update for those of you
who enjoy seeing my hands
I have successfully ordered
the Uwu Market
keychains
and merchandise
I bought my own merchandise
but I got a discount code and all that
I've got the keychains
of all the girls coming
so I'm going to do
a little hand ASMR soon
for anyone
now don't worry this content
will be made public that I'm about to discuss
for anyone who is currently on
Patreon
they got early access to
a YouTube video
which was absolutely outrageous
but I'm just wanting to know
if anyone in chat did
listen to that outrageous
audio and what were your thoughts about it
I'm also using my Patreon
as a big
archive of anything that I produce
sadly
four audios are unable to be
uploaded to it because I was
very dumb
I've made a four part
series
that has hypnosis in it
but Patreon actually doesn't allow
that so I'm going
to upload it on my alt
twitter for free not a problem
I just need to edit it and get out the way
but it means
I'm now missing four audios
raw tuna
that's cooked that's cooked that's cooked
that's cooked so lobster
tuna and then we tackle the
10k freaking
sword fish
this is going to be interesting
I keep running out of love
are the hoodies
no nothing is
limited by ubu market
actually I need to talk to them
again because
Azura is coming up
y'all
why does he not like hypnosis
Mastercard our
unloved overlords
have deemed that hypnosis
is in
consensual for some reason
even though it fully is like you will never do
something that you don't want to do
and unfortunately
Patreon always have to bend the knee
a lot of people have issues with Patreon
but the reality of the situation is
our overlords that we despise
the ones who are on Epstein island
all the time but
deem hypnosis as non consensual
so it cannot be
uploaded to Patreon however
for some
I'm going to say something and this is a bit controversial
but guess what
Elon Musk announced that Twitter is absolutely
fine with that kind of content
so I'm sorry but one up on Elon Musk
because he couldn't give less of a rat's arse
and to be honest
that's kind of what I'm looking for when it comes to
just making content
we're all adults here we're all doing our thing
like there's no need
for all these things going on
but yeah
so unfortunately
it means I have four missing
oh I shouldn't say those words
sorry four inkable audios
so I need to go
record so
I'm not actually sure what my fourth upload
this month is going to be on Patreon
because
originally it was supposed to be
part one of the series
but it's not possible
but yeah did you like the audio
for those of you who are on Patreon
because it was absolutely outrageous
you can probably monetize Twitter eventually
oh you need five million
impressions I'm not sure we're there
unless like well she
stirs
and Mercy
can't get caught in the algorithm
when
this new meta came up
so they actually probably do
have that
but
yeah like
if Twitter is like yeah this is
four I've burnt all of them
I have five
lobbies out of that that's terrible
that was a really rough run right lobbies
we've got 500 let's see
how much we just absolutely
waste honestly
we'll do
it was very unhinged the ASMR
yeah I thought it was hilarious
I was like freaking jumping around
the mic
I was doing like backflips trying to come over
and like get it louder and stuff
do you know how many I put so many
like noise dampening filters
on the audio as well
but the clap was so loud
it was outrageous
um
I don't know if it'll survive on YouTube
but I'll still upload it as a YOLO anyway
because it's hilarious and I don't care
and to be honest I never really
did anything that outrageous because it's just
sound like to me it's like just
the sound of someone clapping their hands okay
it's just what's actually happening
that's a bit outrageous but because
there's no audio it's fine
so because there's no visual
unhinged isn't a negative thing
Sony the audio is the reason
I'll have to
go stuff to see the 7th grade
yeah basically
I did clapping ASMR
but I didn't use my hands
hmm
I want her
well I'm gonna see if I can get some fish
I don't need any more fish if it's for me
I'm sure you've got 10k swordfish
um but yeah
that's the audio I made
oh my god
we've almost leveled up again
that's fantastic
what a genius entrepreneur truly
I've turned
I fell asleep to the begging one
really?
that got so popular
I'm like I definitely hit the algorithm
because
well someone said on one of my
ASMR stream
wait what happened there
someone said on my ASMR stream
that
I was on tiktok feature
page
but Vailer doesn't upload
to tiktok we've reserved everyone's name
on tiktok just in case
but it's more important
to do youtube shorts vs tiktok
like over that kind of thing
um
what liquid you put on your
not hands I heard you spree something at the beginning
oh it's coconut oil
it's oil
in the audio like literally in the audio
you can hear me take off my prel
I left that in on purpose
because I breathed
like heavily through it and I was like
I'll edit this out but then I was like
oh maybe someone would enjoy it
so I just left it in so you can literally
hear me take off my weapon drew
and armour
nudge nudge
tiktok clippers
no like so on tiktok
it's called
a video format is called tiktok
where's youtube it's called the short
and twitch it's a clip
but it's all the same thing
oh I leveled up I got 54
oh my gosh
maybe 70 is gonna be like
way before like at the rate we're
doing these lobbies
um
my beloved
thank you
oh my god that voice crack
70 is fast yeah I feel like maybe
I might have
underestimated how much we're gonna get
the little extra sounds add a lot
oh right so I can actually tell you
the behind the scenes of recording the coconut clapping
let's call it the coconut clapping
that'll be our code word for it
um
the reason why you hear me go
oh and then
I do it is because I had to hold on
to my
my gooblies because they were
bumping
and jumping because of like
in order to make
um your buns of steel
clap you have to like go up and down
quite not violently
but you have to make it quite fast that's something
sometimes I do it slowly and then sometimes
it's like one after
I'd clap that coconut I mean what
the cool thing is
that you can fully unleash the Scottish accent
doesn't mean it tastes like coconut
I mean right now probably
oh I should do that smell trend
I keep forgetting coconut clapping
like 1 to 5 of them
if you cook at a range next door you're burned
I can't be bothered moving though
I want to stay with my reef limbs at the fire
I was gone for 5 just strong
he died no I'm level
I just came to realise I've probably
severely underestimated that we're
achieved 70s this stream
we are most likely going to have
a lot more than that
um
aggressively clapping coconut
well at one minute I was like I feel like
um saw
I think I said saw but what I meant was
jaws that shark like that
because I was away I went
walked further away from the microphone
and then came closer and it was like
ding ding ding clap clap
ding ding ding clap clap clap clap clap
it's one of the most
ridiculous audios I've ever made but
I got halfway
through editing my
first
1k thank you
oh wait I've got salmon sugar
I didn't notice that salmon there wait I'll finish
off the salmon
um
I got halfway through
finishing my first like 1000
special ASMR and it's just
me rambling
and doing tingles it honestly
probably feels like a live stream like when I
just start rambling whilst I'm doing tingles
but like I was having so much fun
like um being like
guess what this is oh my god
this is actually a sponge I don't know if you could
guess that type thing like I was just getting
so excited so it doesn't sound
like ASMR again
from the aster
tuber
like 92 is halfway to 99
XP wise okay
oh dear lord
this is going to take a little cheeky while
um hi
hello thank you for joining
don't worry 70 isn't even halfway to 99
hmm
well I wanted to try and finish it in this
month because I had on week
4 I had 2 back to back
runescape and I picked
the movies I'm like 99%
sure we're doing John Wick
all of John Wick
series
um
if I burnt a singular
salmon
we'll do all of
John Wick
month long cooking stream honestly
anonymous
thank you
thank you Brian
honestly
I'm freaking hilarious
like you could hear me
do it
oh thank you for the super chat
your boy Stephen Adams
holo n fan
what do you mean
b-boys in your favorite holo n
the way she was going to call her fan page
bebelpales was hilarious
I can't remember it wasn't bebelpales
was it? oh no it was pebelpales or something
it was absolutely hilarious
um I remember
being like
she said what out loud when she said
that I was absolutely he ho in
um
but then she couldn't keep the fan name
and I'm like it is probably for the better
people but you're absolutely hilarious
please do not change
um
is this the cause? the worst
the tuber is
for their manager the better
literally
oh well I tell you
I won't tell you
um
but yeah
literally it was hilarious
isn't that what everyone jokes about
pipa they're like oh pipa is such a headache
for her manager
how is self management treating you
delicious I don't have to do anything
literally the girl
as far as I'm aware the girls are happy
they can pick what they want do what they want
unfortunately
because
Azura and Emi
are on a warning
um
by juicy youtube thanks to their
hidden ASMR update guidelines
um
I am does say thank you for the tip
and on this
thank you for your tip
um
oh
unfortunately I've not
I've kind of discouraged them
for doing ASMR until the warning is up
because it's very dangerous
if they get a strike um
I'm like brav
youtube please
I'm back
I got distracted oh don't worry I'm literally here
for 12 hours don't worry
we're doing an endurance today I have had
so many short streams this week
it felt so weird
like I do have a lot
of time to like finally start editing
I have a heck of a lot of vtuber
ASMR collabs coming through
I wrote an ASMR collab
for two the girls would be allure together
um
and
the girls
one of them reacted
and thought the plot was adorable
it's just super basic short plot
I never want to overwhelm the girls
with anything that I assign them
so please don't think it's like some super mega
do do do do do
eh
I know that there is a collab with Mercy
that's both audio and
um that's both audio
and we get to play this game tomorrow
um not tomorrow not tomorrow
next week next week
um I am going to play RuneScape
before it because
I am going to stream on
Mercy's time zone like when she
normally streams um
so basically we're gonna play RuneScape
for a solid
chunk and then I'm gonna go offline and
rest my voice for like an hour
or two no probably
two hours because I'll be in voice call
with Mercy one hour before
eh the collab if you didn't know
it is common courtesy for vtuber
to show up one hour before
eh a collab which is where you
do all of your um
technical
failures as I had with
flipping
eh again special shout out to sheebie
for keeping my head on my shoulders
I was panicking when
we could not do up
eh
she's grinding so fast
baby won't you
grind on me
relax your mind
turn your time
with me
that's all I know of that song
I got one cake
carambua
when you start cooking
members first
I have like
10,000 swordfish to go through
I have no idea what even potential
xp that might is
that might is ok well
one you're done what english was that
eh is that a threat or a promise
eh I was gonna
do marshmallows
actually I got such nice
marshmallows you guys need to stop being so nice to me because
if I get emotional
and start reading them I start getting
teary eyed and I'm like I can't handle these
right now because it's gonna like make me cry
like happy tears
so you guys need to stop being so nice to me
there's currently a reflin
ehm
who's keeping me updated about their addiction
right now and they're like
I don't even feel the need to go back to my addiction
I'm like oh my god you're kicking your addiction
I'm like how are you
what how
like that's amazing like I could get
into the nitty-gritty of like how insane
addiction is and look
your brain once it creates
a neural pathway it likes it wants to keep
repeating that it's nice and easy it's why
nostalgia is so powerful because you don't
have to like learn the new lore of something
it sounds silly but
ehm
like it's very easy
to fall into addiction
and especially
your makeup your genetic
makeup can make you predisposition
for it as well it's quite it's quite fascinating
because it's like it's kind of like
gamba like I spoke previously
I had a
advertisement offer
of four thousand US dollars
to insert a 60 second
gamba ad
and I said no because
it's gamba
but it's very interesting
how
severely gamba seems to
affect individuals
now this is just an observation
but whenever I've seen
gamba ads that are like stop when the fund
stops a ten thousand
swordfish should get you to level 78
let's go
oh my god 78 by 9 to the stream
ehm
whenever you see a gamba ad that's like don't
is like stop stop when the fund stops
they always show a guy
and I'm wondering
ehm
is the predisp... not the pre
the socialization
because obviously if we're being
very stereotypical of society
we live in a society
guys are normally more interested in sports
and is the
environment around it that it's normal
to gamble
and kind of like put a cheeky
10 or here on this
bet a 20
quid here on this bet type thing
before it snowballs out of control
it's quite
fascinating I actually had someone
in real life I knew
that
they weren't a family member but
they were like an acquaintance and I learned
of their story
and basically
the guy gambled away their mortgage
and
it's just
it's such a shame what kind of grip
it has
on certain people because for me
right now I
I am
I'm like confident that I don't have
that kind of addiction
I
it doesn't appeal to me
I would walk away
like angry that I wasted
my money type thing like my brain
doesn't go oh
if I gamble again I'll make back
what I lost like no my brain's like
I'll waste the time that was I'd rather play
like a video game or something else like that
you know
I wish I could join you but not on RuneScape
wait what's wrong with RuneScape
it's old school
look these are all Reeflings we're all just hanging
out outside the we're all hanging
out in Edgeville for no particular
reason
um
yeah sorry I don't know if
I need to turn down the
that sound
effect
I'll turn down the sound effect just because
it's very repetitive
but hopefully you can still
hear it but
sorry
we're in Edgeville together where you can do better
90% of gamblers quit
before they've been big now I have seen those
memes I have to admit they're a wee bit funny
but it is
just a very curious
predicament that people seem to get themselves into
I mean that's kind of what
kick the website kick.com
if you heard about it
the only
reason they are able to be fueled
so high is because of
Gamble
there's no other
reason and it's perfectly
fine to say that
but it just kind of goes to show
you how big the house always
wins if they can offer this business
model on the side
I don't know if you guys remember
when Twitch officially announced
it's like banning Gamble
it's just very curious
because
there's a lot of
discussion you can get into and you can say
well the person that's Gamble
and it's their money
it's their life
it's their choice
but if like
I'm trying to think
and do two things at once and it's not coming out in a sense
so
is it the
hold on let me put my sense together
when is it not a choice
when is it not a choice is the question
why is it it's addiction
and not a choice when it comes to
Gamble but it might be
a choice when it comes to other bad actions
you might do in your life
why is Gamble marked out for one
why is alcoholism marked out for one
obviously when it comes to alcoholism
your body does change the tolerance
but you could argue the same for Gamble
because your brain literally
lights up like fireworks
when you win
and it's just very
interesting because where's the line
drawn from someone is consenting
to do this activity and someone
isn't able to consent to do this activity
because it's causing harm
you could argue sitting on runescape
for 12 hours well that's causing harm
oh well
we'll need to take her offline
because she's not well because she's doing this
for 12 hours because that's bad
for her health sitting for 12 hours
type thing you know
do you know what I'm trying to say out loud
I struggle to say the words
thank you for coming
I'm a member tier
destructive behaviours that have historically
been deemed as vices that's where it is
yeah like
we're being called out literally all runescapers
getting called out from across the line
wow we're about to level up again
oh my god just let me do
one ramble and we're going to be
99 overnight like just
give me one subject to ramble about
and we're done there is a logout
timer after 6 hours I will
most likely log me out when I go for the big job
but I don't need one right now
but yeah
in college maxing on runescapers did it
on homework real
the lines do get but well that's
it's the interesting thing it's like when
where do laws come into place to protect
gamble
gamblers sorry
because when you lose
your money you're told tough
tough bananas
yay 56
yatta
when you lose all your money you're told
tough bananas
when you lose your money to scam
the bank says see tough bananas
but yeah there's laws in place
to protect you in quotation marks
and to get the
scammers put in jail to get
well you can't really put
casinos in jail so that doesn't work
that's a terrible
comparison
hmm
well I've kind of shot myself in that
line of thought I've completely undone
that line of thought there I do apologize
um
there's really
no good answer no there isn't
that's the thing
that's the thing that's the thing I want to
highlight there is
no answer and yet
we still have some laws such as
you know obviously twitch isn't
law but twitch is a reflection
of the community views
or the views of the masses
now do you remember
when a
pokemon was like yeah gamma bad
and then all of a sudden twitter blew up
and then twitter was like
gamma bad and then twitch was like
okay now we'll remove
gamma like
that is a perfect
example of
the most basic movement
now don't get me wrong movement isn't world changing
but it is the basic example
of someone who definitely
is on a larger platform
going hey this thing
bad and then everyone going
wait a minute yes
this thing is bad
and then boom
twitch
got rid of the category
and outlawed it and said no bad
now that is
and just
a bloody perfect example
of how
the community
in specific areas and pockets
do have a voice
and do have a say
as much as you might not think on an individual level
you don't have a voice
it might be true but have you ever seen
planet of the apes
monkey on own
weak
monkey together strong
it is true
you can't even deny it there's so many examples
of this
like think of revolutions
such as the french revolution
one individual would get their head
guillotined ok
I'm not being funny I'm being so
true this is my rabbit hole
but like literally the french
revolution one person stands up
and gets their head chopped off right
no revolution no movement
community is not you know
community is not going to rise up
but hold on a minute the people are revolting
the people
are revolting the masses are outraged
how can society continue
if everyone bands together
and
historically every 400 years
society
shifts and what do I mean by
society shifts something new
comes up for society to be
a part of ok
so before capitalism
which is when global
economics became a thing ok
like kinda the industrial revolution
global economics there was
region locked capitalism
ok and it's called feudalism
or something like that it's like
it's not feudalism it's like feudalism
ok
which was when
lords owned
the plots of land and permitted
peasants to generate food
on those lands ok
that was region locked capitalism
before we know capitalism today ok
but that got outdated when
the revolution came in
because you know
people learn fast to
grow certain crops and if you breed
crops I can't remember who did the crop breeding
what's his name
ah sugar I
forgotten feudalism
is with lords yes yes
the chickens are revolting
finally we agree on something
bro it's not 400 years it's like a decade
stuff changes all the time
but like another massive example
shift in society and you're not gonna like
some of yous are not gonna like this but
you're in for a rambling stream
you know you've got me for 12 hours as if
I'm not gonna get on my high horse and teach you history ok
if you
did not know
in Christianity
there's the old testament
and there's the new testament
the new testament
is was created
I believe in
roughly the 15th century
the church got together and went
look the old testament
isn't doing it for the masses
people are starting to question that
because people are becoming aware
that you know
some things aren't working out in the
story
and basically the new testament
is just
friggin made up
years later after
Jebus the source supposedly
passed away
you're so right Strony let's eat the rich
yes! fun blue thank you for the two
like some people can't conceptualize
the difference between a million and a billion
dollars
now take that million and add one
and then add one and then add one
and then add one and keep going and keep going
and keep going and keep going
anyway
casually red fill in the masses
I'm not kidding I will keep mentioning
in the game
needy streamer overload I cannot even believe
they put that in the game that kind of thing
okay
but anyway
anyway that's just me
I don't know what you guys are thinking
but that's just me
but I could really get on my high horse
I should actually I want to do an education stream
about feudalism because
and like kind of
how history and how society used to work
because bargaining used to be how it was
done! bargaining used to be like
hey I have
two weeks would you
trade me one potato for two weeks
that's how it used to be done
that's how there was value in things
that's how humans did it
and and freaking
there are
there are some examples today
of it kind of thriving
and
so runescape is historically
accurate yes! you guys
trading me right now
you are calling upon your ancestors
to give me the resources that you don't
need in the moment you are looking
after me and in return
I will scratch your back later
it's literally why I'm such a big believer
and you scratch my back I scratch yours
because that's how it used to be
return to monkey
replays return to monkey
we were so nice
we had some communities
we had said it's a belonging
it's so nice
the old test schools
oh right okay you're done
out of curiosity
I've not touched old school runescape
what's with the cooking not cooking window
on the top left so I am using
a plugin called runelight
you can see it up here this plugin
can track your things
there are good bad examples of this
one stick is weak
many together are strong
like the 1940s
monkey
thank you very much for the tip
I appreciate it but get a name
and bonzlo thank you for the super chat
um
but just
literally you guys are
what? who?
dash oak
I mean
a bit of netherlands in the chat
um
stupid work meeting now I can watch
oh my god there are netherlands people
wait
give a bond
so that no members will try
will you do that now
or later
reading that is so funny
questions from you
exams later is good
later is good
netherlands talking
on my chat
more likely than you think
here
Anders
I don't mind
netherlands talking
ha ha ha
Scotland being germinated
I have no idea
I probably not I think
wait are these reeflings I don't think
what did you say about my mother
I don't think these are reeflings are they
are these reeflings
smile
I like that I am in the message
very charming
just dreamed just joined
how's stream going stream is going amazing
I have rambled my
bruh I have rambled my way
through four levels so far
and ran it so yes we're still 3a
I'm not sure
we could all be Dutch I can't
believe it the netherlands
I don't know
Dutch first but
how are you doing
I am
hungry I am hungry
I love you
that
that I want
that you play
runescape
with me if you please
reefling
bye
there you go there's your Dutch
for the day I ain't got any more
Dutch in me so that's the best I got
she's casting black magic
strongy opens her
analytics it's suddenly 99
Dutch
netherlands
what the fuck good pronunciation
I'll try my best
right 57
we're getting there so quick
also in Flemish
it's Flemish
the Flemish
is like
Dutch, German, French
mangled and mashed together
can you yodel
yodel
bruh I was watching Azura
on the telly after stream
she was
karaoke on her way to herself
I was like damn you got some lungs on
your lady
she's been fantastic
honestly
wait what no I didn't mean
to do that I don't need the collection
box my apologies
right we have finished the salmon
we will be back to lobbies
er
what about you
how many languages you know only
English and technically
Scots is a recognized language
but I am
a Scottish
oh that was another funny image
aww but I couldn't say that
when I was playing Assassin's Creed
Brotherhood someone did a
text post and it was like
be me pic related 1500
some
mumbling assassin comes my way
it keeps me in my balls, keeps rambling
walks away or something
but I couldn't save it
I want to save it because it's a funny meme
I like saving the memes that you guys make
because it makes me so happy
why do I keep clicking that one
oh my cat's outside
Gimli you're not coming in the day
that was ridiculous yesterday
I shouldn't have let her in
because now she thinks she can come in
all the time and I'm like Gimli no
we can't come in so she's just going to have to
save my door until she gets the message
I'm sorry Gimli
I'm sorry
the last time she played Stardew
she went karaoke for 5 hours
she has endurance over her mummy
literally she was on for like 8 hours
the last time I checked I don't know when she went off
um
do you have plans to get membership
oh I already have membership
I'm just playing on free to play so I can hang
up all the reflins like check us out
look all these reflins
we're all just hanging
we're all cooking
wait you guys aren't cooking
oh you're putting more logs on the fire
but I'm cooking
oh thank you
thank you fireman
cabbage patch head is doing something
I don't know
oh we've got just an echo
we're linking the fire
oh I understand
but yeah all the reflins
I didn't want to alienate anyone
if they can't do members at the moment
and we're not cooking
wait a minute
we're not cooking
any membership items yet
so we don't need to go in a membership world
a lot of reflings gifted me
a ton of fish
so I'm just powering through that now
and
another reflin
gave me 10,000 friggin sword fish
I don't know how long it's going to take to get through that
I don't know if that might actually take us
to the end of the
stream
10,000 fish
since a lot
you betrayed Gimli I know
you don't know French
I've been lied to
oh sorry Miser
I can't
I can't do it
I can humorously do
what are you doing today
what are you doing
I can do French
Scottish
just to mess with you
but the actual French
speaking
like
I'm trying to think of a sense
to say
Montichons
Machichons
I think is French for my
Yiddies
oh my brain
my brain can't parley the French right now
it's too hard
my roommate that showed me
your content just DM'd me that
because of that super chat
they're like I know
what you are
oh Gimli
I can't have you in the room
she's just gonna
go back to sleep
I was playing with my
cats before a live stream
to tire them out
but I couldn't play with her too long
so she's currently going nuts right now
but she'll go down for a sleep because she wasn't sleeping
when I was sleeping so she'll
don't worry, don't worry about my pooders
and whenever I go make a tea in that
I'll go give her some attention
baby boy is really independent
though he's like not
caring I don't know if it's because he's half
a munchkin that he's more
tired than the usual cat
you can get depending on the breed of your cat
it can be really tired in general
and need like more sleep
I'm pretty sure there's a type
of dog that's known for sleeping
oh wait it's Greyhounds
Greyhounds are like the laziest
dog ever but they can do like
one burst sprint type thing
21 million
literally I got sugar daddy
out the wazoo because of reeflings
they were throwing them coins
to me I was like I'm not gonna say
no this is gonna fund the
I don't know if we're doing wine
I don't know if wine is the fastest
level up once I've
like cooked everything
if I push it I can finish
my first save file in November
oh I haven't even finished a save file
I was considering doing some eating runs
just to show you guys what
the binding of Isaac
is all about
who needs a bot farm
when you have a cult giving you everything
you need literally though
when I had a Saint Bernard
it felt like it slept for 20 hours a day
yeah like depending on the breed
but she's just moody
I fed her and I played with her
mouse but
the problem is because I let her
in yesterday
she now thinks she can come in whenever she wants
you're a bit of a diva
Gimli you're a bit of a diva
I have to admit
but I love her
I love her
you're always cooking
oh I ain't just cooking a runescape
I can't
tomorrow's crash bandicoot
yes
I think
July streams
I'm gonna focus on Xbox games
to get my gamer score up
I've done
decent progress on my goal
of collabing with 100 vtubers
with a 3d old thing
like 3 ASMR collabs
I have absolutely no issue
with actually collabing on stream
yeah good luck with that
I'm too shy
I've made great progress
I think I'm just shy of
6 ASMR collabs
and then I need to reach out
and do
I want to make all of my goals
happen before the one year mark
which means I have to work hard now
and
so
we've got membership coming up as well
because we've got a lot of lost time
to make up for but I hope
you can see with my efforts
and all my hard work there
I'm making up for lost time
it's going good
I want content out the wazoo
I want it to be
good funny times
literally uploaded that meme ASMR
please let me hold it
any plans for halo?
yes I would love if I could actually
do
a vtuber collab on halo
but I don't know
anyone who's played halo
I will ask the vlo girls
first before I ask around
and see if anyone's played halo
not that you need to be
good at halo
to play it like you need to know about it
but I'd rather
I think if you're playing a nostalgic game
I'd rather like two people who are
familiar with it play
I know that sounds really rude I hope it doesn't come across as rude
but I mean
I'm sure there's another halo vtuber
that's freaking good
random question are you playing any drg streams?
what?
drg?
what's drg?
sorry you're gonna have to spell it out for me my brain is very slow
I
you'll like to
check
who?
yes I think I can play with you guys
just as a word
or a word of warning
it's not a word of warning
ac snow paws is live with
space channel 5
part 2
and imibizu is live
with the coffin of andy and leily
and she's doing an endurance stream
I'm so proud
as my cat is currently kicking down the door
oh my god
she's getting that really frustrated
um
but yes
I think
I can play deep rock galactica
with you guys and it's not an issue
at all
she's trying to do the good ending
sorry there's only one ending and andy and leily
and I will not be taking any comments
I don't even
I'm
there's only one true ending
and I won't have it
any other way
me trying to hold in her
oh god the peeler
we literally can't outrun them
that gartic phone stream was so fun though
the girls are so funny
um
but yeah
the
already leveled up again
literally I am rambling through these levels
like nothing on earth
like I wake up on the other side of the ramble
and we're literally 58
that's fantastic
oh my goodness
all these lobbies
I'm burning them a wee bit but it's fine okay
you and emmy agree hard on that
ending yeah
literally I'm sorry but why on earth would you make
why would you
why would you play the game and be like
uh I'm not gonna do that ending
no the whole point is to like
be fine with human curiosity
like as long as you don't produce any offspring
no one gives a rat
anyone geyser
honestly
hmm
halo would be a fun way to do community games
uh like the halo molly player
I never actually played much of it
I heard
the bat
was it a halo battle pass came out
and it was just an absolute shambles
like it was just a terrible multiplayer
launch
and then they did battle pass
and then it just became
like this terrible
thing I don't know
what ending the one
true ending
oh actually I was
lurking quite a lot someone was like
wait I don't get it are we emmy's brother
the reason why you can see
emmy at all times when she
streams is because you're her dead brother
watching over her
I will spell it out for you
you are her
dead brother watching over her
which is why you can see her stream
which is why you can see her thoughts on twitter
okay
I'll spell it out for you
the pin pals I don't get it
hold on hydration guys
hydration please hydrate
hmm
very important
oh actually
tomorrow's crash
bandicoot but I'm 99%
sure buckshot roulette
is after and it's like a super small
game
if it's a small game don't worry
I'm going to you whenever I do
like a two hour stream just know
I'm cooking in the background like trying to edit collabs
or get a collab together
or do something for the girls
if you didn't
hear the good news she be cotton
bum is monetized
and oh the poor darlin
she tweeted out how it was like
a childhood dream
and she was like crying happy tears
and stuff and I'm like oh my darlin
I'm like I'm so happy for
I'm so proud of her like I'm so glad
that she can see the results
of her hard effort already pay off
em she be
has said this before so
before anyone's like oh you're not supposed to
that she be has said she has
an in real life job and
I am very much hoping
she can turn around and be like stuff that
job up your arse after one month
so please don't be afraid to sign up to
she be cotton bum's patreon
that helps her immensely
any merch sales oobu market
got back to me and they were like
wow
the aces fans
and mercies fans are
absolutely like
I'm gonna send her out the wazoo
and I'm like I am so glad
so please don't be afraid to
support the girls via oobu market
they get 100%
of the income generated
dealer do not take a cut
and the girls can attest to that
we don't have anything to do with it
and it completely
and wholeheartedly supports them
if you wanted to
collect all the key chains of the girls
that could be something very sweet and cute
I'm gonna make an ASMR of me tapping it
with my little fake mermaid nails that I
showed on my hand cam stream
um
uh but yeah
she be love yeah she be
oh she's basically a lean
I'm so
glad that the girls can see their hard
effort like pay off right away
um they've been nothing
but fantastic they really have
um is the
merch limited no
it's gonna stay up um
until
until we expire oobu
market has been absolutely fantastic
to work with um
they are super good
I am aware that
they got a bit of flat because of some production issues
but they actually
moved um
they moved locations
quite a few times because their business
expanded so fast that they basically
had growing pains but I
have never personally had an issue with them
now I know that's kind of being like
well you never had an issue with others that's
just dismissing the others relax
I understand how it works but
um to work with oobu market
they've been they were so understanding from
the get go because I messaged them
and I'm like hey violers
the thing I'd love it if the girls can
keep a hundred percent of the earnings
uh we as the company
don't want to take a cut and they're like yeah
we can set that up no problem and I was
like here here's all the references to the artwork
yeah we can do that no problem
um and just they've handled
everything and it has been
really nice to not have
to deal with anything it makes things
nice and juicy and easy
um
uh one of the thing
few things about violers the lack of
corporation greed yeah I just
I I mean
scrawny scrawny can your
patterns go in reverse
no they can't they can
they only go in reverse if I
do that it'll like
should yeah see how it goes in reverse
it's because it has to reset
to the top of my head in order
to do that reverse thing
we can test that again
yeah see how it reverses to the top of my head
that's to make sure it works thank you for the
ten barrel you know you could
ask that for free uh you
guys don't have to ask questions
via um
money uh
it's not necessary
it's really not necessary you don't have to
ask questions via money you're more than welcome
to ask in chat or on marshmallow
if you want to do it anonymously please don't worry
um
but yes um I am
a very strong believer
in um the girls
earned the money they get to keep the lines
share um
because I don't
I don't think it's very nice
if the girls were only
earning like the standard 50-50
rate like what's your motivation
to work if every time you make
100 bucks uh management
take 50 for doing a fall
other than like handing you
the model because at this point in time
it's kind of like
again egan
excuse me I have a question
bruh you didn't even put anything in it
thank you for the
the super chat
you didn't even put anything in it
do you have a rave party with your hair
Neil I can't do anything else
with my hair other than the toggle
I just like hearing my name spoken
with a Scottish accent you should teach others
how to speak like that I think it could be a thing
well she be starting to
develop a not a pretty decent
Scottish accent
um I don't know how much
she used to watch me wink wink
um but
she certainly gives the impression she's listened
to me for a decent amount
but when we were playing garlic phone
and I was like oh when the
Joby hits your prostate on the way out
um
and everyone was like what's a Joby
I'm like oh my god I really need to put a
game together and teach these girls
just letting you know I'm tiny cuttles in
games oh tiny
spainy
oh
yes enjoy work I'll be
online when you get back
thank you so much for the tip
as well tiny spainy
that's how you told me to say it
so I'll say it that way
I was in Mersey's chat
and the snippets were baffled by what a Joby was
bro literally I'm like oh my god
Danny I do the Scottish slang stream
I wouldn't
mind doing a Scottish history stream
that would be quite fun but
I've got the Scottish game show on St Andrews
Day
and like oh yeah that's right I can't do the
Scottish stream until after
full lobby no burn full
lobby no burn let's go
full inventory no burn
I don't know if I've achieved that before
but oh let's go and we've
just finished the last of the lobsters we're going to be
on swordfish duty boys
Jack that isn't even a question
purple burglar
get it see I can say it if I'm not
doing heavy slang purple burglar
alarm but if I like
save together it purple burglar alarm
oh I bet you want to turn on my purple burglar
alarm yeah that's right
let's go
are nor clear
right we are
officially tackling
the 10
thousand
raw swordfish
we'll see where we are in an hour
right let me how it was
passed 22 minutes passed
okay give us an hour
and see how many swordfish we are
because I don't know how fast I can
like get through these
thank you for the super chat
Jack yes I draw me
oh is that the thing
Scottish cannot do
yeah it gets caught
my tongue gets caught on the roof of my mouth
to try and enunciate burglar
burglar burglar
the box at the top left
tells you how fast
a thousand a thousand
per hour so we will
finish the swordfish I think
we might be able to finish the swordfish
if I don't get distracted and don't need
like to go make too many teas
I think at the three hour mark we'll take
a toilet break
and I'll get some food because I don't have any food
in the morning like I just
I wake up and I come on stream and I'm like
alright what's going on that's what we're doing
um
with a steady pace
you can do one an hour
one K an hour
that's that's pretty good
that's really good
right let's whittle this down
to nothing then by the end of the stream
we'll finish the stack of swordfish
and see what leaves is that
can you say hamburger
hamburger
yay
who the hell are you
I brought a new
what was that I caught from
why why we're about to level up
hmm
it's strange
that in these days um what
brian
brian do you talk
I didn't whoa 59
I didn't hear brian talk
I wonder if brian doesn't talk during super chats
brian
brian start talking
during super chat
thank you for the 5
good luck literally though
brian is the name
of TTS for anyone
wondering who the heck brian is
the name of the text
to speech voice you hear
when someone very kindly gives me
the tip
his like the actual
name is brian of the function
I don't know what the name of the other versions are
but his is brian
which is why I always go brian
when someone does
a
a very kind
yeah
wow a guy wearing a skirt
so femme boys so kawaii
an extremely distressed
scottish lad
killets are always the first thing
folk hone in on but
you only wear killets during
special events like weddings are
probably the biggest kill thing
is gimme inside my door
gimme inside my door
but yeah
oh I wish they had a
kilt in elden ring
so
so then you guys can show up in a kilt
and we can all get married in elden ring together
that would be cute you know you're not
supposed to wear boxers under a kilt either
easy access
gimme I'm pretty sure gimme's going nuts
outside my room right now I'm so sorry
you can hear him yelling
she gets attention
I promise
baby boy and baby girl get attention
we're already
at the 10.3
we started at 10.5
strongy shows up in elden ring like a blue
power ranger I'm
scottish
like that dress from ds
worm it's for the ventilation
literally you cannot
get swamp ass via a kilt
congrats
um but
your tatty bojangles
will be bojangling I think
I don't know how elastic
yeah okay gimme lays me
on out my door I can hear her go nuts
she might start hammering on the door
because she opens him by
going up on her back legs and like pushing
with her front paws so if you start hearing
like that's her
currently like opening the
well attempting to open the door
but I think
you need to listen to this song
donal where are your truzers
it's a joke song about kilt I'd play it
but I'd probably get copyright
ridiculous oh my
burn rate is 9%
well hopefully that can get lowered
because missing out on 10%
xp on full inventories
is rough
but we're getting there
so how do I use it on the thing
ta da
let the boys be free
as nature intended
true yes
I love wearing a kill always makes me feel confident
I remember that one scene from the carry on
films where the scott shows their
to scare
to scare people
I'm sure it probably
like get it up here
I got the skirt
18,000
to climb a level
we're starting to get there
where it's taking
a wee minute
but that's okay
we've got lots of time
we've got all the time in the world
but yes
I'm going to let
the girlfriend begs you
to hold it a some more video
cook for another day or two
because it got boy
no
emi
emi thank you for keeping me up to date
with what is
emi doing is she still
endurance in it or did she go for a tinkle
thank you for the
the tip as well boy
she loves holding her pee
I mean
I know
I am aware that it is
an interest in certain individuals
so
whoever those individuals are
I'm glad you are enjoying your little sister
tormenting your little sister
okay
she peeped and then went back for more
peep holding
I never tell you that time
someone paid me
sorry let me rephrase that
someone wanted to pay me
$200 to stream
but I drink
like bottles of water every hour
but I don't go to the toilet
like it was their thing
like they wanted me to be like
ah I'm so full
I'm so full
basically and I was like
honestly good money
unfortunately I regret to inform
I did not
carry out with such a request
however it was rather
interesting learning about that because that was the first time I had ever been exposed to it
thanks everyone
if you don't wear underwear work out people call you a true sportsman true
the big brothers were too we can let her go once
bruh as soon as Emmy
starts begging sorry I could never say no to
like any of my daughters
I can't handle it
as soon as they ask for something I'm like anything for you love
like for Emmy I completely
forgot she was waiting on me making a script
for her
and like I was in the middle of like doing like
10 billion different things at once like doing business
business business and she's like
oh what about this and I'm like
oh yes my daughter I completely
forgot please forgive me I'll update you very
shortly and like I gave her the
script she needed and all that
and I literally
can't even say no to them I don't think I've ever
said like oh
so you're saying
there's a chance it's not
you was it you
yeah calling yourself out
chat
gonna do some slaver
we'll leave the main here oh
Slayer sorry
slaver is what's coming out my move
because I can't stop
salivating right now even though
I'm like super dehydrated
but there's a tactic
to me being dehydrated
it means I don't have to pee as much
and then I can be here and max out
the swordfish run
yeah
cuddles you're too subby you're not a good back
corrector oh no they they get their way
I'm sorry they all get their way I
couldn't as long as they're happy
I'm happy I get
I genuinely get a dorphins
knowing that they're happy or they have
what they need and that's all
I'm all I'm thinking about
and I am excited for
Emy's
Toastream I know that sounds
really odd as a sentence
but I want to see her little toes because
her hands were freaking adorable
on her cooking stream
and
Mercy might be doing a
hand cam at a later date
so I'm excited to see that
I'm like oh but does everyone's hands
look like I feel like my hands are
so like login
scully all
but everyone has like such beautiful soft
looking hands and I'm like oh
for again I know icy hand
cam streams gonna go nuts
I'm like you know in another life
I'm probably
you know I want to be an OG
stand up with it oh I keep doing that
I want to be an OG sand like up with the
hands but I'm
pretty sure icy has like totie
hands like totie means
like minuscule tiny
wee
like she has I'm pretty sure she's got
totie hands as well oh speaking of icy
hello
hi icy how did your stream go on
your um your space channel
5 I'm gonna be honest
I've never heard of space channel 5
um
but that's
yeah
hi snowberries hi icy please
do rest icy if you need go to sleep
please feel free to sleep
she's got doll hands probably
yeah I was just saying to them
icy that when if and when
you want to do a hand cam stream
I already know your hands are like
so freaking precious and tiny and adorable
um
I was saying that a
a me is sorry twins
um me is
in her foot cam stream this week which is
hilarious and I can't wait to see her little
toes
to nibble on um
absolutely terrible I'm so sorry
me I probably say the worst stuff
about me but it's
because
I'm biased
towards Emmys design the most because
it's like if I had a lighter voice
it's everything
I want to be
Gimli
you need to give up it's been like an hour
now
icy ended up doing a full
that oh
did she answer all the OG suns question
the
the worst part is is that
you're not even sorry I'm not
hi snowberries um
emy bezu is currently live
if there's any mods
that can do a link to emy stream
emy is currently live playing the coffin
of Andy and Lele I believe she is
about to finish up the last chapter
and get the correct ending
there is only one true ending to that
game please do feel
free to check out emy the now she's probably
doing something much more interesting
because I am currently
ranting and raving my head off
whilst we are cooking and burning
the absolute everyday lights out
of these swordfish um
we currently have a stack
of 10,000 swordfish thanks
to have an incredibly kind
refling literally spawned
in gave me it and then disappeared
he's gone
he's not even hanging about he's like nah
I just have fun with the swordfish stack
um so
yes snowberries please do not be afraid
to check out emy she's doing something a bit more
engaging a bit more fun
um so please do not do not be
worried at all about yeah I'm gone
alright alright sorry sorry
there you go Morgan Morgan
um yes
we are just doing
99 cooking
we are currently 59
um
and sorry it must have been a refling
mentioned in the money they gave me in chat
I'm sure I read someone saying yeah I gave you that
and then what
we are 59 cooking
we have a stack of 10,000
swordfish which was which was not
cheap at all not cheap at all
we are currently cooking through that
and I am ranting and
raving my head off
just about anything
and everything
but yes I was currently
gushing about the girls doing hand cam
streams now that she
is monetized I actually don't know when
she's doing her monetization stream
hold on let me just
let me just ask her
when are you
doing monetization stream
cause I might need to put her monetization live
um
oops cause I've not put her monetization live
and before you're like wait you control monetization
no in order for the girls
to be less stressed I do
the kind of boring stuff
which is opening up memberships and setting
the price and adding her emotes
to her badges for example
um hey fart head
hey shit
sorry um
yes so if she
be plans on doing it
day I will have to quickly run away
for 5 minutes and quickly set that up
because I don't have access to her account
on the cc
your cash is 20 times the cost of that
swordfish though I know but I didn't do
anything for the cash or the swordfish
I just came I just got here
um
wow level 60
wow
that's amazing
frickin 60
how many are we burn
or burn percentage is going up
oh cause I know swordfish is a bit harder
than what was cooked
we are still doing
1000 an hour
it is possible I will beat
the swordfish stack before
um
just saying the chat that
gave you the JP is 20 times
killer than me
um
yeah basic management stuff
yes
I'm putting their stuff live
probably after the stream
um because I need it to go up
24 hours because
so youtube says they need to approve the membership
tiers but they don't approve
nothing they literally
um can go for it
level 99 by the end of the stream
trust just doing endurance stream right after
closing the endurance stream honestly
uh
I could never do this
I'm just giving it a shot it's always been a childhood
dream of kind of like
reaching 99 in any level
as you can see we haven't even touched
any of the member skills
but um
my combat is so low
but literally having it up here
is really nice um
and I picked cooking because
um I have incredibly
baby memories
of me being outside
the back of lumbridge castle
and I had
my pickaxe
I had my tinder box I had my
my little basic bronze
sword and I used
to um kill the big
rats outside the back of the castle
cook them and I think
the highest cooking level I ever got
was 40 as a child
um which is
just freaking adorable which is
why I want cooking 99
first because I've just enjoyed it
literally these gender norms have hands
of course the whamen picks cooking
oh we're about to get to 9000
the stack is getting
weir it's getting smaller
getting a wee wee stack
burnt swordfish is probably
worth more than cooked on the open market
these burnt food collectors are pretty
oh I'm aware about the burnt food
collectors um
and they just give you a price for it
which is pretty crazy
um fire making is
probably the next fast this is
winter tod yes
that was a ghost fires in winter tod
or am I making that up
I might be making that up
I'm gonna be honest
I might be going crazy
uh my current level
is 60 on the dot
I did title the stream
70 question mark
but someone did napkin math
and said if I finish cooking all these
swordfish I might be
78 which is just
fantastic truly
um
but I thought the cooking
thing was a meta meme like mommy knows
how to cook here is the proof
I mean honestly we could do it that way as well
but I kinda did it as like oh these gender
norms have hands I just really enjoy cooking
like I know there's
this in real life runescape chick
and she has massive knockers
I'm talking a zero level knockers
and I used to just sit and watch her cook
lobsters
and like so many people would come in the chat
and say such horrendous things
when would it be the best food for winter tod
so we keep
oh gimli give it a rest
darling I cannae have you in the room
she's
she's losing it
she's losing it I don't know if it's coming up in the
microphone or not but she's losing it
and this is
I shouldn't have let her in because now it's gonna take
a couple of days for her to unlearn that she's
allowed in this room
ah gimli I can't hear her
okay she's currently behind the door going
meh
basically
um
she should have given up by now
and it's been
it's been quite a while
she should have gone to sleep I'm gonna be
honest
I should have played with her more
I thought I ran out of time because I was making a cup
of tea but I did feed her and
I threw the mouse a few times to give her a few laps
around through her dog
she's not a dog she's a cat
heaven forbid some tatas
admit it we're all gimli
I was kind of
I was like talking to
um Vigo
and
he gets really excited when I finish
a stream
and I was just talking to him and I'm like
oh baby boy and I was petting him
and he was purring
and I was like I need to
I've got two baby boys I've got
refling and I've got baby boy
Vigo
and I need to split my time
between them
between us
so it's really adorable
he's such a good boy honestly he's like
um
de-refling are you there muggers
get to that man whoever de-refling is
because he'll give you jewellery
um
cute female kangaroo called Gimli
she's a refling too never give up
but she's got the
she got that dog you know
real cat girl is someone from
Gimli when I was actually
gonna do an in real life
video where I put
um
a licky lick on the 3d o ears
and then both my cats will lick it
I don't know if YouTube will be weird
about it because I
don't know what's going on with your lickin in YouTube
right now it's absolutely terrifying
um
I don't
oh I keep messing that up
sorry oh my god I'm not
time maxing okay she's now knocking on the door
Gimli
don't do that
ah
mommy's no impressed Gimli didn't he do that
he didn't have litter in yesterday
it opened a can of worms
oh
um but yeah I thought
can we see them the next hand cam
you saw Gimli's back
in the food
in the celebration stream near the end of it
you saw Gimli come in the room but had to take her out
she was gonna knock over the webcam
um I do have a picture of them
um
they killed a rat
um so I thought
Gimli was the hunter but no
uh Vigo was the hunter
he caught a rat
in the garden I didn't even
know it was there
and he destroyed it
so quickly
um I'm pretty sure he like
so if he didn't know
the way that cats hunt
is they apply pressure on the throat
of the prey
so basically
it gets either suffocated
or you know damaged
out which is a shame to say
Vigo
I let him out in the garden
and within 10 seconds
he had perished
the the rat
I didn't I have a picture of it I'll maybe post it
but I know people don't like seeing dead animals
so maybe it's not too nice
maybe I'll put like a little black bar
over the rat's eyes just to
protect its identity you know
and it respect its wee family
um
damn though put it in me base
cat almost
stalks you honestly
um
wait cat almost stalks me
are you that fucking fanny
honestly if you are go and just leave me alone
um
but yeah we
uh
we Gimli we Vigo
um
is there somewhere we can
send cat pics I mean you can just
at me
it's fine on twitter
uh
honestly honestly
my cat is being a menace to the local bird
population it's illegal
to let your cats outside
in Australia or
I don't know if it's just in
Victoria but it's illegal
to let them out
so I have a caged off
background
which is such a shame but I'd rather
they get outside time than know outside time
at all because I actually don't think it's natural
for cats to be inside
um
but yeah they made it illegal
Australia does have a wild cat problem
oh my god it's so sad I wish I didn't
learn about it but they basically
call wild cats instead of just
doing capture and release because it's
like so out of control type thing
and I'm like
bruh bruh
although it's kind of like learning
about cat island in Japan
there's a tourist state island
called cat island but the problem
is none of the cats are
fled or looked after or new urge so the
population is completely out of control
oh my god Gimli
she's
doing my head and
oh my
god
Gimli
I know you guys might not be able to
hear her she's going to absolutely
desert right now she should have given up
like a long time ago and gone back to sleep
what have I done I've created a monster
because nobody wants to see
mushroom no more he's chopped live
I don't know the rest of the words
I'm back
baby
um
oh my god I can't think when she's
me on wait hold on
right she be I don't need to
do her monetization
okay I don't need to worry about sheepsters
but I will be putting
me and AC's thing
live
praying that a speller member names right
but I'm pretty sure it's
snow bear ease
and
pin pals
snippets to me and
moose
should have picked any kind of youtube
to be further driving the birds
extinct yes I just think
it's very dramatic
to not only cast it
you've been telling me I've been breaking the law for the past
23 years and didn't know
yeah like apparently it's gonna slow and
England just made it that your cat has
to get microchipped now
and I'm like interesting
but what's
the real reason behind that because
is it just like another tax on pet
owners
oh if you're a pet owner and you need
to use litter by the way like a litter box
you know how it's really
expensive for litter box
like pellets and all that
play sand
cats love to take big massive dookies
in play sand which is the cheapest thing
ever it lasts so long
especially if you can have an
outside litter tree for them if they have
access to outside
you will save literally hundreds
upon thousands of dollars over
the years
it costs 8 dollars
for a bag of sand and it costs
20 for a decent cat grit
just give them sand
they love it you can scoop it
it's super good
and it saves your pockets
so much money because
there's such a tax on pet owners
the only thing I haven't figured out yet
is how to get good quality food
because
I was actually thinking
of making like homemade cat
the fire
is gone no
rifling what happened
wait let me pick up the ashes hold on
wait I can't I've got too much swordfish
wait hold on hold on
I'll pick up the ashes and take them out the way
I need to put them out the way ok
now the ashes are out the way
no the embers have went out
I've just picked up burnt fish as well by accident
slim cuttles
or strong shady
excellent cuttle sounds better
always thought it would be cute to have a big
chunky cat
oh well thanks for the tip
I can't even remember what the tip was
thank you for putting the fire back on again rifling
it's over
they didn't kindle the fire
now it's the age of darkness
crazy concept
go fishin
the riflings would happily taste test
your homemade cat food yeah
I wanted to make homemade thank you for getting me back
on the subject because I completely forgot
what I was rambling about
I
wanted to make homemade cat food
because they were struggling to eat
like that pre-made stuff
and the thing
this sounds really bad
but on the boxes of cat food
it says not fit for human consumption
ok
now the reason why that
alarms me is because I would never
want to give my cat something that I couldn't
eat and cats eat meat cats are
wow 61
thank you
thank you riflings for funding my
cooking habit
yeah I just find it
a bit hmm
and sus
that
it's not fit for human consumption
when the content is just supposed to be meat
that's possible for
cats to eat
which I don't like
VV buys a rotisserie chicken
cats didn't like
I fed them it
you know who liked
more than my cats
the magpies
which I've yet to name
it's
a husband magpie
a wife magpie and a daughter magpie
that visits me
oh no
rifling
is the rifling afk that normally does
like the big log pile
wait I'll clear away the ashes hold on
there you go it's out of the way
I keep clicking collect
bank banker
take that out then take it raw
ooh we're at 9.8
fire fire fire
we're so on fire
praise the fire praise the sun
pet food in general
is a rarity
affordable
mmm it's like ridiculous pricing
as well like I'm not happy with the price as well
but I thought it would be really cute
to make like
homemade cat food for them
it wouldn't be the best but like I've seen
this youtube channel
I think it's called June's Kitchen
and it's literally dedicated
to feeding the cats
gourmet homemade food
and it's the most adorable thing ever
and I'm like that's what I want to do for V going in
cats are hyper carnivores
yes carnivores
I almost said omnivores
but omnivores is both
what's vegetarian
wait wait
oh sorry I did that I was pre-firing
I got excited there ok we're now
9.7 let's go
9.7
oh hydration check
my voice is starting to waver a little bit
herbivores that's right that's right
herbivores for dinosaurs
is
vegetable
hmm
oh dear my voice is breaking
and we're partly even got started with the injured stream
you
just friendly reminder
in the link in the description
M.E.B.Zoo is live with
the coffin of Andy and Lele
a very fun and unique
experience video game storyline
and plot very unique absolutely no one is denying that
hmm
I'm lucky I work as a cook
I just bring home
food for leftovers
and it's free most of the time
yes oh my god
when I used to work as a waitress
the best part was like getting sent home
with like all these treats and food
and aww it was so good
it was so good
oh man she's almost at 6k
so am I
wait what happened
I was 5
thousand yesterday hold on
hold on
let me do a new batch of
where did we celebrate
5k wait how popular
did that freaking ASMR video get
am I missing something
I matter
hold on
wow
that ASMR video got 18,000 views
I only have 5,000 subscribers
what
what happened
what did they get picked is there a
tag it got picked up on
hold on wait I can
ah I can't see if there's a certain
tag it got picked up on
what how bizarre
wait let's see what the analytics say
okay that
top traffic source
browse feature
other youtube features channel page
suggested videos and external
what's browse feature
is browse feature like in the feed in general
hold on let me do a new stack
sorry I know you can't see the stats
I'm looking at
is browse feature just like in the side
window
probably hit the algorithm
it was good
oh
I'm at 6k I've not even done the first
thank you celebration
what oh wait
hold on let me screenshot this so you guys
can see what I see you can see
I'm not
I'm not a secret
kind of creator I'll show you what I see
this is what I see on the video
it hasn't updated the
where is it
it hasn't
ah
that would be too easy wouldn't it
image make source
this is just youtube stats
video I guess
okay
and then pick this one on my desktop please
is that it
this video
wow
what on earth
do you see that
holy
what on earth
that got pushed so much
look at browse feature
76 percent
browse feature my goodness
but look
it says I got 300 subscribers
for it the money hasn't
updated because it takes like 48 hours
for the money to show
wow I did not expect that
the fact
the watch time is 1.8k
hours if you didn't know to get monetized
you need 3k watch hours
holy crap
maybe
maybe gen 2 should come out with an ASMR
video before debut but kind of ruins the
voice although saying that you hear the voice
in the trailer in the shorts anyways
that much of a deal because it might help with the culling
if the girls came out with an ASMR video
for gen 2
nice when quality
is rewarded but look at that
a browse feature
source that's pretty
that's pretty nice
sorry my tummy is rumbling if you heard that
literally I've not even got my first thank
you for 1k out yet
oh
oh my god
yeah whoa
I'm 5800 I literally
tweeted like thanks for 5k yesterday
holy crap
that's insane
your trailer hooked me pretty hard
yeah you're like I'm Scott
oh yeah
oh cloud he's Scott
win win
well I wasn't lying during debut
and I was like you'll be eating good if you're an ASMR
enthusiast
it's unlikely
I'll get that first video out today
because
I'm doing AC and Emmys membership
when I get offline
and then I'm probably collapsing
unless although I will say it's really
fun editing my
thank you videos because
I'm like
I'm not making it super professional
and like editing out all the bumps I'm just
lowering the bumps in that so it's still
like on the same level
the culling was so silly
it was absolutely insane
on AC
I mentioned this yesterday so don't worry
if you didn't hear it but AC
got called
1500 subscribers and on the same
day I got called 700
subscribers even though
she had more shorts out like I was
pushing shorts on AC
at the time
that's just crazy
do you love a cheeky bit of ASMR?
it was so rough on AC
but she's been doing fantastic honestly
I
am
still interested in a clipper program
for the girls
I'm just waiting for
the first month of income to come in
and then I can kind of open up pie charts
and be like right is this
going to be possible
for Vehler to do a clipping program
like Idol N has done because I really
like it I think it's a really good way
to get clippers involved and
help promote the girls
and all that jazz I think it's fantastic
so we are still looking into that
and hopefully it will
give the girls a cheeky boost
I've had to re-sub
three times yeah like every really
I had to freaking subscribe back onto the girls
at one point as well I was like bruh
we were literally all each other's first subscribers
and I got booted off and I'm like great
you've stolen it from me
you too
absolutely stolen it
I hope those missing 1,500
would you sans find their way to her
honestly though
I'm sure they will I'm sure they'll be like
hey wasn't there a cute polar bear around here
at one point
if you interact with the content
leave a like on stream
or leave a comment
then the algorithm will show the girl
more to you
so if you are an OG
you're like her streams are never showing up
please do consider like
just going on her short feed
for example
don't like the stuff right away
genuinely sit and watch it because if you don't
sit and watch it then the algorithm
knows that you are just sitting there
it's really annoying
but the algorithm is now too
advanced
because before way back
and much older youtube days
if you left a like
you left a like
but now the algorithm is like
this person left a like at the 2 minute mark
maybe something interesting happened 2 minutes in
ok because of that statistic
we're going to now
promote this video to
people who
have interacted with this vtuber
the algorithm just gets so
silly
I'm dying for the hypnovis
the hypnovis
can actually go on youtube
youtube allows hypnosis
patreon doesn't
make it make sense
but we love youtube out here for that reason
it's very
strange
probably the first hit
sorry
take this burnt swordfish
the first
ASMR I'm going to do is
forget your name
and replace it with reefling
I will not make it a permanent
effect
I will make it a session
I think maybe a 30 minute session
if you will
and I'll maybe give it like 2 hour
effect I really do not want to
mess around with permanent effects too much
it kind of scares me permanent effect
stuff I have to be honest I'm a bit of a scaredy cat
ooh our burn percentage
is up to 15
I think it's holding
steady at 15 though
and hopefully it'll lower as we
get more leveled up
wait no hypnosis no
hypnosis is ban
it is a bannable
offense
suspendable offense if you will
there was
a ASMRist actually that got
their entire patreon taken down
not even a chance to
appeal or
get suspended and then delete the content
sometimes patreon will suspend
your account until you
your content
applies to their tos so if it's not
too offensive whatever you've done or made
but
there wasn't ASMRist recently who got their
entire thing just taken down which was
pretty crazy
just making me permanently less procrastinate
yeah honestly only a bit of mind break
I feel you
yeah a chubby
weight gain that got
taken away
which was crazy
absolutely crazy I'm not sure
I mean I
I can see
why because sometimes this stuff is
like tied down to a chair and funnel fed
or whatever but
it just gets ridiculous because whoever's
participating or creating especially
for when it comes to audio side of stuff
like no visuals no nothing
like it gets pretty ridiculous
like that you can't
do it like but anyway
all hail her master
card overlords yes yes
yes yes you win yeah again you win
you win again
hey ho you win again
um
who's thinking
up all these rules and restrictions are overlords
don't you not know about them
see there's this company called
black rock and then there's a second
company called I've forgotten the name of the
second company and they own everything
um
and uh oh wait until you
learn about politics oh my goodness
can't wait to get started about the
political side of thing and no I'm
not getting into politics but I'll get into
destroying the economy and
we should restart society
or run away to a farm together
I'm more opting for the farm
side of things um
because
yeah the farm would be a heck
of a lot better option
um
CNC is not okay with Patreon
which hit me yes the
oh 62
thank you 62
it's nice to see you 62
um
but yes um
so people
from an outside perspective think
hypnosis
um
you don't do anything you don't want to do when it comes
to hypnosis I am a full believer
in that I absolutely do not
think but because of the way
it seemed comedically in the public eye
like for example when
a magician does hypnosis
oh look they made this person
drink a bottle of vinegar
type thing um because
it's seen that way publicly when the
reality is when you participate
in an alternative context
you do not do anything you don't
want to do this is a fact
it's just how it works
you like people
seem to think like you completely just
like oh you're inhibitions
you can't control anything you're so
like no mother
that's not how it is
all reeflings pull together and put a money
in a oh should we buy
a castle
should we where should we
what country though I want
to say a castle in Scotland but um
it's very hard to although
saying that if we had a green
glass house a greenhouse
then we could have tons of
um produce
maybe we should get a castle in
Scotland
and then we can have a big garden
and we have like we feast on the meals
every night and we can try and make
me for the first time
black rock van garden
those are the names quick tooth
um squiddle kingdom
anyway if I can't get a span because I've started
talking about black rock it's been a good run
yeah make sure you support the girls
all hail our overlords
um
yes um
we can try and learn to make me
but I feel like I'd poison everyone
if I did it
oooh someone just leveled up
congrats
15.8
did that go off I thought it was 15.3
I was hoping it was going to go down
it was fun
it was fun while I lasted it was
let's go castle with a farm
could you imagine
we all have our little bedroom and stuff
and then when we need gen 2 to be made
we just turn the lights off
and see what happens
hehehe
mmm
I just want to say some things
but I refuse to say it
that might get you banned
shove it in my marshmallow then
show me what I want to see
mmm
I want to cultivate
tea
oh my gosh and I can make honey tea for everyone
and then you guys get to know what honey tea
tastes like when I'm always like oh I want honey
and you guys can make me my special honey tea
see there's honey tea in general
and then there's special reefling honey tea
I need special reefling honey tea
because my throat is perishing and I'm sure it'll help
I could just fill a vitamins
mmm
oh vitamins yeah
so we need that as well because apparently
it's full of vitamin
what vitamin is it full of
is it vitamin E
you need to give me your vitamin E
reefling come on
come on get it out
wipe it out right on the table just like that
hehehe
mummy needs her
mummy needs her special honey tea
although I should actually
write an audio like that holy crap
why have I not done that yet
I'll do it this month because there's a myth in there
oh I just really started really hard
I said myth in there if you hate that
oh my god there's a myth in audio this month
I'll make that plot
the audio this month please
can I make that the plot for a patreon this month
where I need my special honey tea
oh my god yes
I'm in February
I know February is so far away
but I actually have a meta audio role play
month as well
but yeah I'll make it my missing thing
I do want to care for a little garden
yes so
there's a lot of hardy plants
so hardy plants are considered plants that can
tolerate close to frost
or very low temperatures
these hardy plants
are things such as potatoes
leeks
these root vegetable type things
what's another root vegetable
turnip very big
neeps and tatties
is turnips and potatoes
these are very successful
hardy plants in Scotland
so these are probably what we'll focus on
and make up the main majority
berries
strawberries
and blackberries for example
these berries are actually
quite successful in Scotland
against all odds
because
they're quite resistant
which is really quite fascinating
there's a lot of
strawberry production and manufacturers
in Scotland if you didn't know that
a little fun factoid
potatoes
boil and mash them stick them in a stew
and we make a big dinner
and we have nice yummy dinners every night
a carrots
yes carrots
fantastic example a ground vegetable
yes yes yes
wow
9.4
about to hit 9.3
about to hit 8
we're getting so close
gollum would be fuming right now
leeks are a winter crop
yes
and we can also have garlic
we teach you about the drying process
of garlic as well
but we would need a shed for that
surely one of us reeflings
or DIY can make a shed
although oh my god
we're getting two steps away from being Amish
at this rate I'm not even being funny
because the Amish are known
for building stuff really fast
but I'm sure if all of us reeflings
came together on the castle farm
we could build a shed
we could teach you all about garlic
you need to dry out the garlic
because if it's wet it will rot
but if you dry it out successfully
the garlic will last an entire year
from harvest season to the next
it will last an entire year
absolutely fantastic
and we need to get massive freezers
to freeze all our produce
so we can do massive meal preparation as well
how big of a shed are we talking
it would need to be decent
I'm too scared to learn about canning food
because I've heard about
it literally perishes people
if you mess up the canning process
however there's one process
I really like and it's
D
dehydrated food
so you're left with the dry
husk of the food
basically but I trust that
and apparently that stuff
lasts 20 freaking years
if you put it away right
dehydrating food lasts 20 years
I'm like
oh my god
this is just me being a weirdo
I absolutely love the idea
of a zombie apocalypse
don't get me wrong I will perish within the first few days
I will be bitten
I'm sorry I'll just admit it there's no way
I'm not that good
trust me I'm not that guy
but I really like the idea
of having food reserves
and like
I think they're called a bug out bag
yes a bug out bag
I freaking love the idea
of a bug out bag and all this
food that's good to go
is it MRE kits?
I wouldn't mind trying an MRE kit
taste testing stream that would be funny
like a hand cam MRE thing
that would be
curious and then we can
judge it from different places
apparently South Korea has the yummiest
MRE kits
America has neutral
I think UK is neutral
maybe France might have something better
MRE
clogs your intestines oh no
does it? I don't know
oh like space food just add water
yeah like space food
we can try space food as well when we try the MRE kits
rating MRE kits live cam
I just rate it
and then like say like a bunch of like
stereotypical stuff about the nation that I'm
waiting
my life wouldn't change
if a zombie apocalypse happens
just close in the house
if we're still in yeah I really
like the idea of dehydrating
food because it lasts
years which is just a
mind boggling thing to me like I absolutely
love the concept of it
I just find it so fascinating
that we could preserve food like
if you think of our ancestors
who had to live on a yearly crop
basis and like if your
crops were messed up you were in
trouble you had to find a trade quick
like if you were a lumberjack
and you cut wood or you sold
I don't know you sold yourself
but
that trade really didn't
still doing it today baby
keeping my ancestors proud
if they're
lumber probably
fire choppin probably
root harvesting like harvesting
mushrooms from a forest like if you knew
what ones didn't hurt you
it's like 4,800
calories shoved into a box I wouldn't be
surprised wait really maybe
I should eat our MREs
because I don't eat properly
recently I've been really
I don't know
reflin reflin reflin
do not tape
doom
do not tape doom
I will talk to you
openly and honestly
I've been struggling to eat a little
bit until things settle
down
I'm very happy to say my A-bomb
has calmed down
it has calmed down
it was preventing me from eating properly
basically
I could start eating
but then I got adrenaline burst
which stops me from eating
I'm not hungry when I get adrenaline burst
but I'm very thankful to say
it is subsiding
I've managed to eat a bit better recently
but no doom
no doom
okay
9.2
we're doing it
the stack is going to be gone by the end of the stream
mark my words
you keep activating our worry mode which is why
what level are you now
level 62
62 which is fantastic
no doom here
we're only winning glad to hear you're eating
but yes and I think
because now the girls are getting monetized
I feel a lot of relief
a lot of
like all of it off my shoulders
because I was worried
that the designs that I had given
Shibi and Azura are going to prevent them
from earning money for a month
but it's not happening
I'm so happy to say it's not happening
because Shibi got monetized
which is absolutely fantastic
truly fantastic
I am very happy about that
please take care of yourself
yes I am doing fine
still feels like doom stop it
reflying stop it no doom
it was because I was so worried
about monetization
because the girls
um
I've kind of said it a lot of them
are wanting to move out
and I think it's
actually very possible
after the first month
but we needed youtube monetization
just to really elevate it
because and the thing
with youtube monetization as well
is that the vods can be
the vods
the streams like if someone watches back the stream
well the girls get
some of the money from the ads as well
so it's like generated free income
you do not have to actually physically
you know hand over money to the girls
because
you generate money for free
watching their asmr's
their asmr's are going to go up shortly
and I forgot to do mercies I'll need to give mercies her
so that's what I'm doing
I'll put emmy and aces membership live
and I'll put mercies meme video unlisted
so she can upload it whenever she desires
and I'm gonna doom
no
no don't doom
how about a tiny speck of doom
why would you doom
everything is going so well the girls are getting monetized
emmy and aces
are about to do their celebration
mercies celebration was fantastic
someone was gifting her 50 bombs
which was insane
no doom in on main
literally no doom in on main
like everything
is just going so fantastic
like I tweeted out like thank you for 5k
and I was saying like all that
self doubt and everything is just
melting away overnight which is true it has
like
generate money for free
yes oh my god
please don't ever feel bad if you can't
genuinely like give money you don't understand
like you interacting with posts
you're promoting them more in the algorithm
em
you're watching their asmr
you're watching ads that goes to the money
the girl gets money for that
em like
please don't ever worry
if you can't hand over money
that's why I always say
oh I'm always streaming for free
you don't have to be a member
like the membership stream start up next week
but you don't have to be a member to consume at all
em
type thingy
I care about you and the girls too much
I'm always gonna worry
I was worrying over them I was like
full mummy mode
thankfully I got an 8 hour
sleep last night
oh my god
it's why
I probably sound a bit tired
I woke up at the last
possible minute for stream
not because I don't love you because you guys
always go oh mummy's late she doesn't love us
anymore no
I took medicine to
put my ass to sleep
and I got a full 8 hours
and I'm so freaking glad I got a full 8 hours
I'm like oh I feel so good
it feels so good to get
a full 8 hours of sleep
em
but yeah mummy loves us
is the mercy meme video
be a problem did youtube
unlist it no it's not out yet
I need to upload it to her channel
because I subtitled all the
meme videos
em
edgeville bank
that was to the theme of 64 zoo lane
which is a british tv
show or it was
I don't know if they make new episodes
but yeah
so if we like commenting streams
that helps yeah it helps
like immensely like
so to give you an example
ic does an asmr stream
you like
that stream and then emmy
does an asmr stream you like that stream
youtube goes youtube
algorithm goes hmm there's
a connection between these two girls
they've both done asmr and this viewer
both enjoyed them to leave a like
and then the
algorithm goes hmm
this other youtube
user both enjoyed these two
girls I'm going to start
recommending this user
these girls
and then it's kind of a knock on effect
so
em youtube
will recommend
someone who's never consumed ic's asmr
before because they liked
emmy's asmr
and then that also goes
further ahead to other vtuber asmr
is for example the algorithm
is like an insane
tangled spider web
of a mess
and anything you do
will affect it so
for example
if you
go on twitter right now and you type in
emmybzu and it'll pop up her twitter
you've just affected your algorithm
on youtube because unfortunately
em websites
completely cross platform everything
whatever you type in even
if you go to rule 34
and type in the girls name
you will affect the
results of your youtube browsing
experience because
of what you've typed in on other websites
as well
em
it goes very deep
but unfortunately your websites are
all interconnected whether or not you want
to whether or not you say
no to cookies no to this
they are connected it's undeniable
em
does youtube listen in the chat too
so youtube will
see you interacting
with me on chat and it'll say
this user like strony will
funny enough this other
vtuber is like
strony I will recommend this person
strony
another version of strony type thing
sorry I'm not very good with my words at the moment
em
we'll probably we'll get we'll do a
tinkle and a refuel at the 3 hour mark
em
I'm definitely gonna make another tea and I'm gonna get some
yummy snacks
em
I bought a nature valley bar
and I'm like is that the worst snack to eat
on stream there's just gonna be dust everywhere
and you
stop looking at me misspelling your name
how can you not
strony kittles
strony
kittles
strony cuttles
how can you spell it wrong
but yeah like literally if you
go on twitter
and you search
vealour
again you're manipulating the algorithm
when you go on youtube odds are you'll probably
have a few more vealour streams recommended
to you on your page or down the side bar
because
the algorithm knows that you have an interest
in vealour it's it's it goes so deep
unfortunately cookies are just
websites are such
liars being like oh we don't track you
via cookies only the essential ones
you liar
you liar it's just the way the internet is
these days we're just such shame
for the last
week I've been getting ads
regarding the Scotland
honestly
come visit Scotland
Scotland tourism
industry come to
Edmund
actually I think Edmund is the most
more expensive than Glasgow although it's
probably
a small amount of
different so if we're watching like
Scottish VTubers we should get
more Scottish VTubers
I actually don't know about
getting they're like
super rare I'ma just say this
on behalf of all Scottish VTubers
right now a lot has to go wrong
in your life in order to become
a Scottish VTuber
now to become a VTuber in general
that's perfectly normal if you're any other
nationality if you're Scottish
and a VTuber
bruh whatever happened in your life
I feel for you hen so if you're a Scottish VTuber
listening in I feel for you hen
don't worry I went through it too
you know
I
am only aware of two other
Scottish VTubers
unfortunately they are not
for me content-wise
definitely not for me
but that's just my
being me
definitely not on the same page
when it comes to
thought process
or like
how we were raised and all that
you can kinda tell when you
hear someone talk
you can kinda tell the way they've been raised
in Scotland which sounds terrible
sounds almost classic so I'm not trying
to be like that I'm just trying to be like
I don't know you can
you can tell when someone doesn't
gear and then you can tell when someone
geyser and I
much better with people who didn't geyser
you know
so how do I infect other people's
algorithm
I suppose
the only way you can do it
oh we're almost at 8k
is
by posting
YouTube shorts in particular
in locations where it's appropriate
so just that you're in a general
VTuber fan discord
if someone were to watch that short
fully
you have successfully infected them
algorithm-wise
because
they consume that content
it's fascinating
and honestly I actually am quite interested
in the infection side of it
but yes you can successfully
infect someone with the veiler virus
I am
sorry I just read that comment
yes you can infect someone
by doing that if they have never consumed
veiler content
but you
maybe make clips of the girls and they click it
for the first time because they got recommended
or you post in a discord that's appropriate
to post the VTuber stuff
or maybe a VTuber read it
actually they're
I think there's
so
veiler do have the veiler read it
but it's not being publicly posted yet
but I don't know
I mean literally I was just going to put everyone's
oh sorry
this is why I can't talk and think at the same time
there is a possibility
of just posting it for memes
but we were going to have to put it on approved posts
only because it can get nasty
pretty quickly
and I do not want any of the girls
to be subjected to anything
nasty
let's go infect some
replays
I have no idea what you're saying but I'll take your word for it
thank you
it's Edinburgh a bad place no it's not
it's just more rich
and
sometimes rich people
are not very empathetic
but that was such a mean and nasty
generalization
when I say rich people I'm talking like
multi-billionaires
type stuff rich
the average duo everyone's empathetic
but if you're not very empathetic
please don't worry I'm actually going to do an
educational stream on human nature
and empathy, empathy is a practice behaviour
you need to practice empathy to get it
you need to
flip the switch
and be able to have abstract thoughts
about empathy as a whole
and I'm actually going to challenge you guys
and I'm going to
make up scenarios where you need to be empathetic
and you need to give me a reason
why you feel empathetic
but I'm going to make the scenarios super hard
so at a glance you're like
that's disgusting behaviour
but
we have to learn to be empathetic
and we have to think about why
the person may have behaved that way
it'll be an interesting concept
either the stream will go terrible and everyone can laugh at it
which is fine I don't mind you guys
or I'll have to laugh at my stream ideas
because I have pretty bizarre concepts sometimes
oh man we have a place like that too
in Milan, never got Milan
so it's like London but smaller and prettier
it's pretty old, it's pretty old
there's a lot of older architecture
Edinburgh is turning people
into an English city in regards to the most posh people
I definitely feel more comfortable
in Glasgow
and good old Glasgow
mutual comfy
and then
I'm going to pull the lever and make everything worse
what does that mean
the Scottish accents kind of come from
wealth and class
so the more slang
you speak statistically
the more polvo you are
and it's completely normal to be
in poverty in Scotland
the statistics are 1 in 5
children are growing up
in poverty however
I actually think the statistics
are in 3 now
so it's completely normal
to be impoverished
when you grow up
it's absolutely nothing out of the ordinary
no one's rich type idea
I like that, I like human psychology
that sounds pretty interesting
are you trying to get us to empathise with some scoundrels
no nothing bad
but I want to
oh no
oh no the fire
pick up the ashes
I will clear it
oh no you've already cleared the campsite for me
thank you refling
wow we're at 8.9
we are getting through it
oh look I burn
you dancing
who's dancing back there
I burnt 98 lobsters
because I had 500
hold on
thank you fire maker
you're so on fire
in hot hot hot
you so on fire
anyway
look at the drip, I forgot about my drip
my goodness
look at the eyes, that is hilarious
that they're just blobs
I love this game
that's so good
I heard a lot of good stuff about Glasgow
firepaw, flames, yes
it's currently British
only a thing, wait sorry
isn't current British English only a thing
because they didn't want to be associated with the nobility of the plagues
yes
there is a very viral clip
that a guy
is being interviewed
and
oh god what was the word
I can see the interview in my head
it's an English interview
and the guy speaks
what we call posh English
and then the guy replies
tomorrow, that's it
the guy goes like tomorrow
and then the guy replies tomorrow
and he's like not trying to
correct him but he's trying to be like
wow look at the difference in this
regional accent
but the problem
with it, it's not that problematic
relax before you're like well steady on
you've got blue hair haven't you, nah relax
I ain't got blue hair, can't I
if anything I'm the opposite of you
the kind of thing
with it is because posh English
accents are associated with wealth
are associated with grammar
schools for example, a grammar school
is a rich person
school, high education
school, public education
is kind of associated with
not necessarily pro but if you can't
afford public education
you can't afford it
so the guy was like
look at this accent
this man clearly
you know, wasn't
educated in a grammar school type thing
and that's when it becomes a wee bit of an issue
received
pronunciation
it's them also calling it the queen's English
just finding out it's not
Glasgow
it's a shame
it's fine if you accidentally
name a city wrong like Edinburgh
Edinburgh is normally
pronounced Edinburgh
by
folk who don't come from here
that's perfectly normal
I'm sure I say all these locations
in different countries wrong as well
like Arkansas is Arkansas
and like Mississippi
and what's another state
in America
Rhode Island
Colorado
I'm sure I say it funny so please don't ever be embarrassed
if you say it funny
I always said Glasgow
but in the regional dialect
it can also be Glasgow
don't ask why it's Glasgow
it just is Glasgow
Texas
I'm sure I'll say
I don't know if there's some locations
in the states that I can name
Anaheim is a place in
California
because they hold
conventions
I'm pretty sure there was some Anaheim convention
at one point
if I ever visit the UK I'll go to Glasgow
honestly it's such a nice
although Edinburgh is pretty good for
tourist stuff like the Edinburgh Castle
and the Edinburgh Museum
are pretty close together
did you say Wales is associated with
Posh? No, Wales
is associated
with the mining towns and all of that
and the
Welsh accent
I can't do
what is the Welsh accent?
I can't think of a Welsh
sentence to say
to start the accent
a bit of coke
and rum please
the only example
of Welsh accent I have
is this little Britain
skit where the guy's like
I'm the only gay in the village
because he was so proudful
he'd be silly that guy's
or that girl or that lass
and he's like I'm the only gay in the village
that's the only exposure to the
Welsh accent to be honest
which is absolutely terrible
all of a sudden we're drifting up to the
Northern Ireland
Heavenly Father who art in heaven
hallo to be thy name
today we're gathered with the reeflings at Hedgerville
we're currently cooking up a storm
with swordfish but we still have a high
burn rate
100% now are you joking
why is my burn rate getting higher
I'm leveling up
Wales is associated with sheep
I will tell you
the reason why Wales are associated with sheep
it's illegal
to steal a farmer's sheep
it wasn't at the time
many a year ago
to have
actions with the sheep
which is why
people would pretend
that they had had
action with a sheep
instead of stealing it
because you can't get arrested for actions
but you could get arrested for stealing at the time
okay that is why
poor Welsh people
have to deal with that stereotype
and it's such a shame
because it's not true
you just need to know a little bit of history
to understand a little bit more
Aberdonians
profusely sweating
what is it
Aberdeen
absolutely short in behaviour
stealing was the death penalty
yes okay
that would be it
it was even more severe than I originally had anticipated
I shan't be in Scottish
I'm getting the football off
I said
oh my god sin I have bad news
I might have to delay our collab
into July
because of work reasons
and each of our agency reasons
you'll have to forgive me but I do have my shock
caller for it
but you're going to have to give me some time
I shan't be in Scottish
we're level 64
and we've got a total level of
150, level 2000
here we come
I'm kidding we are not doing 2000
there's no way
I'm not even talking to you ever again
sin I'm sorry
I'm not freaking kidding
um
uh
oh no
I've just went in the discord
someone's getting banned from someone
everyone's chat for being annoying
oh no
reflans I hope it's not one of you
someone's getting banned
Shawnee had to reveal to me
live in front of millions that she hates
no what the heck you're such a reflans sin
for saying that reflans are
oh mummy hates me
I need to delay until July okay
give me till July
give me July sin
and then we can shock each other with callers
do you have a heart rate monitor by the way
I was going to wear my heart rate monitor so you can
literally see my heart spike every time you go
she hates me what if I die before
you better not sin
I'll be raging are you joking
you've just got that 3d model and everything
I honestly
I love your 3d model streams
I don't know how you're not exhausted by the end of it
honestly I'd be shattered after like 30 seconds
of moving around I'd be like right that's all
I've got time for
it's been nice reflans but I gotta go and rest
I need to lie down
I wore a shock collar for 10
oh no I'm
I'm not
I don't even know how
big we're gonna get it done
sin
sin will
will always be a reflans
did you
kicked my toenail off the wall a few times
oh no
what
what's your community name again
because I remember when I
when I saw you getting started
it had been named something
but I don't know
if you're still named that and I don't want to say the name
okay it's imps now
okay it was something else
um
it was something else way at the start
and I didn't want to say it
I was seeking suspicion I know who's getting banned
just
do a couple of them clapping with no hands audio
sounds like you got a good workout
and bruh I was so out of breath
recording that like
horrifically out of breath
I was like
like you can literally here we go like
ah
clap clap clap clap clap clap basically
I was so bad
man
wait what level did I just get
64 bro wait why can I not kick this
yes oh my god
it was 64
I was suggested sin cells that was
it I didn't yeah I'm pretty sure
isn't incel and
what's that other word
like a ban phrase on twitch
now do they still do that
do they still moderate that
because I remember it got banned
and I was like isn't that
like I don't like the word
simp because I feel like it's used anytime
where a guy just genuinely enjoys content
from a girl which is so
like it's quite frustrating because it's just like
I don't like the terminology
but to like outright ban it
is like what oh did I
miss a few cents yeah twitch doesn't
allow those words but I've never really tested it out
you can get banned for it that's
pretty
yeah like I'm pretty
tired of the word simp because I think it's
used whenever someone just genuinely enjoys
content that just happens to be from
a chick like it's really
but anyway I think outright
banning it is like a bit severe
I just hope that the
definition slowly changes over time
did someone just talk there
maybe later
oh wait was that for me
oh my god I wasn't paying attention
was that for me
the moderation is inconsistent
to say the least yeah it's why I don't
really enjoy twitch
a lot of people write why not twitch
but I have seen countless examples
of what have how they don't
apply the rules fairly
at least with youtube
it does seem like a
overall blanket
which is very easy to be like okay
right because like
now I'm aware that you're looking
isn't allowed now I don't know why
older videos that are made
eons back are fine but recently
not know like Azura
was eating a cookie
Azura was eating a cookie
and she got a warning for
enjoying a cookie just because
her voice is so silky smooth
it's definitely been
generalized to any sort of kindness towards a person
but especially women
yeah like it's why I'm pretty
tired of hearing about it to be honest
like I think it's overstayed it's welcome
cause it just gets used to
oh you enjoy any type of
content from women
and it's like bruv I'm just here
enjoy the runescape streams like my god
I'm here enjoy the rambles and how we're going to take down
the big banks
um
I prefer youtube
twitch raising sub prices
oh my gosh yes at least
with youtube you can decide on membership
price I say that as if I didn't
begrudgingly raise my price by a dollar
of pure rage
but I will make it up I will do as much
streaming as I can to
earn that money
um
but yeah twitcher just seems
to be taking a sin
moving to youtube
if you type in
twitch that you're
an age you get banned 100%
yeah
it was a very
cookie indeed
can't eat a cookie on stream
youtube is really crumbling apart
thank you
I came up with that myself thank you
hi reeflings
oh it's the person that actually got the name reefling after
like five hours hi reefling reefling
no no I came up with that joke myself I promise
it totally
totally wasn't uh how is she looking
how is she looking sideways is she
supposed to be looking sideways
I just realized she's never looking
why are you looking to the side
I don't know maybe she's got like a sore neck
or something that's okay
I didn't miss the
yeah it turns out all
had to do was open the application
in order for it to make noise
I accidentally closed it the other time I tried
it and couldn't figure it out
she's so shy she can't look us in the eyes
honestly like look into my eyes
not around my eyes
yeah
it's like when you see a guy call
someone a simp for watching a girl
and then you look and they watch some big muscle
male streamer for nine hours a day
but that doesn't count
literally glorkin
hard on it
but because it's a whammin bad
but male good
bruv we're tired
bruv let's just enjoy
let's just enjoy the conspiracy through
okay let's just enjoy him
it makes you a simp for listening
to me coconut
my cheeks
and make them clap for 15 minutes and hey ho
then hey ho
snakes and stones
may break my bronze
but you'll never get more quality content
from another streamer
when it comes to ASMR
no that's a lie that's a lie
oh 8.6
8.6
bronze
my issue with twitch at the moment is
something about the vtuber
yes that was a recent to us update
if you did not hear the news
vtubers now
must
conform
to the attire
rules of in real life streamers
but the problem with that is a lot of vtuber models
you know
they have a bit of appeal to them
show if you will
and because of twitch's
who goes there inconsistencies
it's very hard
to ascertain
if
uh oh sorry
hold on
I'm just gonna check if any of the
girls are streaming
please be advised
that
sheebie
is live with
vampire masquerade
2 mods I give you permission
momentarily
to
post the cheeky link
or if emi bezu playing
coffin of andy leily
in during stream and also holding in her
urea
in her tress
there are 2 other vealer members live right now
please do not be worried
if you cannot watch us all
once I heavily recommend
watching the other girls
first because I am
locking in an endurance stream today
thank you very much vealer mods
please do not speak ever again
actually you know what mod appreciation
and ironically
I do appreciate all your hard efforts mods
thank you as much as I am a little
meme lord
please do not I've locked in for a 12 hour stream
you will not see me offline
until 11 hours and 55 minutes
because that is exactly when the vod breaks
em
so please do not be afraid
to watch my gen mates and enjoy them
and then you are welcome
to come back to me at any time
wow this person got gardening
gardening
you got a freaking cabbage on your back
aww you got green cake
aww I forgot to buy his green cake
we should probably buy green cakes
aren't the twitch attire standards
based on what you are
doesn't that mean vtubers need to
yeah so on twitch
you can
stream in a bikini if you are in a pool
or a hot tub
so that is like saying
I could pop up on my bikini toggle
right now and put like a hot tub
asset and then I am good to go
question mark like that seems pretty redone
this
I'll close that because it is kind of covering up
me me me
em
don't forget
that twitch has the hot tub category
which is only worth watching
when some insane guy in a lab coat
show oh no the fire we got so distracted
we got so distracted
talking about the um
let me
let me take the ashes so they don't get in the way
I thought ashes got in the way of cooking
am I going crazy did I make that up
fire
er yes thank you
much more depreciation
em
I completely forgot what I was saying
in real life youtube is barely having a time
I feel like they get away with anything
youtube is definitely more
late wait am I dumb
I am em youtube is definitely
like so much nicer than me
em
it's just the facts
bro I'm sorry you can argue
to a wall
god my burn rate keeps going up
stop
stop stop burning
you shouldn't be burning
em
I'm here for the long haul oh yeah
you got endurance for 12 hours
abusing mods
streamer abusing mods
but they like it though
don't you mods
but you can't speak
ha ha ha this is a one-sided
conversation
em
I think
all the girls got extra mods by the way
so do check your discord
or whatever you applied with
I have no idea I didn't handle the mods
so if you got picked as a mod congrats
wasn't it me
em
but do check because I think
3 people didn't respond
even though they were super keen
em
twitch admins have their favourite
mods and shambles
tell me
about the dude with the lab coat in the bikini
wait is that real
gotta get your hair blower up
there are potions
to help you last longer
oh my god that's terrible
mods aren't real they're like birds
post what you want
no I'm not here I do have mods
we need to keep things above board
another mod flexing on you
by deleting your message
lmao
and slap
I don't know what the lab coat thing is though
twitch feels better as a dedicated streaming site
but the actual infrastructure management
is awful yeah I would say
discoverability on
youtube is so much better
em in my opinion
especially with the shorts algorithm
I would say on twitch
the only way I could
you know
foresee someone
em
for
foresee
foresee someone
being
um
discovered is the
raid option which is called
redirect on youtube
if you get a streamer that is kind
enough and is massive and raids into you
it can
literally make or break
you as a streamer like it's pretty insane
it really is
like I have told
the girls please to always raid
into each other to keep a train going
em if
no other talent is online then you're more than
welcome to raid into
another agency
no problem at all like I
yesterday called
in a favor with a friend
mimosa and
she was so polite was it
yesterday no it must have been the other day
em she was so polite
and I said look I'll raid into you
but do me a favor when you finish up
your stream raid back into a violor girl
and she said that is more than
I'm more than happy with those terms and I was
like yeah I'm more than happy calling
a favor for a friend
em
yes
I absolutely don't mind
it at all em the VNU girls
have been absolutely fantastic
some of them have been raiding into me
I actually need to start messaging some of them
and being like hey you have 3D or microphone
question mark question mark
em yeah
I still find the violor mentality of mods
please do this thing thank you now please be quiet
affectionately
eee
yes em it's very
I don't want to say
jarring
em but for someone who maybe
is new to stream
and em
the streamer
is having a repertoire
but a back and forth with mods that are named
is a bit not isolated
but it's like you've it feels like
you've missed out on lore and it just gets harder
to enjoy the streamer like someone
could be lurking watching me for the first time
right now em
and just being like what's she all about type
thing and if I'm like oh mod X
mod this mod Y mod B
you can see and like crack and like you jokes all the time
em like
it's not very
enabling to come in
for the first time
em
whereas I quite like the
mods don't speak but we are
incredibly appreciative for you you know
mopping
mopping the floors and making sure everything
is good to go in the stream yeah
em
do shorts still work for discovery
emory said
they attach dead people to the channel
now
emy isn't entirely
wrong but she isn't entirely right
shorts
definitely have a
subscription
subscriber count effect
em and they also
have discoverability effect
now not all shorts
people who will subscribe to you
will show up in a live stream that's just
back some people purely
enjoy shorts mind
and they will just watch shorts and nothing
else that's perfectly fine
so emy is both right and both a wee bit
wrong it's very good
em I do have
brah
I have three shorts editors
and all three of them are busy for a couple
of weeks and I could absolutely
smash their faces in because I need help
I don't have editing skills
em
I think I'm going to have to reach out to an editor
that I like to style of
it's because I'm
I'm drowning I need help with shorts
and I do not have the skills for it
nor do I have the time for it
but I'm now that the girls are monetized
I'm wanting to
actually scroll
em I'm wanting to start pushing out
shorts for the baby girls now
em to help with overall sub count
em we are going to
put some advertisements into the shorts
as well so some might have more views
and others and we'll
take it from there look it's just a kind
of em my current
goal once everyone has done their celebration
monetization stream is
my current goals I'm going to get everyone to
5k subscribers
em
which
shouldn't really be too hard
em I do
have a collab ASMR that's going to go on
AC's channel
which should help boost her a little bit
em because the culling was just so
oh 65
wait we're going to
approach the naughty numbers
any naughty number approaches
me
em new viewers feel like
they are walking into a friend group
yes
it definitely is
kind of like especially
whenever I
kind of talk I like to
say oh I spoke about this
yesterday but don't worry if you weren't
there because it's also
quite nice and kind
language to use for people who may
genuinely who couldn't have been
there
types that
how did I keep doing that I don't know
how I keep doing that I'm being such a silly
bully with that
whoa 8.4
ok at 8000 I will
call a break and I'm going to
get a cup of tea get some snacks
em and
hopefully Gimli doesn't come flying into the room
the moment I open the door
but I think she may
em if the streamer is only talking
to their mods that's for the rest of the chat
hmm
your self count will be inflated but it's still a net positive
it's a positive overall
I'm happy to see this
publicly I really want to get play buttons
for the girls I think
I would absolutely
love that
em it will take time
it will take hard work
it will take dedication but
em I will
show the girls what is working for me
what has worked what is working
em and
you know if they do shorts with me
if they do ASMR collabs with other girls
em if they
do stream collabs with the girls
em I think
it is very possible
I actually do not see it as an impossibility
if the girls let me cook
and equally they also cook
em
I think it would be absolutely lovely
to get the girls play buttons and
before anyone asks this viewer
holding the play buttons
no why
I'll say it again
I would never
ever
hold a beautiful
symbol of their hard work
their dedication
their love for their craft
their love for their community
from the girl
absolutely not pointing fingers
but I think
it is very clear
there is corporate greedy
agencies
that care about accolades
to prevent them
to prevent their talents from holding
such a beautiful symbol
and then there are agencies like Vila
that says do whatever you want
here's the money
basically here do me one
have fun here's your money
here's your play button
yes
you don't want the play button on your giant mega yacht
no
I absolutely do not care for that
right I have to ask
I actually don't know if it's real
I only hear it from the memes
is the yacht real, is there actually a yacht
or is it just a meme
hello
do you plan on playing Titanfall 2
absolutely it is a fantastic game
I would love to give it
a shot
for the first time as Stronu
calls
and we can see BT
together
and this time I will get uppies from
the correct BT and not an enemy
that freaked me out
because I could have sworn it was
um
nah it's a meme, okay it's a meme
I thought it was real
I thought it was actually real
and someone was like oh my god
this person owns an actual yacht
on the back of these vtuber's hard work
and
I don't know who it is
you know who you are
whoever keeps telling me to save the blue one
I can't
my guy for one
and two Lamal
I'm starting to think you're just daily
asking that in my
marshmallow so I keep bringing it up
I cannot save anyone
I cannot save them all
but those
who seek the violor route
I will do anything
and everything in my power
to help you achieve your dreams
and I hope my girls
are in attest to that
um
I am happy to discuss that
I always root for the underdog
um
and I think you should too
always root for the underdog
sheebie
sheebie has finished her masquerade
part two
did you finish the game in like under an hour
hello sheebie and harem
hello shreemsters
we were talking
sheebie about you getting
monetization
and how proud I am of all your hard work
work
um
but sheebie went to goalie
oh is she okay
oh she got migraine
oh no
oh
poor woman
she cried herself so much happy tears
harem
that she gave herself a migraine the following day
oh
I hope she feels better
hold on let me
send her a message I'll just put
harem
have told me you're not
well please lie
down in a dark
room
hydrate and
possibly caffeine
might help
I don't know I heard chugging
one gallon
no I heard chugging one liter
of chocolate milk
also
destroys a migraine
but I don't suffer
from them so please forgive
me sheebie I'm dumb
but I hope
you're okay and
I'll take care of
the harem
well you feel
well you rest up
there we go that's literally
my thought process in typing
hello harem thank you
for joining me yet again
mabzu link in the description
it's currently live with coffin of
Andy and Lele
the snowberries
that joined us a bit earlier
and if you are
I'm doing a 12 hour endurance stream
so if you do not feel
so inclined to watch me cook sardines
to cook 10,000
swordfish do not worry I'm not
in solid harem
please do check out mabzu
her link is in my description
as long as my description is
comfortably correct or
if you really want to help the youtube algorithm
type mabzu
in the search bar and it will
do wonders for the algorithm
and pushing violor to you yes I am
not kidding that is very true
if you type in the search bar
on youtube mabzu that's
I-M-M-Y
D-I-S-O-U
she is live with
the coffin of Andy and Lele
she's doing the correct thing and she's also holding
in her urea
for her chats satisfaction
I'm not going to judge it look I'm not here to
judge I'm just here to
deliver the m-Brian
wait
no message but Brian
Brian okay thank
you for the tip Brian
but there was no message so Brian didn't talk
really
interesting and good to know yes
Amy is doing the correct ending to Andy and Lele
so if you are looking for a bit more
of engaging
engaging gameplay then
rip for Brian
I'm just here to
burn swordfish to be honest yeah
honestly I'm here to burn them too 18.1%
the burn rate is going up
I'm not beating the burn rate
allegations they're not doing too well
at all
but thank you for the tip Brian
less robotic please
that is how I type
it's the only way I can get words out and stuff
it's terrible
I have like really
poor
I have really poor
I don't mind talking about it like always
talk about it I have problems reading
writing which
I don't you guys are more than welcome to poke fun
at my grammar my English my spelling
it does not bother me at all
because I get to be like a smug little
mmm about it and be like
oh yeah I've got problems reading and writing
and yet my entire job surrounds reading
and writing isn't that hilarious and I get
to be smug about it
because it's like oh well it worked out so far
even though I can't do it properly
but I
please don't ever be like
oh I'm scared to like poke a little fun
at me or whatever you're more than welcome to
it doesn't
why what if I search
Azura
what if I search Azura it doesn't appear on her channel though
no you have to type her full name
we've only been out for a week the algorithm
isn't gonna know you're asking for Azura Delay
the vtuber you have to type
Azura Aze Ure A Space De Ule Ete
there you go Azura Delay
I know it has a T in it unfortunately
it is French so you drop the T
wow wait wait wait whoa whoa whoa whoa
French and Scottish people
drop in the T in their pronunciations
what's going on here
no I simply type the surname
with the double L that's the problem
Katoos
you gotta give them the government
aww silly how silly
how could you forget
Scrolling Pinterest
and it's just
AI generated pics of koalas
with big what
wait what
did you type in one of her vtuber names
and then came up with that by the way strongy
since I never played Runescape
could you sell me on it
number go up
yippee
it is a slow incremental game
although it well depends on how you want to play it
I am literally just
cooking I'm cooking away look
see this little progress bar
cooking
I'm literally level 65
and cooking and
I
I'm watching the bar
slowly go up
and it's beautiful
and I get dopamine every time
as I level up in the game
it's gorgeous I just can't help it
I'm gonna be real
I'm not even here for the gameplay
I'm here for rambling while I play Isaac
I thought about doing Eden Isaac Runs
shortly for like a shorter stream idea
if you didn't know
most Isaac Runs
last one hour so I thought maybe
for a shorter stream
I would purposely do a four hour stream
so I can redirect into Emi
because I never redirect into Emi
I finally got to redirect into Azura
yesterday
but I never do it for Emi
and I can never do it for Icy
unless I pulled an all-nighter
I might pull an all-nighter so I can
say I redirected into Icy just to be a smug little
hmm about it
but I
wanted to do a four hour stream
so I can redirect into Emi at one point
because poor Emi never gets redirected
and my reeflings are never exposed
to Emi
what sentence?
I didn't even mean that sometimes I mean it when I say sentences
and sometimes the sentences just
happen
I thought dropping tea was an American tip
not the harbor
don't remind me of all that beautiful tea
this is a preparation
but she's cooking for real for me
everybody feeding the fire to keep up
yes special thank you
to the reeflings
that are just helping stock the fire
this is making this go so fast
like so so fast so thank you
for all your help do it, I appreciate it greatly
hmm
but yes
ok say no more I'm sold and yeah Isaac all day every day
in November I'm warning you
all now November stream sniping
week I'm not even kidding
I want to play Isaac back to back to back to back to back
to back to 12 hour injurances
oh I've not
done that oh no
I would have to do all my membership streams
in one go
unless I make a deal
with membership people
hello strongy first time chatting
just came here from sheeby stream
hi harem
she wasn't holding up no she has
a migraine
I honestly I don't know what reason she has
a migraine for because I'm pretty sure migraines
have no rhyme or reason
but I'm like 99% sure
she was crying happy tears might have
affected it and she maybe is pretty dehydrated
right now
an hour for a run
mine lasts like 5 minutes I suck at the game
oh don't worry
Mika's big fan
thank you for the 10 gifted membership
congrats to those who caught it with your face
if you are lurking
you might have a thing that needs to enable chat
but congrats
thank you so much for the gifted membership
enjoy the emotes
there's 10 emotes right now
I will be last to update my emotes
because
the emotes artist is taking their
unfortunately they need a month
so it goes
I say I may
mercy she be yuzuru me
for updates on emotes
but the girls get to pick their emotes now
I'm not going to ruin any of them
because it's not my business anymore to ruin or spoil
the behind the scenes
the hypno cult rose
did I catch it
you didn't catch it with your face rip
rip and piss
but yes
if you are lurking and you aren't a member
you might have to enable it from chat
whoa I only burnt 3 that batch
that was a really good batch
hold on
we are cooking by gas reeflings
we are
ouch my legs got
those tingles that really hurt
ouch
and before it's a blood clot
if the blood clot goes to my lungs and I die
I just want to say I love you reeflings
management
the girls get to hold the rights to their IPs
and let them just have 100% of the money
I don't care I'm dead at that point
ouch that freaking hurts
give sin sister
leave sin sister
Which leg? Your massive third leg? Oh yeah, you want me to have a big third leg for you?
Come here, wiefling. Mommy wants to play.
Some things I say, things that I'm like, that's creepy, not the other way around.
Um, put it on the table right now.
Strawny, I can't die. I'm too busy. Literally, I am too busy to die. I'm not even being funny.
Have you ever heard those stories where people are like in a coma and they're like close to passing
away, but then they go like, I'm sorry, I can't die right now. Like my family member is going to be
or like, oh, I'm too busy to die right now. And then they wake up from the coma.
Have you ever heard those stories? They're pretty crazy. You can't do that. I was caught off by
surprise. Oh wait, I worked. We will kill to, we will kill death to keep you safe, Strawny. Thank you.
I appreciate it. No, I am far too busy. I'm not going to say too much,
because I want to respect my girls, my Jen once. I've obviously been doing a lot of cooking,
actually. That remains, I need to go ask for a collaboration from another VTuber,
and I have no idea if they're going to accept, they might accept, they might not.
Hey ho, we'll try. Currently, Jen too is cooking, and yeah, no, I'm not naming them.
You'll be happy to know I'm not naming them. But it's very busy trying to maintain everything
all at once. But I did say I'm a workaholic, and I really enjoy working. I enjoy giving value for
money as well, especially in this day and age where everything's getting greedier and greedier.
I'm like, no, we're going to do a business tactic called undercut in the market.
Undercut, undercut, like that kind of thing. Damn, the hey ho gets moved. Hey ho,
hey ho, let me finish on my point, hey ho. Yeah, I really like pushing myself to offer value for
money. It's why even with membership streams, like on days where we do a membership stream,
I'm still going to do a cheeky two over stream before it, and then we can enjoy our more cuddly
membership streams. Like, I have absolutely no issue with that. It doesn't bother me none,
and life, life is good. We, we are bingchining. Undercut in the market, love. Yeah, like I,
as I said a bit earlier, but for the harem, that might not have been here when I was rambling
about it. I was saying that even if you cannot physically give any money to the creator you're
watching, just liking the stream or subscribing to them, or just hanging out and lurking,
all of this contributes to the algorithm and leads for the girls to more success, especially
VOD watchers, special shout out to VOD watchers, especially if the girl streams in a not good
time zone for you. I don't know, if you go into Mercy's comment section, there's like one dedicated
VOD watcher and I'm like, you are helping her out so much. I understand watching live stream
VODs is not the funnest thing because the person isn't live, but a lot of you are saying you kind
of listen to me ramble in the background. That is perfect because you, you engage with the content
for long periods of time, again, boosting the algorithm for the girl, boosting it, having
cross promotion with the vealor girls, it's just fantastic. It really is. 12 hours of content for
free, that is value. Yes, like I don't mind it, like now it's absolutely, it's not, I'm very serious
when I say this, this is absolutely not a reflection on any other VTuber streamer, whoever, whatever.
I do not find this to be a job, okay? This is fun, I'm enjoying myself, I am breaking my voice,
rambling to you, talking about all these plans, I've got cooking, talking about how things are,
like this doesn't feel a job, feel like a job and I feel sorry for streamers where it does feel
like a job and they can't publicly come out and be like that. Wow, 66! Maybe that should be my
donation, like a tip sound instead of, are you squiddin' me right now? Although actually,
I quite like are you squiddin' me right now. No thanks to the time stampers. Oh yes, special
thank you to time stampers as well, VOD watchers for any of the girls, the supplies to any of
the girls, seriously. You do not go unnoticed, especially on ASMR stream, time stamping on ASMR
streams is very good for me because I do have plans to clip the girls ASMRs. I'm currently in talks
with someone to do it for me, but the problem is, you know, the profits aren't, the profits won't be
there for the clipping ASMR things, but you know what, we'll get there, we'll get there.
All of the Vealoo girls are perfect for background noise, you all have very beautiful voices, oh thank
you! I'm sure all of us appreciate such a kind comment, like I love her mixer voices accents,
all of that. 1700 to go. Wait, what's 1700 to go? The fish? Oh no, wait, what's 1700 to go?
Clipping ASMR is a good idea. Yes, ASMR is a very popular category, so Emmy! Did Emmy get the right
route? Pen, pals and Emmy, did you get the right route? Did you get the right row? I said row instead
of row. Hi Emmy, hi pin pals. Don't worry, you don't have to talk too much because I think you're
bursting at the seams, so please feel free to go to the toilet at any time. The pin pals mouths
are open. We got the right route, that's what I raised you for, that's what I birthed you from
my loins for, Emmy, that's my Emmy. Hi pin pals, hi pin pals. Yeah, a pin pal came into my stream
and tattletailed on Emmy, saying that the pin pals are not giving her permission to tinkle.
Pin pals, what do you see to such accusations pin pals? Per Emmy's bladder is about to break,
so it's a traitor. No, no, you've been tattletailed on. Oh, she went snitch. Oh no, scared, that's right,
I'm on it, you pin pals, you don't think I'm watching you? You, as much as you watch over my
little sister, I need to watch over you too. No one was supposed to tattle. We were discussing it,
we were like, uh, yeah, it's quite an interesting, uh, interest. Snitches get stitches. Well,
pin pals already have stitches, haven't you seen your adorable design? You know, little,
little stitches over here. I plead the fifth, yeah, you better plead the fifth pin pals,
you're in trouble. Just to keep you up to date with what is going on on this lovely occasion,
Acey has finished her stream. Shibi has also finished her stream, unfortunately Shibi isn't
feeling so well today, so don't be afraid to send your love to Shibi. We gave her good
altitude care, we took care of her with her sister, Mama. Okay, I'll trust you or that you
look after your little sister. Um, why only do you want Amy's love? Bruh, has Amy mine corrupted
you so much that it's not even English? We only do what Amy loves. Oh right, sorry, I'm just
going in a quandary. So, oh, that was me, that was me, that was on me, that was on me, I'll
apologize. Apologize, pin pals, that was on me. I'm getting mine, I'm getting mine corrupted,
just thinking about Amy. Let me do a hydration check, so thank you for coming in. I am just
doing 99, cooking on RuneScape, not very fun, I know, boring, boo. Azur, oh my god, is that all
the streams? Wait, is there no Mercy stream? No, tell me you're lying, Mercy modis, is there no
Mercy stream? Shoulda picked Mercy, is there no Mercy stream? She's playing, no, there is a
Mercy stream. You should play in a prank on me, she's playing Harvester part two. I'll bean
machine, thank you for becoming a member. She's playing Harvester part two, um, so don't worry,
in T minus snippets, any snippets in the chat, T minus one, two, three, four, five-ish hours,
Mercy's coming online. I am just playing RuneScape, please do not feel forced to watch it,
I understand it's not the most exciting thing if you are not into RuneScape.
Um, we are currently in World 380 at Edgeville Bank, uh, Edgeville, that's right, Edge, Edge for me
right now, um, Bank and Hydration. Did I forget to put that burnt swordfish away? Um, we are currently
Azur's playing straight, wait, Azur's playing, why does it not display? YouTube is really,
okay, sorry, Azura, sorry, YouTube is really struggling to show me when the girls are going
live, oh, her thumbnail is adorable, oh, look at what Azur's thumbnail is, oh, it's adorable, she's
got a little, her hair on the cat, okay, Azura is up in three hours, just reach 69, how are you a
higher level than me? Did we not start at the same time? How are you a higher level than me? You can't
be, reeflings are a higher level than me. Uh, yes, T-minus, for the Bleeding Hearts, T-minus
three hours for Stray, a lovely, a little meow meow game, um, and then Sniff It's Warning in
five hours for Harvester, who is putting, are we getting drunk? Hold on, hold on, we're getting
drunk out in here, hold on, hold on, hold on, let me drop this, let me get drunk right now, go, go, go,
go! Oh that actually made, I love that noise, go, go, go, go, go, go, Reeflings, you're allowed to
go take a drink if you like, right, let's use it on the fire, did you select the funny all bell
on the sub button? Exactly, I don't see Azura's stream, I didn't display for me either, I only
displayed mercies there. I am under the impression that we are going to be added to Holodex soon,
which is a website which will list all of our streams and automatically do it to your time zone.
So that will be coming soon if I'm not mistaken. I don't know how it works,
but it means that it will auto show you everyone's stream. Veal or we did consider running our own
website, but it was like another expense that you know what, Holodex does it for free and I'd rather
put any expenses like back into the girls, back into shorts, back into promotion. There is for
those pinpals that are listening in and any snowberries, there may or may not be an ASMR
coming for snowberries and pinpals. I hope you enjoy it when it does come out, but there's a
little hint for you. Holodex takes an average of 20k on all channels as prerequisite. Okay,
well we're coming for it. For any yappening that you may have missed out on, because you are
watching the good ending on an Emmy stream. Long story short, Azura is the last one that we are
waiting for monetization on and all of the girls have been successfully monetized. I really started
through that one and the monetization streams will be happening soon. TM, you can become a member
as a reefling, you can become a member as a snippet and tomorrow snowberries and pinpals,
you can also become a member because the girls are doing their membership celebration. So please
do not worry though, the girls will always be streaming for free as well. They will not be
exclusively doing membership streams, that's not how it works around these parts, but please do
look out for it because once my endurance stream ends, I'm streaming for 12 hours, I'm doing a
cheeky endurance stream, once my stream ends I am going to be the one pulling the strings behind
the scenes and opening up membership, so if you really wanted to get it before the stream you can,
but it's better to do it on stream because the girls will say your name. Do you want to hear
the girls say your name? Don't be silly, let the girls say your name. My wallet isn't paying
waiting for membership to become available. Oh okay, this isn't Emmy in game before anyone
thinks it's actually Emmy, that's hilarious though. We've got a pinpal and they're waiting on Emmy
um singing. Say mommy would you like us to send you Emmy's latest dealie at audio and marrow?
What did she do? What did she do? What did my daughter do?
What did she do? What did she do? What did I miss?
Peeler did she just did she just end stream and then give you the audio of
the bruh bruh snitch it she didn't do anything
shut up shut up shut up
hey guys I knew it I knew she was doing it
she may or may not have been forced to. I'm like
Danny to join in too but I feel like my my peeler um isn't going to be very fun because I hardly
have any liquids because I sweat it from my hands and feet so much oh I need to clip that
actually I need to clip that fucking part of stream where the pop rocks popped to prove how
sweaty my feet are. I'm probably gonna have to make that clip myself actually now that I think
about it. Join them mommy the allegations are unfounded. No who hasn't tinkled yet?
I have not tinkled. Has Azura? I don't think Azura is tinkled.
Can we return to burpler and not be pissy? Honestly as long as the girls are happy
and uh you guys are happy then everyone's happy. Couldn't give less of a. Couldn't give less of a
not no mercy and no uh Azura okay I found the new video very funny oh did you enjoy it I'm glad
you liked it um for anyone who is on my patreon don't worry I'm talking about early access content
you will get access to this content I'm about to talk about for anyone who is a patreon uh membership
link in the description below wink wink um I uploaded a interesting audio where I did clapping
ASMR but without my hands uh yeah so you can listen to that now if you so desire it's about 15
minutes long I believe or 18 minutes long yeah I heard the let me hold it ASMR did you love it
it was so popular wait hold on hold on I have a graphic to show you guys boom no wrong one try again
where is it boom I have no idea how popular that video got I celebrated 5k yesterday and that one
video has almost put me to 6000 subscribers which is insane to like absolutely insane so you know
super thank you to everyone who subscribes um I am a very big believer in the rising tide lifts
up all ships um wasn't it 18 the last time you showed it no this is this is like what I've got
like right now um uh I'm a big believer in a rising tide right raises all ships or whatever
the saying is um so I'm very thankful I will always promote my girls I'm very happy to say
Mercy's meme ASMR's around the corner so is Emmys and Aces once the girls have done their
monetization celebration stream their meme ASMR can go up my meme ASMR was please let me hold it
where I absolutely lose my mind um begging you and pleading with you to please let me hold your
fireman's hose while you take up and it did so well I genuinely like I it has 18 000 views
but I don't have 18 000 subscribers so it's like doing so well I couldn't have asked like a better
kind of result if you will for like uploading so thank you so so much strongy you're at 5.88 right
now geez slow way I'm half of the viewers yeah you enjoy it um it's at 19 k views now that's fantastic
my goodness I couldn't have asked for better um we need to pump those numbers up yeah no no that's
more than enough I'm very happy so um it means I get to promote my girls more as well I get to be
like like check out these girls strongy there is an actual chance that this being an endurance
stream will get you to 6k I don't know if the video has got much steam right now you should all
hit the like and subscribe button right now exactly this weekly news was up um wait I could
let me show you what the stat says now on the video I'm happy I I don't mind I'm happy to share so
hold on let me screenshot this yes so this is what I see as the leecher on the other side of the map
um and then file save as blah blah blah too right so this was hold on I'm freaking accidentally
screen recording I keep actually on the screen recording I don't know why it does that oh hold
on the refunds are talking also hit the little bell icon see you guys are better at pushing that stuff
than me I like I forget to say like oh like and subscribe in this stream oh like I always forget
to say it even though I'm live for 12 hours I have 12 hours to remember to say one sentence
and I fail the challenge every single time you guys are just gonna have to do it in the chat for me
it's kind of ridiculous um right so this is currently uh oh I guess it didn't update so
you can see like all the stats wait I'll update it to the new one hold on um it didn't update too
much because I'm live so if you've never seen the behind the scenes before this is what it looks
like when you upload a youtube video these are the statistics you get you get your viewers you get
your watch time you get the subscribers that were directly earned from that video so people
discovered that video for the first time and they click subscribe because they really enjoyed
me pleading with you to let me hold it ASMR um the reason why estimated revenue is not visible
is because it takes 48 hours for that statistic to update if you guys really want to see it I'm
more than happy to share it doesn't bother me noon um I and then you guys can kind of see the fun
behind the scenes but uh yep um that's what it looks like it says the video has got 19.751 views
um like subscribe smash the smash the bell member to share the video yes um
but yeah that that is fantastic uh you can see the little trend if you see that right right side
trend and you can see when the video was released it had the highest viewpoint and then now it's
still actually going pretty strong it's it's not doing bad at all it really isn't um but yeah I'm
more than happy to show that kind of cool behind scene stuff uh you have went from 555 to 5.8 the
stream um like that video is like propelling me forward I'm hoping the same happens for the other
girls meme ASMRs because I am not putting any advertisement money into myself I had to at
debut because we kept getting called below the 1k and we needed the 1k for uh redirecting into each
other um crowdsourced self-promotion question mark oh my tummy's rumbling I forgot to get some
that's okay I can ramble for a bit more um but yeah I'm gonna miss the chat you're gonna miss
the fact the chat is slow oh no no no no no no no no no no no no you see I know how to gatekeep
myself and do you want you guys want to hear I'll repeat this story as many times as you like
if I start throwing out ASMR videos people are gonna subscribe for ASMR videos and then they're
gonna say oh strongy cuddles lives I'm gonna go listen in hold on a minute this this vtuber
is rantin about how we need to take down black rock this is an ASMR I'm not watching this shit live
and then they'll only just watch the ASMR videos and just like that I have gatekeep myself successfully
because I know how to do it so you're welcome you're welcome that's right I've been sitting on
this plan for a year and I will spoon it from the rooftop but that's the best part yes because
people will be like I want I want ASMR but you're not doing ASMR live stream and it's like no no I'm
not what you're gonna do about it you're gonna leave oh dear oh no might and what was it how do
you call it a tight knit community oh no my tight knit community terrible we're in shambles even though
I'm finding major success truly in shambles I'm on my knees but yeah you're welcome don't think that
will work for long well you'll be surprised um I've spoken to other ASMR creators especially
twitch ASMR creators um I had a friend who used to stream ASMR and she got 700 viewers concurrent on
ASMR and then she went and played a video game and she got 40 viewers and the entire chat was spamming
like someone would come in and spam when's your next ASMR stream and then leave again
tried and true I I'm aware this and it's gonna happen it's just it's just facts okay that logic
is flawed how dare you how dare you say I'm dumb even though I'm clearly dumb but I've seen it happen
on twitch yeah mm-hmm yeah it's not that uncommon for ASMR streamers to branch out yes no it's it's
it's a tactic because I'm always gonna be a gamer I'm always gonna be gaming every day
actually we're playing lego lord of the rings I can't keep quiet about it because I'm so excited
to share lego lord of the rings with you guys it's two back-to-back streams again I'm so excited
because on the first day we play through all the missions and and get like a hundred percent and
then we get to play in middle earth and it's so fun and I'm so excited so yeah we get to play um
lego lord of the rings and and it's like one of my top games because it's just so fun and perfect
although it always glitches out at this one ice lolly place I will show you what I am always
glitches out and it annoys me to high heaven because I have to let me play the game also
and lego lord of the rings is super good like will you still play hobbit afterwards yes um I'll
play hobo hobo 467 I'll play lego hobbit um at a later date it's not my favorite because if you
didn't know well now you're gonna know because I'm gonna insert my knowledge into your mind
um lego hobbit is only two games long and it just abruptly ends there's no public
um explanation that has been released um there are only theories as to why only the two lego
hobbit two hobbit first movies were made into the lego and not the third um but warner brother
bean shit heads um yeah it's just a mystery why the game abruptly ends at the two movie mark um
but it just is what it is um so unfortunately I do not fully enjoy hobbit to the same way I
enjoy lord of the rings I apologize I do apologize um they lost the source code no I'm pretty sure
warner brothers were is it warner brothers it's one of them were being they were being very there
was a lot of production issues with the movie hobbit and then to base something off of the
movie to get the rights to do something it probably was just getting even worse like the
production issues on the hobbit were insane like um I've kind of spoken about it but Peter Jackson
he's the director he became so violently ill tending the fire for mummy thank you briefly um
he became so violently ill he like lost a bunch of weight he developed stomach ulcers honestly
I felt like Peter Jackson when we were developing gen one I was getting ill um I'll honestly convince
myself at a few points I was like this is it this stomach pain I feel right now I've done it I've done
a Peter Jackson and I've got myself a freaking ulcer in my stomach um do you like the hobbit yes
I love the hobbit movies I love lord of the rings and hobbit movies and we're gonna watch um if um
on christmas day we're watching lord of the rings extended and then on boxing day we're
watching the hobbit extended so I can sing all the songs um because buffer has an amazing song
when they're with the elves um if I can remember the first sentence of his freaking song
oh and oh and also had a tipsy cat who paid the five string fiddle he squeaked and he scored
any quickness tune oh wait I'm I'm I'm skipping the lyrics someone needs to put the lyrics to
the ball for song oh well there's an end there's an end there's a merry old in beneath the old gray
hill and there they brew a beer so brown the man on the man himself came down one night to drink his
film oh the ulcer had a tipsy cat who played the five string fiddle he squeaked and he scored
any quickness tune and the landlord shook the man on the minutes after three he said I can't
remember the lyrics you'll need to put the lyrics so I can sing it but I freaking love that and I
also hate um and that's what bill bull baggins hates was it blunt the nice bend the forks
did and burn the corks
that's what bill bull baggins hates oh I love it so much and then obviously misty mountain far
over the mist misty mountains go I just forgot I'm supposed to be a dwarf when I sing I'm not
supposed to be all the way up here but I'm so excited I'm all the way up here but I need to
bring it back down here
scuff the floors honestly isn't the extended like 12 hours original for the trilogy then I might
have to make a second watch room but that's okay um that's fine I say again the siren can't
sing I just oh yeah you think I can sing yeah you'll like that wait until we do drunk karaoke
yes we'll do drunk unlisted karaoke I think at some point and I don't care if I'm not hearing
any of the notes I don't care if I'm tone deaf we are gonna have an amazing time I will try and do
it on a weekend when we do a drunk karaoke so you guys can get smashed with me I was gonna say
shitface but yeah you can get smashed with me um and I will take um song requests but we need to do
it in advance so I can learn the song because if you guys start asking for me like rap m&m
the best I got is green day okay I got none more than for you other than green day um thank you so
much turbo the dog for becoming a member I vote for misty moon oh I wanted it to be like
hype drunk we get like hype drunk on the weekend like it's been a long it's been a long week for
you guys I'm about to head off to bed please rest well yes rest well however I appreciate the gaps
oh yes see you when you wake up in the morning um the misty mountain cold in the trailer made
me so excited for the movies and there wasn't enough singing oh there if you listen to the
extended editions there's a few songs here and there and gandalf sings the song from the books as
well it's like oh the the road is long uh that talking route uh thanks for going to remember
I appreciate it turbo the dog I already said that what your donkey Kong picture well no listen to a
smashing moment yeah unleash the stress so you're not gonna sing rap god and godzilla
and scott absolutely no there's no way I can only do like old school m&m and I still need the lyrics
up on screen um because I won't be able to do it like efficiently what's her burn rate oh it's going
down 18.2 I'm pretty sure her burn rate was 18.7
do go donkey kong dk donkey kong is here he's finally back to kick some tail oh dk yeah
even the scottish version of donkey kong rap I can't remember
yep but drink on and start singing them bars literally I can't obey myself believe
that's planet air turns slowly it's hard to stay say I'd rather stay awake when I'm asleep
actually I'm going to do a meme song cover and you guys inspired me during my James Cameron's
avatar stream and I am going to make a meme song cover of drumroll a secret tunnel but Scottish
and the artwork for it and someone drew a meme artwork of me which I need to reach out and ask
for permission to use for it um but someone drew me like going and then in the next frame
I'm blasting a Scottish beam and I want to use that artwork in the music video um so I'm going to
see if I can do it so basically two lovers I'm going to get someone to mix it so at least I'm
not monotone deaf on it forbidden be one another and I'm actually going to have to write the lyrics
out for the music video maker because they're going to be like what is Faye from Faye
uh secret tunnel secret tunnel through the mountain secret secret secret secret tunnel
basically it's going to be like less than 50 seconds but I think it's funny a little question
for mome are we eventually going back to needy streamer overload for other endings
maybe a membership stream I don't want to play games I've already done before but a short game
like that is very good for membership streams in my opinion and again if you're not membered and
you're listening please don't worry I stream for free every single day you get free content you get
content out of the wazoo with me okay just let me cook give me time I just need a bit time
just need a bit of time yes give me some time
yes a bit of time um
wait when are you planning to do the first membership stream next week once the schedule
goes up you will see the membership streams I will have it listed on the schedule there are
three membership streams next week they are all at different days as well to try and enable
members to try and get a little cheeky uh little cheeky um shot on a come in to join I will vary
the days as well and I'll vary the plots but it is a watch along a member ASMR and a tier list
rating for the first membership stream week we're gonna spend an awful long time on that
tier list rating so I do apologize it's gonna be a bit of an epic bit of an epic
thank you oh how's the toe um I I might I might be losing my toenail
so I went to the doctor man she goes up there all good um and um they've given me an option
they've given me an option I can either remove a side of my toenail or I can get the whole thing
taken off and they told me that um if I get the side of it taken off
because of the shape of my nails I have what's known as c-shaped nails I have no idea if anyone
listening knows what that means I have c-shaped nails which means I am more prone to this issue
so they basically said yeah ingrown toenail that was it that's what they said I thought
she cut into my skin but she cut into my skin and down the side of my nail which is why it was so
messed up so uh I have an option to either get it cut on the side a little bit or get the whole
thing taken off um and I've opted to get the whole thing taken off because I can't be arsed
would you still love me if I didn't have 10 toenails um they said it doesn't grow back
for some reason your fingernails grow back but your toes don't um so yeah I they said the risk
because of my nail shape the risk of me having this problem occurring is pretty high um but I
thought I had normal toes but apparently I have unique c-shaped toes wherever that means yeah
you still love me okay yeah for some reason if you lose your fingernail it will grow back
your toenails do not have this ability uh today I have learned um so I have opted just to get it
yanked off um it's coming up in a few days um I think after my buck shot roulette I am perfectly
fine to stream I asked I was like is this gonna put me toes built different literally I said is
this gonna put me like at a disadvantage like will I be able to um I need to be in bedrest
and they said as long as um it feels fine I feel well I am okay to set up um I am completely okay
to set up and stream because I was like I still want to stream smile um because uh yeah I'm just
asked if I needed bed rest but I don't need bed rest for it which is good for me um just means
we can paint your toenails faster honestly do you should I show what it looks like once it's
healed up they told me the healing takes a long time so I'm gonna be taking uh vitamins um I'm
also uh have been advised I need to go sit out in the sun for five minutes to get my vitamin D up
if you didn't know your vitamin D is what dictates if your scars heal faster uh if winds heal fast
not scars sorry if a wind doesn't heal fast it becomes a scar but um I looked up some pictures
of what toes look like that don't have a toenail it doesn't look that gross to me it just looks unique
um oh no the feet lovers are in shambles with me I'm so sorry if you're a foot lover I recommend
M.A.B. Zoo she's on a foot cam stream this week I'm afraid I can no longer take over um yeah
so um that's probably never gonna get a pedicure again I'm sure that surprises no one
the funny thing was I had looked up stories about going and getting pedicures done and I was like
oh that sounds so silly that's never gonna happen to me the one time I go and get my freaking toes done
but I'm not mad honestly I find it quite funny like some I know some people might be like oh my
god how are you laughing at this I don't know it's just funny like I feel like your body tells stories
and like my story is like oh I got a pedicure done for my reef lens and now I have nine toenails
like I think that's a funny story like I think that's hilarious like your body is telling all
these stories of all the fun you had in your life like I have a scar um on my boob um because I
handled a feral kitten uh don't recommend ever picking up a feral kitten but unfortunately
there's an emergency situation so I have a big scar uh a little uh well it's not big sorry it's a
light white scar that goes along my chest and I just think these kind of things are like
little funny things being like oh I remember when that happened uh I burnt myself on my mum's lamp
she had like a nightstand lamp shade thing and I burnt myself on it and I've got a burn on the
back of my elbow like I think these are like funny kind of things like some people might be embarrassed
about scars or things going on with their body but I'm like that's me that's that's what makes me me
um yeah I've got like a scar on my knuckle um because I rode my bike into a event at my grand's
house and it's like that it's just how I'm made up it's just part of me as a little child uh oh sorry
I just kicked the mic sorry I'm lifting my feet up hold on let me put my feet up yeah I don't think
anyone should be embarrassed um about like scars or your body like it's it's you it's what
makes you a silly goober um you know so my father was a gamers gotta kick it well you can kick me
again mummy well if I get a plushie I hope you're ready for the amount of ASMR you guys are gonna
see my hands so much if I get a plushie I'm not even kidding I'm gonna make so much hand cam ASMR
um yeah got a scar on my right pinky no clue right from Millie Tindley saying Brian
have appeared today to celebrate the life of strongest tone it died how it lived making content
honestly though I think that's like a pretty cool story oh wait I did that way to prematurely
pardon me thank you so much for the the tip reluctant to say yes I have it right now
um I did tell you guys I am on painkillers unfortunately it is it's throbbing and not
the good kind of throbbing um I got it assessed and booked me in um but like the doctor was super
lovely he was so nice um I've not had him as a doctor because I had normally have a chick doctor
and she's really nice um but like all the doctors in Australia you guys shout out to the to the
healthcare in Australia you guys are like actually nice what the heck you guys actually want to help
people with their problems what the heck um so yeah ripped to my my ill fable but I'll keep you
guys updated um it's after the buckshot roulette stream um so after buckshot roulette originally I
was going to do a foot cam I'm going to be honest I think I'm probably going to be on an ice pack
by the time we're on buckshot roulette I think we'll do heart cam for but uh heart cam no we will
not do heart cam that's just my chest um we will do heartbeat um I think Azura has a heartbeat monitor
on I was watching her play stardew and I'm like what's 86 what's 82 what's 76 what's 81 I was like
oh my god it's our heartbeat she has a heart rate monitor on I was like what open heart surgery
cam honestly the toe not growing back could be different per person whoa your toe came back
oh they told me what they need to do is like they completely I'm not looking forward to it though
because they said they have to do like two injections and then yank your freaking nail out which is
kind of gross but hey oh recovery I think they said roughly two weeks so if you guys really want to
see it I'll show you but yeah kind of gross are you squiddling me right now anonymous maybe a new
pedicure will fix the old one is that not how it works no anonymous sadly um the reason why I had a
plaster over my toe is because when they give you a pedicure they cut around the skin and they cut
your nails super short because they're going to apply gel to it and the girl accidentally cut into
the side of my skin and then cut into the nail itself which is why it's causing all these problems
and basically acting infected because it's now growing into my skin which sounds really gross
said it like that um but unfortunately um not happening my my poor ill fable
did they say anything about putting a chemical on it to prevent I think so I can't remember the
full conversation basically the conversation was like you've got this what do you want to do this
is what happens if you cut the side of it it's a possibility of coming back and because of your
nail shape it's much more likely to happen again or if you just get it off it's one and done you
don't have to come back um everything should be fine um I don't need antibiotics it's not like
that um it's just bad um so I uh I'm just like get it over and done with I'm like I want to be in
and out I want to be back streaming I don't want to have to like go back in and all that now it
literally I just said now just take the whole thing off take off we gotta go bald take it off we
gotta go bald um thankfully because I get to sit while I stream as opposed to someone who's forced
to stand while they stream question mark anyway um the healing process isn't an issue uh because I
explained I was like oh I'm I'm stronger uh I don't have to be bedridden for this and he was like
nah you're fine uh if you're sitting for the full day then just sit um I need to change the bandages
though which I'm a bit hmm I don't know if it's gonna be gross but I'll try my best to behave
uh don't worry even if it doesn't grow back I don't care yeah I still like my my nine toenails
um bandage changing oh you're feeling brave I think I think it's going to be very um
not pleasant you'll have to wrap the toe up when you take a shower I could probably take a bath
easier than a shower because I can just like dive into the water with my my leg out of the bath
mommy's streaming from the hospital bed I probably would I'm not even joking I'd probably
if I was ever in a hospital for a long time because of whatever reason
I'd probably just buy a gaming laptop and port my model on it and be like right that's so let's go
and then like the nurses come in and and they're like what are you doing I'm like oh don't worry
about it I need me a chat need me need me up my rooflings hospitals that's who would go hard not
gonna lie well we're almost at seven thousand fishies god we are getting through it the question
is are we gonna finish the fishes by the endurance well you keep streaming from the shows how you
raise the nurses for real for real why is it nurses are so caked up for like no reason I have a
that's it I'm becoming a nurse only to get an even larger rump okay I'm gonna become a nurse
so I can get a larger rump my friend had his removed forever ago it doesn't look that different
just an indent where the nail was okay so true nurses have that you can play old school rinscape
on your phone but I kind of stream it though oh it's the bunny reefling that I thought was telling
me to hurt myself because they gave me fish food and poison the one thousand and two smelly
socks in your bank that's reeflings giving me a bit but let's just say there was no there was no
ink left and then strong it's your body your decision but are you feeling you might regret it
I couldn't give less of a about my toes I'm gonna be honest um I don't uh they don't do anything for
me I don't paint them I I'm not very feminine in terms of getting my nails and you know toes done
it doesn't affect me they told me it doesn't affect my balance in any way my feet will adjust
very quickly to applying pressure while walking um I'm not trying to just miss your thing but
the fun part is if you put the mesh you stick thing on the bed if it comes off yeah um that
hurts to take that off yeah I just it doesn't bother me I've never been into doing my nails or
anything like I literally have fake press on nails to do ASMR with when I do show my hands
you've been playing for a while consider taking a break from stream
jaguics do not insult me do not insult me I'm being insulted by jaguics
uh I did do the salt water yes one thousand bibius honestly what's your best feature then
my butt my outrageously redonkulous round juicy twerkin
that's all I got going for me small chest big but thank you very much I'll thank you for each toenail
oh speedy there's no way I still have 10 toenails give him get a little cook
I'm not gonna yank off yet wait for buckshot roulette then you can make fun of then we can
hold a funeral at the end of buckshot roulette for him how about that that is hilarious though
thank you for the tip oh my god oh also Anon thank you for the tip about the pedicure question
yes sorry I forgot to thank you but yes uh unfortunately pedicure does not cure it for
whether a hill that's meant built like a pair yes 68 68 68 zooling that doesn't work 68 oh my god
oh hydration I'm pretty sure I said I was gonna like go get a tea in hydration like
two hours ago or something but one more okay when we get to 69 we'll go for a break how about that deal
please do hydrate refling please do not do as I do um do as I say not as I do because I do
terrible for me health but I just I just hate taking breaks I like I like being in it I like
being boss you know I started late but I seem to like I'm catching up to mummy stop no you're
making me scared are you guys gonna be ahead of me all of you guys getting 99 cooking without me
just hilarious hypnosis when you sway back and forth and make us obey when soon um my first hypnosis
is forget your name and your new name is refling you will respond to refling you will get praises
refling etc and I will not have permanent effects it will be roughly 30 minutes long
but it will fade away after two hours I'm gonna do a two hour fade effect I am very cautious
about doing any permanent effects stuff it makes me slightly nervous
strainy what if our name is already refling you already respond if I have loved you into refling
refling who's been a naughty refling
have you not been looking after yourself refling how are we supposed to look after each other
if you don't look after yourself that's right I'm gonna guilt trip you into looking after
yourself and there's nothing you can do about it I'm gonna it's over for you refling it's over
before it even started okay this is true real hmm well I've already been permanently affected by
you mom I stood at attention I turned up refling time to line up it's time for your daily inking
what hole are you gonna get it's a surprise that's terrible why do I see these things at
learn also me when my content gets limited ads hmm curious I wonder why
angst on you the game is rigged my name's already been refling for a week oh wait it has
literally because you're called refling in game well I like surprises sounds like a bit
the game is right from the start it's inking tame not yet
not yet because we like it the algorithm must be haunted
actually I need to tell the girls to be careful and say more substitute words so if you didn't know
youtube alt caption streams doesn't even matter for the full 12-hour reshoot triple alt caption up
okay and the problem with that is that's why you need to do substitute words because it will
identify the rate of things being said and it'll be so you can swear sometimes but if you swear too
much you're in trouble you know what I mean so I'll need to tell the girls to maybe do some
better just hear a really weird noise though is that in game
anonymous
strongy I was in a meeting at work today and my boss asked me if I was intentionally putting
no it's over for me I'm done for anonymous no way
anonymous no way you've freaking assimilated the slang
are you being saying like oh are you being saying that oh I instead of like yes
you're like mmm I can do that oh my god we're doing oh hang on can you um can you do this
excel sheet ah I can and they're all looking at you like what you didn't tell us you're Scottish
you're like uh uh uh just pull the old Brian assimilation any percent that's amazing
oh Amy's Vod is totally not going to be kept off even after editing out she's already on a warning
so I'm very worried about her and Amy at the stage I don't want to tell the girls like hey you
need to like knock it off because that's not fun for anyone sorry my microphone is just playing
a prank on me they're pranking me John the Scottish accent is funny until it's too late
to be honest I've started typing I a lot more
hmm
how do warnings work so none of the girls have a strike on their youtube channel
but they have a warning that lasts 90 days three months so if they were to do something against
TOS they get a full strike which limits them for a week they can't do anything for a week
um like they can't upload they can't update they can't do this they can't do that um
and I am a bit nervous but as soon as the warning expires at the 90 day mark um I think
all is good at that but what the heck is that what the hell oh my there's no way
I'll just hold on big ass he's right
um it's not messed up because it gives a warning and not a strike
but the length being 90 days is pretty rough I have to admit considering youtube haven't
announced their new updated TOS or their stealth TOS wherever you want to call it at this rate
um it's a bit messed up because they've updated it but because they gave a warning
if they gave a strike then yes I would agree and say that's really not
fair because you've not you've yet to say that ASMR ear licking is against the rules yet even though
you're applying it um type thing uh but yeah so I have to confess I've reached night nine cooking
three times before this stream you cannot have I only started like a week ago
you can't you mean before though like before you can't have done 99
because that's like they say it tastes like 81 hours to do 99 or something
oh Azura got a warning for Ian a QQ unfortunately yes like Azura
I don't know what's going on with Azura she wanted to do an exercise ASMR stream
and unfortunately management was like bruv you're gonna get a strike for that you literally
got in trouble for eating a cookie what makes you think you can do heavy breathing ASMR working out
and it's such a shame because I never want to say no to the girls but I don't want to risk her
like her income because I know she's not monetized yet but she's about to be
I do not want to risk her monetization um like if she wanted to record it and upload it like on
Twitter that's fine I have no issues with that the cookie embargo honestly yeah the sounds YouTube
sucks um yeah she wanted to do workout ASMR but that would result in like heavy breathing in the mic
and huge I don't know what is going on at YouTube headquarters but it is absolutely
going to the dogs I wish they would just come out and see what is and what isn't
instead of playing this weird guessing game of like oh but that's fine oh but that's not fine
oh
oh my god they very curious very curious well I got a thousand likes on that ASMR video hold on
in the money you may not have a cookie YouTube literally I think because Azura's voice is so
silky perfection in sexu is why she got walloped with it which is a shame because it's not fair
that's not fair at all um because that is just her voice I I'll tell you something in the interview
with her I thought she was putting it on and she was gonna like reveal her voice to me in the
interview no that's just her voice she's just straight up a goddess uh no questions asked
hmm
purple burglar and you're the second one you're the seven I see you see taking that
um literally punished her for a default voice I thought literally um there was a lot of actually
there's a really interesting thing about the uh introduce yourself videos a lot of people did
their character voice that they currently like do as a vtuber and then they were like
hi viewer and their actual voice um and it was quite interesting it was nice seeing the swap
um and I was convinced I was like oh Azura is like yeah putting on a voice and then I did the
interview and I was like oh I didn't even know people had goddess voices like this um do you
know how much money I would make with your voice yes thank you uh give it to me now
oh actually I was like if I could grab all the girls voices yank because uh you guys seen that
movie with a mermaid in it and where her voice gets stolen oh it's called the little mermaid
yeah uh her voice gets stolen there's a ha ha ha ha meat she did 40 push-ups yesterday and the noise
is bruv bruv your voice is pure oh guy you like that right lads time for a group session get your
tentacle out and then get your lotion and have a wee go at your tentacle and then once you're ready
you'll ink everywhere thank you lads uh no that's literally how I thought my demo recording went
it was absolutely awful who's stunting on us with these lava capes are you stunting them
um vivi pronouncing it the lower still sends me it's adorable
shawnee wishes to take her auntie Ursula I literally if I could steal the girls voices
it would be over for everyone unanimously at once I could do lollipop I could do milf I could do me
I could do yandere you know but I can't
but that's okay because sometimes I can go but the only way I can do this is by closing my
mouth basically we just all watch me if I was a lollipop beach a burn sounded like that
then you want to watch me yeah it's always fun with you yeah drop more like more like your your
mom drop showing your head is a baby your family this dude can't get rid of me
yeah today our risk game we're gonna um get the swordfish that we're burning
oh I don't even want to uh with the burn rate of eating yeah no it's not working it's not working
like I'm uh I think I'm down here comfortably and I'll stay down here thank you very much
only if you had the same personality I cannot lighten my Scottish accent to do lollipop scots
it's impossible
oh here we go oh here we go no the accent gets oh here we go no well I can't do lollipop scots
for the heck are we going your bike it doesn't work I can't seem to lighten my voice and keep the accent
I can't seem to lighten my voice and keep the accent no I just said
that's impossible it's not possible it is not I can't put this together it's not possible
do a Mario impression
oh wait it's Mario when he falls off the map he goes
oh we're getting there god we're at 6k actually
well wait who did you ask for it why did you wait who did did you ask for something else
strutting and strutting and there will be no other I'm here for you as you love you as you are
I love you too Risenan that's so awesome
she sounds like she's talking with our wedgie speaking our wedgies
I feel like alternative between Scottish and Slavic like I can mimic AC a wee bit with that
oh wait hold on I've lost it oh wait whoa whoa I've lost it
I feel like I'm insulting AC right now I'm not trying to insult you
hold on let me pull up AC's screen hold on AC's small pause get us on it get us on it
what is having a having a stroke and not the good game the classic me
get get her voice in my ears right now
if I don't have my med it won't have my med it's best for myself and everyone else
it's best for myself and everyone else otherwise my uh yeah so uh yeah so
I'm overthinking it as always I overthink stuff a lot I'm over if you're thinking it as always
I overthink stuff a lot it's not working bro it's not working I'm not mimicking it's not working
no it's terrible attempt at least I tried at least I tried I sounded a lot better during the ASMR
I think that went a little better agent Smith no I see why see you should totally go take a
tiny break and let us get let us get a hurt I mean I'm getting another tea mmm refractory
period already up I need my I need my tea if you could mimic the wheezing laugh that would be
impressive this following someone stopped me from being kicked from AFK I have no idea I'm sorry
she really is all six girls I think I did mersey's laugh pretty all right during that ASMR stream
right when am I taking a break when we get 69 yeah look we're almost there look we're literally
what a couple more inventories I need to wash some dishes for a bit oh you're such a good
beef lane you're looking after the home for me thanks for watching the dishes
just do not attempt to mimic mersey's laugh
if someone can send me a sample of it like a timestamp
I might be able to
we're almost level 69 and then I will call we'll do a pee break I'm gonna get loads of
food and all of that and I'm gonna make another tea sorry my bottle is crinkling away there
please not this
please not this the voice thief not voice pyre safe you steal the person's voice they are mute forever
so who voice will be my voice junkers if you're on ruin light you can look for the logout timer
where
like it's funny but I'm afraid for her every time it starts you're gonna record the no
I don't know the peeler allegations probably aren't going away uh
they're not going to go away for like my burn rate went up again it really is just
that's the start
identity theft isn't our joke starting
strongy you're at 5.9 so gee am I actually unironically runescape duration to 6k
I mean I don't know I don't know how often that ASMR videos getting recommended to people now
it dies off like after the first 24 hours the like recommendation dies off
I'm
no what does it say online wow it says 5,900 heaven subscribers
hey that was a terrible burp you shouldn't even rate that one
I mean you wouldn't download a voice
lol the soundtrack with the anti-piracy advert was a pirated thing itself
oh did they not use their assets properly
stopping at 6k would be ending way too early a yellow
yes I do have my 1k first 1k celebration on the way I am going to break up the ASMR
uploads like maybe every three days I don't want them to like be one after another after
another type thing because there's no way people can enjoy my 12 hour streaming experience and my
ASMR on top and with the patreon uploads you just can't handle it can you I'm just giving you too
much you can admit it when it's too much refund I like when you see it's too much it's cute let
you can't handle what mummy dishes in
that reminds me yes
astronomy the only one who hasn't been peeler no um you're sending us to edge valley that I
am a zero and mercy have not been sent to peeler and
and neither have I the other three girls pretty sure they have been sent to the peeler allegations
as a celebration for 6k subscribers here's me joining peeler
so
oh yeah is there a did to it
I can handle anything momy throws at me oh yeah
wait until I do the no refractionary uh script that'll be fun
um I'm able to put a lot of love into the scripts that I make but I don't know if people
like them but I like them and if I like them then good why kfp spady thank you for the 20 gifted
wow that's a lot thank you jeez louise congrats those who caught it with your face uh check out
chat to enable it if you haven't already it may it'll do like a prompt but thank you congrats
to those who have a more access now feel free to spam any more squeeze thank you 20 b big number
b number okay you're squiddin a bit too much let me turn that down a little bit you're squiddin
a bit too much brian
got the kfp song honestly we share in we share in the hair color kind of well I'm more of a war
what I'm elan I love that meme squid on me momy I'll squid all over you I have to go do adult stuff
be a wage slave on a Saturday I used to absolutely love working on a weekends I know that sounds silly
but sorry enjoy your wage-slaving I too used to be a wage-sleep so I'm allowed to say that
so anyways like in the streamers don't know how hard you and bruv bruv oh gon be real
gon be real do you honestly think I'm someone who's never had a freaking job that's rough
oh freaking straight gon be real
um I really enjoyed working on weekends because it was so busy and the day goes by so fast
um and it meant I could do stuff during the week like on weekdays uh Monday and Tuesday was
usually my day off when I was a wee waitress um missed my waitress job guys can we open up a
cafe at the castle with the farm so I can be a waitress again I really enjoyed being a waitress
it was really fun I used to work in a tourist cafe and uh you see it loads of tourists and
like I'm gonna just say this now for the Americans in the back we we love when Americans come in
because you guys tip you guys tip out the wazoo actually I'll tell you one story so in so
so anyway right Americans come in absolutely fantastic experience and I'm like um okay just
for to pay your bill please like come up to the front because the uh unique payout the tail type
this guy hands me his card and I'm like what and he like straight up hands me his car and I'm like
and to like walk away with to walk away with his actual bank card and like put the transaction
through and I'm like no uh I cannot do that like you need to be there to witness it you need to
be there to agree to the amount that we're charging you like you cannot just give me like your car
your credit card that has no freaking pin on it and I was like no it's no you need to come up with
me I'm so sorry please do like come come with me to the tail type thing I was so shocked to learn
that in America you part with your card super easily there's no pin on it and there's the limits
are like five thousand us dollars I'm like what there's no pin you don't have to put in a code
that's just a default please if you're listening right now make sure any card you own in your
worldly possessions has a pin on it because that is insanity I was like so flabbergasted I
unironically the word is flabbergasted um that are pinless honestly um I was like so I was like
I was like so I was like why are you handing me your card and actually I had one American
family that came in and he must have been from Texas or something I could not understand him
we couldn't understand each other actually that's how humorous it was he wanted water
um but he was saying it really funny like I couldn't understand it and he was like oh can
we get some water can we get some water but he like really said it fast I was like I'm so sorry I
do not understand you can you say it a bit slower for me and he was and then the daughter of the
family was like water like she said it the way I could understand it and I was like oh water of
course I can do water that's not a problem um and then um basically he was like oh it's just
because you've got a funny accent and I was like oh actually mate you're the one with a funny
accent around here but in a nice way we weren't being mean or anything but like we're he was like oh
you're at us because of your accent I'm like mate you're the foreigner in this country I cannot show
you that much but we were like joking about it it was good vibes and he tipped me um we we love tips
we love tips shadow wizard money gang we love giving waitresses tips um
uh the pin is only if you go to an ATM debit cards only use pen credit yeah don't have credit
cards down with credit cards wait until I get on a rant about how a credit score is just made up
numbers for you to what what credit are you trying to take advantage of
ah excuse me level 69 you just interrupted me in my corporate greed rant we will we will
continue but we made it we're at 16 oh nice nice thank you please please can I get nice in the chat
take I'm I'm gonna tape a nice in the chat nice and then I'm gonna tape it nice in this chat nice
there we go nice oh it's dancing I've forgotten how to do that is it like slash wave or something
uh nice nice yeah thank you thank you I'll be here um credit scores were invented to
stop women buying homes hey yo I've not gone down that rabbit hole I've gone down the rabbit hole
where um you're told oh being in debt is bad but this anonymous oh oh you gave me money for that
oh thank you anonymous oh thank you for the six dollars and 90 cents anonymous I see you nice
pen and I get a pen and two for the 6.9 thank you you didn't have to take me you know you can
take for free you know you can take the stuff for free nice journey hi champ hi I'm gonna cry oh
hi um I am full tin foil hat not yet soon maybe I am a of the tin foil hat where the system is
rigged against you to go into Zarian the tip as well thank you for the same thing you guys can
take this for free you know you don't have to give me money to take nice I said tape it not tape it in
the the the tip link um where was I the system is set up for you to fail so you've been told your
entire life oh being in debt bad debt bad and yet the most American infrastructure you have to put
a down payment to get a car type thing and debt you can buy things online in four installments
that's a debt and then the the worst offender of all mortgages mortgages are just normalized debt
for over for norm normalized debt enslavement there is no way you can guarantee you're gonna
have a perfect income for 30 years and it ah ah I could absolutely explode off the planet
um they also close your account if you don't use your card anyway oh sorry what are mortgages
so a mortgage is when you go to a bank and you say hello bank I would like to purchase this house
the bank will then own your house that you pay a monthly mortgage into with astronomical fees
over the years with the charged interest by the time you have finished off paying your lovely jubbly
25 year mortgage with interest you have paid an astronomical amount that isn't even houses aren't
even valued the materials of houses aren't even at that value the construction isn't even at that
value the entire system is rigged it is rigaton needs to high heavens do not ever feel embarrassed
about still living at home with your parents do not ever feel embarrassed if you're in real life
friends from high school or whatever have moved out are able to rent do not ever feel embarrassed
about any of these aspects you the system is rigged against you do not feel a shred of it
multi-generational living was incredibly common for centuries way before capitalism came into the
picture do not be embarrassed about living with your maw living with your grand that is your sense
of community is beautiful to even have that and I would absolutely love to see the uprising of
multi-generational households I would absolutely love to see the uprising of people going back to
another thing in world war one in world war two people on mass were instructed on how to grow
vegetables at home with the rise of supermarkets capitalism who here knows someone who grows
produce themselves I know no one I know no one that grows produce themselves
because of how how much lack of time people have maybe your grand might do it because she has time
because she's retired did you know how common it was to have a farm to have farm animals such as
chickens how common it was to grow even the most basic of vegetable such as potatoes such as
tomatoes such as peas okay you I want to see this become a thing I want another thing another
thing notice how tiny gardens are getting for houses hmm I wonder put your tin plastic someone
give me a tin foil png right now hold on tin foil png I'm not even kidding hold on let me cook
tin foil hat png get me on this right now get me on this right now I'm not even kidding we're doing
this live why are all pngs fake pngs why are they all fake pngs can I get one real png
jeez louise one real png you look like a real p- oh you look like a real png hold on a minute
not club penguin tin foil hat png there's no way hold on hold on hold on oh pause pause
where is it hey let's go okay let's clip it to my my head hold on you feel like right and well um
at it sorry I just jumped up there in excitement um and well I'm at it hmm isn't it curious that
garden spaces for the average house have been lessening and lessening every year I wonder
do they want the people not to have the ability to grow produce in the means of their own production
for survival isn't that curious isn't that curious that flats but massive sky scraping
building blocks have no garden space so people cannot produce their own produce their own vegetables
their own fruits their own herbs so people are forced to rely on supermarkets yet again capitalism
strikes isn't that curious I find that so curious at this day and age with all these
advancements and buildings so many houses the garden spaces are getting so tiny you cannot
even have a produce producing tree and isn't it curious that even when there are fruit producing
trees um that they purposely don't have fruit producing trees when they have to put trees down
instead they use pollen trees um which are good I don't get me wrong they're good for the bugs
but they never give free produce producing trees I freaking saw a story where someone um got given
lemons from the garden and she didn't know that you could just straight up cut the lemon open and add
it to the juice they thought it had to be produced isn't it interesting that in school you hardly
learn about the cycle of the farmers and how you never are encouraged to go to farmers markets
instead of the big freaking Tescos are big as their big this or big that
talk your shit damn straight I'll talk my shit isn't that interesting that you hardly even learn
about seeds seeds I will tell you about seeds right now to remember the three threat factors
of growing seeds it's what wot water oxygen temperature that is how you grow seeds
um the other part of fun is when Monsanto tries to sue people for using their seeds
and another thing there's states where you can't even collect rain water it is illegal to collect
rain water what would you use for rain water hmm you would water your own crops with rain water
bro the system is beyond bull don't look too deep into it or you're not gonna enjoy what you see
you have to look around and say we live in a society that's all we can do we flings
we live in a society amen okay i'ma get off my soapbox for a minute there
let me remove this asset no let me remove my tinfoil hat but don't think I won't put that
hat back on hold on actually I have this hat okay we can put this hat on we're back to meman
okay it's a bit wonky but that's really wonky right above calm down we live in a society
oh thank you for letting me rant about that but it makes you think wait it's illegal to
collect rain water yes but is that because it might drinking water might be contaminated
why do you think that's contaminated is it because these mega corporations bribe their way into being
allowed to pollute the waters did you know in the uk there is no swimmable rivers
that are not toxic for they're all actively being polluted in did you know that all in the name of
what reaplings capitalism shopping behavior sorry I took my tinfoil hat off zero yes zero
by the way I also have a friend who has like 20 different crops growing in his
basement so a garden is technically not needed and that should that gentleman be having those crops
right I'll get oh pardon me I'll get off my horse um I think I may need to eat for I haven't
eaten anything at all to do in fact I've only had a cup of tea and a half bottle of water it's not
looking good for me so yes um I will do another batch so when strong is farm airing on BBC
oh they'd never let me air it I'd be going nuts yeah actually well I'll go back for a little bit
it's not too tinfoil hat during world war one and world war two where food scarcity was a thing
in the modern day age food scarcity is not a thing please do not be under the impression
is scarce is a lie um food scarcity was a thing so people were encouraged to grow farms and to do
very unique plots to do legumes to do potatoes to do cabbage the most staple foods you can imagine
and with the uprising of supermarkets people stopped doing it and who benefits who benefits
when we the individuals the small communities no longer grow our own crops no longer have
thingy we are fully reliant on the system which is not good you never want to fully rely on the
system but guess what if you don't want to rely on the system what do you need oh well you need
a plot of land to grow okay and you need time but wait a minute even if I fully outright buy
my plot of land wait a minute I still have to play some to pay some sort of yearly land tax
um towards the place that I'm living in because there's no place that's truly free there you can
you buy a house in UK and every year you pay council tax even if you don't participate in the
services that they provide um you do it in Australia they have a thing called land tax in America they
have a thing called something tax even when you want to fully no longer be a part of the system
they already got you hook line and sinker um and it doesn't matter what you do you can't escape it
anyway um that's me property ownership tax yet farmers are struggling yep so um every time uh
there is a there was a shortage in Australia recently this happened a couple of months back
now though um there was a shortages of eggs and the prices went up because there was a shortage
of course that makes sense so more people are wanting eggs but there's less eggs uh
hold on a minute what's going on here we're in the information age a major um a major
major um egg producer in Australia came out and said um actually there's nothing wrong with
production at all if you want to know the truth um they're actually not giving us um as much money
as they used to and yet the prices are going up and we don't get to see any of that benefit
are you telling me these mega corporations are artificially hold on let's be honest
are you telling me these mega corporation wait how is there two how did i do that hold on a minute
hold on a minute i need to put my tinfoil hat back on no it can't be that all these mega corporations
are actually hand in hand with one another no wait you mean the cost of living crisis
is actually artificial because if one shop raises their prices the other shop can justify that
but then the major no that can't be right because capitalism obviously brief what the
frick is that rune play that's very grand sitting on that table but that oh no that can't be right
no the good businesses aren't wait a minute coca cola owns all of the market wait but i thought
capitals and bread competition no no everything i've been told that's not right wait a minute
hmm something's not adding up coca cola seems to own literally everything wait a minute who is
the sole business owner because everything seems to be getting acquired wait wait a minute it's a
conglomerate everything is a fucking conglomerate and they can put up the prices as much as they
please because there's no true competition even if there were cheaper brands that wanted to get on
the shelves brands have to pay to be on the shelves in your common supermarkets holy moly
my head's spinning just thinking about how deep this rabbit hole goes maybe we should focus on the
one rabbit hole that's important to us and that's shebe's hole we love you shebe we hope you feel
better after your migraine what a way to end that okay okay i'll take the hat off i'll take the hat off
i'm sorry i get very passionate okay i get very passionate right i'm done i'm done i'm going to
take a lovely little blue break um and by that i mean i'm going to tinkle make a tea and i'm going
to make some food so i'll be roughly four minutes if i come back to one message that says mommy hates
me and not i understand strongy uh was it blackwell rockwell rockwell uh then yeah much better the
tinfoil hat was blocking your hypnotic rays you heard the insane thing
take your bio break my bio break honestly more time to catch up to mommy mommy loves me yes mommy
loves me no not doom break no doom break right i will grab that do this burn them all right i
will be back in four minutes please reeflings do stretch do get up and stretch your legs we don't
want any booty hole problems but don't worry if you have a booty hole problem i'll apply the cream
myself um uh do get some water do get some liquids do tinkle and do get some food as well
i'll be back in roughly four minutes uh the toilet's right there and then you boil the
kettle and all that jazz okay bye i'll be right back
so
Are you squiddin' me right now?
Do you hear it? Reefling's Blackrock is coming for strongy. She knows too much. And they are coming for you too, Skull.
Do you hear it? Reefling is coming for strongy. She knows too much.
Reefling is coming for strongy. She knows too much.
Did you tinkle? Did you tinkle? Let me see. You never let me hold it. You never let me hold it.
You've got to hold three minutes. I was away.
Day 100, still no mummy in sight.
She died of a leafling.
Oh boy. Do you hear it? Reefling's Blackrock is coming for strongy. She knows too much. And they are coming for you too. No!
Thank you for the tip boy.
No, I think I have got my mesh back.
I will refrain from any more tin foil unless you guys get me started again then I just can't help myself.
I have a can of cola. I have a honey tea which I need some help with the reference with.
I have a Nutri-Grain Bar, a Nature Valley Crunch Bar and a blueberry muffin. I can't really make it make a noise.
I can smack the bottom of the casing. I don't know if you can hear that.
But that is pretty much what's going on in my food. That's still too much.
I really remember it being that one. Maybe it's my head set. I wouldn't be surprised.
She came back. She loves us. Of course I do.
Remember that time I thought I wasn't going to come back? That was rough. That was rough.
And then I come back. I come back even stronger.
Yes, for endurance streams it's not possible for me to prepare food. Unless I did it in advance but I'm a lazy fud.
So I've bought a load of drive food or food that is zero prep time.
I don't have any boiled eggs. I ate all my boiled eggs. And my meat sticks have kind of overstayed their welcome.
No, no, no. I'm going to take a bite of my muffin though.
I did not realise I had been streaming for five hours and I've literally had nothing but a cup of tea and a half bottle of water. That's outrageous.
That's how distracted you guys get me. That's how much I freaking love it.
Oh my goodness. I'm going to take a bite of my muffin. I do apologise if I'm not talking for a few moments.
I eat my muffin. Itadakimasu.
Oh my goodness. It's mason jelly.
Oh yeah, we distract you. Yeah.
I can't believe it. I can't believe we really enjoy each other's company. It's crazy. It's a crazy concept.
I honestly couldn't imagine being a VTuber that hates our audience.
Why are you even streaming?
Because I'm pretty sure I have heard a few stories like that where they're like, oh I hate what I do.
I'm like, well if you hate what you do, go clock out and do something else. What the fuck?
You don't enjoy your time? The fuck? How can you not enjoy your time?
Actually, while I'm on my high horse about VTubers now, how can you not enjoy your time?
You dictated everything you get to do. You don't have to do a single thing.
If you want to play a game, play a game. If you don't want to play a game, don't play a game.
If you want to zazoo, zazoo. If you don't want to zazoo, don't zazoo.
Wait a minute. What's going on? I refuse to believe there's any VTubers that stream that actually don't like streaming.
Because you get to pick everything. Does that make sense?
The Elden Ring DLC comes out and I get to do nothing but play with you guys for, friggin, what?
Half a week more? Maybe more? Actually, maybe five sessions. I have no idea how big the DLC is.
I don't even know if they've given an indication on how big the DLC is.
I just want money for existing proof rule.
And another thing about capitalism. I'll stop. No more hi-hat. No more tinfoil for now.
I will burn you out on my conspiracy theories.
T minus one hour, I believe, for our lovely goat goddess, the goddess of fertility.
Or mummy, literally she is your mummy canonically, lore-wise. She is quite literally your mum.
It was enough to be nearly a full game. Okay, might need to change up my plan for the fourth week.
Do you want to hold it, strongy? The DLC. I want to stack donuts on it, and don't say no.
Okay, if it's like, wait, are we going to do a full week of Elden Ring then?
Hmm.
If we do a full week of Elden Ring, on the fourth week, I will make up for any membership content.
Like, I will literally do back-to-back, back-to-back, back-to-back, member streams.
Like, you know, I'll do it. I'll do it to make up.
Shora, thank you for becoming a member.
And everything.
Does that sound like something you'd find in stacked donuts?
Oh, I tell you what, I was doing my research on a game that I might play.
It's called Boutro. It is a poker-type game.
And, unfortunately, I'm not very familiar with the old straight flush, flush, royal flush, or whatever.
The only flush I do is after I drop a big jobby in the toilet.
And I was, it looks pretty easy to play, in terms of me actually being good, that's a different story.
However, it looked like a cam to our game experience.
So, I was doing my research, I was watching people play, and I'm like,
Oh, yes, I understand none of this. So, I'm going to look at a few more tutorials.
But we might give Boutro a little try. I'll be one of my shorter streams.
Not the new Tinkle.
The guys, whenever you poop, do you always pee as well?
I think it's the same for guys.
I do know a secret, though. If you move your fireman's hose, your butthole clenches.
I've never been the same since I learned that fact on the internet. The internet has scarred me for that fact.
See, you're all twitching your buttholes right now, I can tell.
Reef flings. I can't believe you're doing it in unison.
Okay.
I have finished my mini muffin.
I'm going to open up my cola to wash it down.
Honestly, I was worried about eating on stream, but it's really easy to eat in Playbroonscape at the same time.
I twitch butthole for a moment. Reef flings together strong.
We can also manually twitch your fireman's hose, but can you do it without twitching the butthole?
No, you can't. Apparently, it's guys' biology that you can't.
Wah.
Wah, bit of cola.
Man, by the po- wait, wait, wait, wait, hold on a minute.
I was just calling me hypocritical because I just talked about corporations, and then I'm currently eating and drinking cola.
Man, as if I can source this stuff myself in the wild.
Who else is going to give me my sugary nectar?
What's that? I got you.
I'm currently open my nature valley. I have a bowl to eat it in because I just know it's going to go everywhere.
Wow, we're almost at a million eggs P.
Look, 730,000.
Tea? Did you just snipe that? I think he just snipped that little thing there.
I'd like to check out mommy's nature valley.
I thought a certain type of exercise could give you that kind of control over the muscles.
Do you guys want to do kegels together?
And whole, two, three, and release, two, three, and whole, two, three.
That's terrible. Don't encourage me. Don't get me started.
Not only will we have, oh my god, I'm trying to take the nature valley out without it crumbling everywhere.
I have the, I have a Canadian maple syrup flavor at nature valley.
I got a box that has like three different flavors inside and I just grabbed one because I had to tinkle.
Whoa, wait, how fast is this one?
Mmm, it's a ham. Oh, gosh.
I'm sorry if we got like eating time.
I'm off to buy groceries, enjoy the shop, try your best to shop local, smile.
Whoa, that's like respawn so fast. That's 30K every second.
Mmm, am I going crazy? Why is that spawning so fast?
Is it like in a van or something?
Mommy's through it, she doesn't need a lift of 22 million and I'm like, oh my god, is that 30K? That's amazing.
Mmm, yes, I'm enjoying. Is Gimli still fine? No, she's asleep. I'll just sneak around her.
What was that? Oh no, it wasn't me that leveled up. I take another big bite.
Wow. Wow.
Mmm.
Bye bye, don't worry if you have to go, this is an endurance stream. I did not expect anyone to sit for 12 hours with me on RuneScape Wall.
Someone's dropping them. Why would they do that?
How rather odd.
Is he just giving them a week?
But what if we wanted to?
Ah, we're not supposed to.
How bizarre.
Mmm, no, I think it might be bad for your health to watch me for 12 hours. I'm going to be gone in.
Mmm, 70.
Oh my god, we hit 70.
We're only just over the five hour mark. Can we do 80? Is that too much of a reach?
To do 80?
Mmm.
This shit fucking flaky is anything, man. Nature Valley, count your days.
That's outrageously crumbly.
Chat summary shocked you. What does chat summary say?
What's your favorite snack?
I don't even know, that's just too many to choose from. Something salty probably. It went from 70 to 76.
Good 6am morning, never woke up this early.
Wait, you're up early to watch the stream? Don't do that, get rest, you need rest.
Wait, where did the time go? Last I looked it was 97 minutes in. No.
Can you guys see what the chat summary says? Can you post it? Or is it not going to let you post it? Cause I can't see it.
Cause I'm strumming. I'm strumming my badge.
Ah.
I haven't played whole night, is it good?
Wait, well, that's what the chat... That's what the chat says?
That's what the chat summary is on my freaking stream?
Wait, wait, another conspiracy theory, but I did not mention that we want to take them...
Rockwell. Hold on a minute.
I went to play Old School RuneSafe, what's a good reason to give it a try?
Number go up, serotonin, every time number go up, yippee. That's your summary.
What's your favorite Pokemans? I don't know, there's too many.
There's too many Pokemans to decide from, and you know that.
There's literally, isn't there not like over a thousand now? I'm pretty sure.
Autism game, to be honest. No, is it actually?
Oh, you know who I like?
You know who I like, what Pokemon I like, but it sounds like a freaking racist name.
Sorry, that was so off topic.
Yeah, so there's this Pokemon called Qing Ling, and it sounds so racist, and I'm like, bruv, it's ridiculous.
But it's a cute Pokemon, I like the way it looks, it looks really adorable.
Yeah, the cute little bell one, yeah.
I just, the name just like, I'm like, I'm not sure how I feel about that.
17 point name, Burnry. Oh, it has gone down.
Only Tism Havers here, we only have Tism around these parts.
We don't have them functioning brains.
Mm, mm, mm, mm, mm, mm.
Qing Ling is the sound it makes, what are you saying?
That sounds like a weird name.
My favourite Pokemon is Mega Yum.
I quite like, what's his name?
Is it Aaron? Aaron?
The wee Aaron guy, he's so cute and tiny.
And he eats Aaron, he's so cute.
You thinking of Penicillin, what?
Penicillin, Penicillin.
Absol, Absol?
Aaron is cutie.
Where am I getting distracted?
I'm not, I'm not, I'm not Mega, ugh, I'm not maxing on my swordy fishies.
I definitely am going to finish all the swordfishes though, which is amazing.
I'll need to go buy something at the Grand Exchange.
Sorry, if you heard my stomach rumble, they are illichid and internal fire.
Those plate bodies are getting suspiciously close to us now.
What an error, they're getting so close.
Mine is Nidoran.
Oh really?
I remember when Pokemon Go came out, I was really digging it.
Look at the bunny's dancing.
Oh, they're doing like a perfect, you know, I can't remember what it's called,
but that's like English culture when you stand around a pole and all dance around it.
That sounded like another type of dance,
but no, it's like actually English culture, like back in the old days type thing.
Why are we on the same wavelength again?
God damn it, streamer.
I'm just trying to, you can't keep doing this,
you can't keep saying everything that I'm thinking.
Gardevoir, Hypno-R.
I do, I've always enjoyed Gardevoir thoroughly.
Enjoyed Gardevoir.
Very cool, unique and different design.
Color scheme as well, very unique.
God damn it, how many plate bodies does this person got?
Oh my god, wait, everyone's like walking towards the, as well.
What, how much was that, 3 million?
Is this a refling doing this?
Am I going crazy?
What's plate body 4 for defense?
They are free.
But why give it away for free, didn't you know?
Are you squinting me right now?
What?
Thank you, boy, for the tip.
Wait, we can't both be holding at the same time.
Well, my hands are relatively small.
Thank you for the tip.
You probably like her art too, huh?
Yeah, what are you going to do about it?
One look.
Sorry, I only mow my hands.
Two hands is fine.
He keeps answering you strongly, but yeah, it's a refling.
Okay.
I think he's trying to give you a nice valuable thing.
It wasn't me.
Oh wait, am I supposed to chase after it?
I'm so sorry, refling, if I'm supposed to chase after it.
Oh my god, streamer distracted.
I'm so dumb, I'm a streamer.
I'm just a streamer.
I stream my life away.
Away.
I'm just a refling.
I stream snipe my life away.
Away.
68, 16 points.
Oh, the burn rate went up.
I got a little too excited there.
Hold on a minute.
I think it's because it's reset.
The burn rate will kind of go up until...
M.E.B. so you're under arrest?
That guy said it at the NPC says.
I'm focused on the grind.
You don't want me a grind?
Come on, mate, come on, mate.
Why would M.E.B. under arrest?
There should be pin pals under arrest.
I'm not really enjoying this bar anymore.
Rather flavorless, isn't it, bro?
I'm tempted to order takeaway, I'm going to be honest.
I'm like...
I'm doing an insurance stream.
I deserve a cheeky takeaway.
I'm such a good girl.
Why should I not get cheeky takeaway?
Pizza, nah.
Not pizza.
Australian pizza, I'm sorry, Australia.
And any Australian Muslim?
Australian pizza is...
No, thank you.
I've not had one pizza I've enjoyed here.
It's just full of grease.
The grease is dripping off the thing.
They could have blotted it or patted it or whatever, but they don't.
Cheeky little treat, perhaps.
I'm bringing you all with me as I buy a pizza before a storm hits.
Oh, you're actually getting a pizza in real life.
Didn't Emmy burn down buildings?
Look, Emmy needs XP in order to summon her brother back.
It's, look, whatever she does, as long as we can look the other way.
The fact she's not, actually, now that I mention it, the fact she's not even in jail.
How would she be evading jail when she just uses her magic on people who try and stop her?
Or maybe she has, like, influential magic.
I wouldn't be surprised if she had, like, turned the other eye type of spells.
Where it was like, oh, must have been the wind.
I wouldn't be surprised if she had access to that.
And her wee totems.
High charisma, yeah.
She has to rescue Nissan from the devil herself.
Like, Maggie Thatcher?
I think people were so confused.
They were like, why'd the devil herself, and then Maggie Thatcher?
And it was a surprise.
There was a Scottish person on the development team, and we thought the gag was hilarious.
So, there you go.
I drink a wee bit of cola, and then we're gonna get on my honey tea.
Any honey tears?
Me, me, I'm honey tea.
And we can just be a peeler on them, and...
Okay, they can't do anything.
I cracked up.
Wait, what was my joke?
Wait, what joke did I just say? Hold on.
Wait, what did I say? That was funny. Go again.
Go again, tell me, remain me. I'm ready for going.
Oh, the Maggie Thatcher.
Alright, sorry, I thought it was a pun. I'm not gonna lie, I had my fingers ready to do that.
Okay, my apologies.
I thought I made a pun, and I was like, what did I make? That was funny.
I forgot.
Okay.
Chewing fish and chips for my...
I...
So, do you want to hear the saddest story in all the land?
I really like Mexican food.
You know what I don't like?
cilantro.
And that stuff tastes awful.
Do you want to know what cilantro is primarily used in?
That's right, Mexican cooking.
Man, I hated you.
It tastes awful to me. Absolutely awful.
I tried a...
I tried a rice wrap.
I think it was Vietnamese inspired rice wrap.
No, rice cake wrap with chicken in it and all that.
And it sounded so good and I took a bite and I was like...
In Australia, there's a lot more access to Asian foods
that are authentic or really good type thing,
which is why I'm currently addicted to local Chinese.
And so, I've been adventurous.
I've been like, oh, I'll try this, I'll try that.
And I couldn't figure out why I hated it until I finally figured out it's cilantro.
I can't handle cilantro. It tastes nasty.
I'm so sorry.
I apologize to those who do enjoy cilantro.
Yes, I have the soap gene.
I cannot even describe to you how nasty and completely ruins
and any trace of it in the food completely ruins the food as well.
It is an unlucky and unfun gene to have.
Isn't it genetic?
I don't know if it's genetic.
My dad, I think, eats it fine.
Because one time he made, like, is it Pico de Mayo or something?
I'm so sorry. I think I butchered that.
He made it and I tasted it and I was like, this is nasty.
But I never said that to him.
I just said, oh, I don't think my taste buds agree with that,
but he never said anything because of the cilantro in it.
Pico de gallo.
Okay, sorry.
Yes, I think my dad tried to make some of it at home.
And, yeah, I was like, hmm, nope.
I better buckle up in Pico.
No, buckle up in Pico.
I've had my fair share of absolutely horrific things I've consumed.
Where's the yellow thing?
Oh, that reminds me of it.
We need to do a watch along of Kevin Bridges.
Kevin Bridges is a Scottish comedian.
You might know someone called Frankie Boyle
or what's the other Scottish comedian's name
and I've forgotten his name and he's got Parkinson's right now,
but he's still alive, I'm pretty sure.
And he's got a beard and kind of big,
not curly hair, but wavy hair.
And he's older, oh my God, what's his name?
Billy Conley, oh.
Billy Conley.
It took me so long to get there, holy crap.
Hold on, I need to drink my tea before I get sick.
So I put far too much honey in my first team
and I put far too much little.
I can never find the balance.
Billy Conley is like real Scots.
I'm going to do watch alongs of like,
Scottish comedy so you guys can laugh
and I can be like,
why are the reeflings running in an X pattern?
So they are assigned each other to follow each other
which is causing this four way.
Oh my God, what are you doing over there?
So they're not actually clicking anymore.
Their characters are following each other
which is causing an infinite loop.
Which is pretty cool.
Wait, you don't pronounce the second Billy Conley?
Oh, Billy Conley, sorry.
Billy Conley.
I'm not good with names so don't expect any,
don't expect a miracle with me, okay?
It's a strong summoning ritual.
Down with black rock.
I love Kevin Bridges,
my brother served him at a local club.
Oh, that's amazing.
I really enjoy Kevin Bridges' humour
because it's quite deadpan.
British humour is quite deadpan
so we'll probably do a watch.
Again, sturdy with it.
Hold on, let me just get the fish out of the bank first.
Reefing getting sturdy with it.
Ay, ay, ay, ay, ay, ay, hiddah hiddah hiddah hiddah hiddah hiddah hiddah.
I love all these emotes in the game.
I haven't unlocked any more but other than the default ones.
Hmm.
This stomped-on Rottra really sells me on the cult vibes.
Aw, she be playing cult of the Lamb, did she finish it yet?
I think she was so close to finishing it at last I knew
but maybe she did it.
Ehm
Hydration
Gears are quid, oh you're getting stabbed. It's a great one. It is. Oh my god and
Oi fat boy right? I know this makes no I'm gonna. I'm gonna tell Kevin Bridges is joke, okay?
So Kevin Bridges is a man, and he's quite large in size. I think he'd lost the weight since or whatever
but he said he was like 25 stone or something which is big and he was telling
the story where he's out late at night waiting on the bus and some net comes up
and goes oh fat boy Gia's a quid or you're getting stabbed and then he's
like I saw I start calculating my BMI with the other people around me type
thing and then he ascertains that it's him that's been picked on by this
person and he's like in order to avoid this heinous act against me for the
mere price of a quid and I think that's a pretty good bargain and so he did not
get stabbed that night that's the best I can do for telling the joke but it's a
really good joke I'll get us to do a watch along Kevin Bridges call the
lambs getting local co-op I know I'm gonna play it with sheebie and we'll force
her to play with me and he used to weigh about 350 pounds
there's an American place that lets you eat for free and if you're over like
heart attack grill oh my god I'm so sorry I look at videos a heart attack grill
I think it's so fascinating and there's like a way outside the restaurant and if
you are over that weight you get to eat for free I'm like wow 25 stone equal to
160 kg mm-hmm what you gonna do oh he says as he gets shanked I was a bit
premature there wow we are like burning through this well I don't know what
level I can cook those octopuses but I think we'll go to the grand exchange and
buy some I have a terrible feeling they are a membership only item so we might
have to swap to a membership world which is a shame for anyone who's not a
member the heart attack griffin
mm isn't heart attack girl just a place because the owner hates fat people and
wants them to do what is that the lore or
wines is probably better at that point wait caravan wines better than caravan
caravan I'm sorry I'm not saying that right I'm gonna pretend I'm saying it
right what level cooking I am 70 on the door
we think someone gets 20 some octopuses honestly mate honestly mate right I've
had a nature valley bar I've had a muffin and I don't actually feel like
eating that's what I'm saying when a stream I don't feel like eating properly
tick manipulation oh I'm not that good at the game I'm not that good at you
that chance for me
oh boy really gonna get me a by-merry well don't buy it yet wait until we've
decided on what's going on and kill more combine
you've seen so my girlfriend says red hoards are from Ireland and I said red
herds came from Scotland Ireland has a higher redhead percentage I believe but
you must acknowledge with that that due to the Irish potato famine which was
actually just a British government and starving the people and a lot of Irish
migrants went into Scotland and because it's a very close company a company
company country thank you for the five but I'm I want to say I think your
girlfriend's right where the red heads are from Ireland and give them to mummy
wait what he wants my wine making supplies wait is wine faster hold on
hold on I'm banking I'm banking hold on what what does wine look like how do I
get wine Shawnee if you right click game at the bottom of the screen and click
if game Shawnee if you right click game at the bottom of the screen and click
filler it will hate all the cooking messages
huh
oh thank you thank you thank you gail gan choose for becoming a member I
appreciate it mm-hmm government starving people ridiculous I bet that hasn't
even happened to tons of other countries red haired red heads are from the
Northern Kingdom Catholic I actually have the redhead gene so if any
refling has it too and you want to rendezvous with me we might make more
Emmys what that's a lot wait how do I do that oh wait wait wait hold on hold on
hold on thank you so much refling oh my god wait what I do though hold on hold
on give a thing give a thing take out 14 I think it take it take out 14 and then
shove them together like this is this faster oh I don't know if it is faster
hey thanks for the two
let's make more girls gingers together and then do it like this okay that worked
make sure you do it every 14 seconds to he a huge XP job put 14 in the bank and
then combine them about chat it gives about 2200 average huh so this is more
or less than cooking the swordies we're gonna go for about 14 second random
timer they take a bit to ferment okay I'll ferment you I'll ferment you in a
minute in between these cheeks sorry breeding more changers into the world
of strong you can also right click the X button oh no they're gonna ferment
before I'm ready don't ferment don't ferment I'm getting scared can't throw
at me really good time they only ferment when you aren't crafting wine
how bizarre okay I guess can you get bad wine or is wine always successful you
can use the X button on the bottom of your bank tab so you can bank all isn't
enough faster if I like pull out wine put wine away pull out water pull it
great you can make bad wine did a burnt fish people buy bad wine then click
twice as fast is it painful watching someone trying to maximize their like
XP gain and they're doing it all wrong you're just like oh god I can't watch
this anymore that's what two clicks now it's fun to watch you can't get bad
what wine because you're such high level so you pull it 14 each and come back
all after
ah was that right did I do it right the sentence 14 yeah I think I did it right
okay we did it we got there in the end only non-alcoholic wine is bad oh well
apparently I like all the reports are now coming out about how bad alcohol is
for you I'm learning big gains let's go I'm learning I'm so fast
me watch Johnny burn the wine honestly I wouldn't put it past me
this is so goofy look I was all hanging out at the bank together I did that wrong
sorry I did it the old way you can click the bag button all right I gotta go
thanks for your more than welcome thanks for hanging out please anyone don't feel
bad about not being able to hang out the full stream that is not possible
Azura is going live right bank and then click click okay that's how they're
wanting me to do it see refunds are so good man they don't even get keep
information about me mmm baby I'm gonna take a shower scrub it up there's a
more a metronome plug in to help you understand time picking ah you know I
honestly thought you were just referring to metronome the freaking there's an
item in Isaac called metronome and I forgot like wait a minute it's an actual
thing that helps musical why gate keep info if you want to see people play the
game you can also click space bar instead of make all in chat click space bar
instead of me call hold on hold on right put it in do that do that together
space bar oh we're getting even more efficient refunds we're getting night
night tonight Isaac brain roll honestly it hit long ago the creator of Isaac I
follow him on Twitter he's been utilising Twitter a lot to talk about
mugenics
wait what was that other also can click on the bank so you don't have to oh my
god we're getting the stress and Isaac players when they realize mothers are
real and yes I've been following and Ed Edmond I believe is the creator oh my
god I'm going to take a minute to learn these strats and and he basically came
out was like oh the bending of Isaac was based on my trauma of my religious
trauma smile I was like oh my god are you okay and cuz like finding of Isaac's
prey like if you understand I mean not that you need to oh sorry I fucked that
one up sorry sorry we flinch I'm sorry forgive me and that's like oh my god
are you okay you can make it so that person escape closes the bank oh my
god there's too many too many new strats hold on let me let me nail this first
strap first because I'm messing it up right empty sack grab grab combine
space bar okay I just need to do that a few times and then my brain will
comprehend the new strike cuz I'm not used to doing it that way yeah that's a
whole lot of trauma yeah like and so Ed mind was like too bad seven 750 trout
is worth like a hundred key what empty sack click click combine space bar
we're getting there we're getting there we're getting after repentance I feel
like well there's been a bit of whispers about the binding of Isaac
because someone did a cheeky day of mine when they shouldn't have and there is
something called the repentance plus it is possible empty sack click click
combine yes I might need to do that escape thing honestly not my work
you can set buttons to escape in space honestly yeah so it's possible there
might be an item update I am not part sorry and hold on hold on I can't talk
into that at the same time it's possible that they're gonna have a slight
change to some items and all that jazz the DLC does come out in November which
means we can all play multiplayer together and I'm going to go crazy
you literally you're gonna be sick of it but I think it would be really empty
sack it would be really good to get dead God together I think that would be
crazy because I would make it so much easier of all through like the max
lobby size is four so three reeflings at a time can do a run with me and I'll
just do it the way we did with Elden Ring where I write down your name and
who got in and you know take it from there type thing oh my god right empty sack
click click combine thingy okay we're getting there what was that skate key
thing I need to do now dead God would feel so close literally I could do it with
it I could definitely do it with co-op help but do you follow matters or grab
items oh no I just do whatever I want I have never actually it took me so long
to like realize I don't have to pick up escape leaves a bank interface for you
wait if I just escape naturally I have my finger ready to escape and I play on
Xbox no cross plays not gonna be plausible in Xbox empty sack take on
my hit escape and then combine space oh my god we're getting there we're getting
there we're getting so close and I eat far I'm not gonna lie excuse me could you
imagine if I just he'd like that have a big sniff okay empty click click escape
combine oh I'm getting so good if you made all of those wines I'd get a million
XP wait oh I'm getting nervous hold on a minute I'm starting to understand how
that streamer with the big boogers got so much out of those lobby use making
those lobsters empty sack click on both escape combine okay we're slowly getting
into my head sorry it takes me like so long to figure things out that was loud
sorry what did I do she's got the rhythm click empty grab grab escape space
man try going up even higher I made one four two key why is trying going up did
we break the market reeflings did we become the enemy we sworn to destroy
well empty grab grab escape this is just gonna be like this for the next five
minutes until I can do two things at once oh when you said brap sorry sorry I'm
breaking your ears we're breaking you ain't even you know even the fact I be
going hard I'm breaking the hearts like damn she's thick but I'm thicker I don't
know the rest of the words actually you cause the spike in the market honestly
that's funny if true and real I'm just gonna I'm gonna pretend that's oh my god
this is I will say the cooking was a lot easier to read stream the only thing I
don't like about wines is over so quickly I can't we can't think either die here a
hero or live long enough to be on the market honestly oh god my brain can't
keep up with us escape god we're moving we're at like almost 5k great sorry I was
supposed to do space one up do you plan on making an old-school runescape up no
I don't know what planning is I've never done it or been in one before I just
used to be the scammer at the exchange post I was like double in money that's
me that's what I did I can't believe it I can't believe it
wait combine oh I never had escape that time
whoa whoa wait what did Stroni cause a spike apparently the price of trout is
going really weird right now Stroni took all my money I'm sorry I took your
thousand gold I sure you did absolutely nothing with it because I abandoned
they can't probably never bothered again price trout trout is 41 raw trout
190 for a raw trout quick sailing for like 189 hmm did we actually one goes
oh it's all right sorry I'm messing up strokes Stroni drawing a big tentacle in
the pre-stores
um well I'm happy that we at least reached 70 that is good sorry I'm
please don't look please don't look I'm embarrassed I'm I don't know what we're
gonna end on if we do I think someone said it was like five endurance streams
if I just like non-stop did this then I would reach it I was hoping wait oh no I
messed up oh no it's gonna form in don't form in don't form in don't form in
don't form in don't firm in you see honestly it's less about being efficient
and more about saving our hands so you guys don't have to stoke the fire for me
all the time
hmm
whoa bing bang boom bat pal I'd completely did not strut that over it
stronger really wants that giant ex-people I well I'm wondering could we
just keep doing it until they're all gone I don't know how long it takes to do
6,000 wines though I could only do 14 pair inventory slot which is a bit of a
problem so I need like just what 14 how many 14's does it take to get to 100 I
don't know but I'm gonna be here for a while I think or is it six no 14 my
right wrist is deaf messed up oh my god you okay we fun from this game cuz you've
been playing this game so many grapes wait people just XP bomb for fun mostly
yes he want to click on that guy but I'm not to click on it right empty the
sack click on the ingredients escape combine space bar see it didn't write
that time I have to like mentally bring it to my head how much seven so I need
seven inventories to do a hundred that's quite a lot
what I've messed up but that's okay I'm trying my best you need roughly so 62k
wines to get from 68 to 99 brah who picked this is there not right let's do
fletching we can do fletching in four hours we're getting how many wines there's
no way I can do that I'm starting oh no I'm starting to have doubt reflings have
I messed up have I messed up picking this game it's 200 XP per wine oh that's
more than the fish fletching is death gonna messed up your room have I made a
mistake picking King I'm getting nervous I'm getting chicken and now I did say the
next time we do runescape I'm going we're gonna what do a movie watch along
as well just so I can rest my voice unless you do like how's the cooking
going we're starting to feel a bit daunted now and it's starting to settle
in like oh no this is a lot and the next time we do runescape stream we are
gonna be watching a movie series so I don't have to talk and I can rest my
voice a little bit because I do have quite a few ASMR clubs coming up and I
need to keep my voice steady need my voice to be steady and ready wines are
like 480k if you're consistent per hour I mean it's alright you need 87k sword
fish so waitings are still faster in the end oh my gosh oh we flins I think I'm
gonna messed up picking cooking but I really want 99 I've never had my first
99 before I'm getting nervous I'm gonna shake you just drink back what's with a
ritual dance at the top of the screen those are reeflings they're just dancing
each other we're all hanging out of the fire remember level 92 is halfway stop
is it actually no I will not give myself that I'll see what happens after the
movie marathon xp wise it's halfway I know what happened to the legendary
stamina I'm getting nervous I don't know if I have an end in stamina now I'm
getting shaking way right empty boom boom
boy fat boom boom cooking is the fastest without completely rune like cooking
fish isn't it good that we'll be there with it yeah next runescape stream though
I'm gonna be watching movies so I'm not talking too much because my voice is
getting shredded but I love it can't help can't stop talking okay
well making wines is faster with the reeflings here 99 shouldn't be a problem
okay okay okay although it'd be really cool to look back and see how much time
I spent I wouldn't mind doing some questing after we get 99 cooking I don't
know if I'm gonna be able to do 99 cooking in one month though because of
the streams that I've got planned out it doesn't really work that well because of
Elden Ring because of Elden Ring I would have been able to put more time into
Rinscape but because of Elden Ring 99 cooking that's all because of a mediocre
joke that you're a whammin you got this Johnny we'll make you and we'll get
your master chef but it would be kind of cool to look back at like this the
stream thumbnails and see how much time it took obviously we did some questing
the first I had so much fun like doing all those quests and like waiting for
everyone and be like okay we'll do this next we'll do this night and so if I do
achieve 99 cooking and I'm not burnt out of RuneScape then pardon me I'm burping
away here I actually wouldn't mind and I wouldn't mind what I wouldn't mind doing
some more quests than again together because that's quite fun and it's more
interactive than literally you do need to do a quest to cook a koambas I can
never say I don't know what on earth I'm supposed to pronounce them as and are
they better XP than wine is the question that need combat for that quest by
any chance 50 subs away from 60 stop is that video still getting traction yeah
sticking at my yet for the river only by tick manipulating right no if wait so
I'm just doing wines for the rest of this entire gig oh no it's only faster if
you're paying attention I'm just doing wings for the rest oh this is terrible
stream content you guys just seem to go back and forth to make more wines wait
so then why was that chick doing lobsters we're the one with a big jibblies out
why did she do lobsters for cooking is lobsters cheaper cheaper can always
switch it up yeah I'll maybe finish my swordfish once this batch for minutes
I'll swap back to the swordfish just so like everything the reflins gave me and
being used up that seems like the wisest thing it's come oh yeah you're like
when I yeah for you oh yeah pull over your face your stomach your thighs fish
would be we floor but we less attention yeah I'm the Wayne attention batch is
getting pretty rough I know I can I'm sorry I'm touching my boob right now I'm
I'm not even pretending otherwise I've only got one hand available right now
tea you can literally just talk to us for the content that's why I'm here
no right I think we can finish off the swordfish and the Wayne also it was
actually really funny that you just straight up handed me like your wine
collection no questions you know like no this is mine you're just like I hear
habits Tony it's quite funny actually don't think about it yeah there's no
point in arguing she can have it
why you did it rank wow oh that's so big oh you can get it oh sorry I'm
getting distracted why don't ferment I got distracted I was reading don't ferment
you're yapping is so strong we forgot that you were also playing runescape the
game is more a background to you honestly we first try to get more
mad rope with all this wine exactly forfeit all mortal positions to the
cauliflower no look after yourself get yourself a debt buy yourself treatees at
the corner shop and then and only then the fermentation is top left oh wow
that's so cool man rune rune light plug-in is so good we're learning
what what
plop plop plop don't ferment don't ferment don't ferment I was actually there is
like this feature of her that posted a thing where this song's like done done
done done and she goes get pregnant get pregnant get pregnant get pregnant and
I was gonna remake it and be like get break get main break get main break get
main break but I can't say it that fast but I was gonna add like plop seven
effects and all that and the music and then do my hypnosis thing also that
timer stuff can be moved by holding all and dragging it I'll leave it in the
top corner where it belongs we know
was that the one by someone underscore it is it got like six thousand likes and
I was like oh my god I want to make a reefing version of that so I was like in
main break in main break in main break in main break in main break in main break
yeah
keep going to click on the banker but she's not there's so much going on over
there in parachutes I think I remember seeing that yeah I like went pretty
violent I thought now that oh my god I want reefing version so I'm gonna put my
hypnotized on and stuff be old and breaking breaking good well not
pregnant in your case get your boy for it really for me
stroney you can't imagine what's happening by the way wait why what do you
mean what is what does that mean why does that sound like a veiled
truth I mean we're almost at 4k water we've just done about 500 there I'm
wondering if I can do it in one sitting and just let the XP pop and then I'll
be satisfied with that oh maybe maybe baby if I don't mess up what hello I
want to grab that oh my god reeflings are such sugar daddy that was 7 million
just hanging out on a table
allegedly actually did a gilded someone go it have been to drop in a gilded
frickin plate armor people are storming the channel are y'all winning
stroney get in pregnant yeah I've never really been I mean I'll cater to
everyone I'm pretty sure the viral version was either they get pregnant
biting it or get me pregnant mmm not sure no it wasn't that one I didn't see the
show I know what the show every one is but and I definitely must have seen it
from the other check I want to grab that
stroney reading my I want to grab that let me shake your hand I'm already here
Lord of Storm I'm just gonna check when Azure comes what was that noise why is
that look away for a millisecond and there's lots of weird noises going on
hold on hold on let me check when Azure comes on subscriptions why does it not
say is there is coming up next that's so annoying oh no my frickin wait I'm an
idiot I'm an idiot I'm an idiot oh how could I forget the wine fermentation how
could I have been so silly I just want to make sure we deserve
level 72 right I'll take it level 72 that's actually not that bad though I'm
quite happy about
198 key 198 key seriously whoops that was good though that was really good okay
maybe wines is the way to go because a big if true and I'm not even finished
fermenting all the wine that I've got hold on I'm gonna put the heating on
cuz I'm absolutely frozen it's 15 degrees am I supposed to survive in
yeah apparently I'm Australian I rent and but okay I just I just popped the
last into the 73 I would have jumped three levels if I managed to do one more
batch right hold on let's see what's going on with my Azure delay she is coming
up oh my god as it were please spell correctly there she is there she is oh
literally in T-minus two minutes and Azura is playing a absolutely precious
game called stray I have not yet had the pleasure to play it but it's bloody
good yeah yeah if you've made the 1,000 winds it would have been a two hundred
keep on listen to strong you yeah well at work and proof product to me I feel
like and I feel like I would distract being like at work and stuff honestly
if I had an office I feel like I'd be like one of them bosses that couldn't
just give a rat's ass like as long as you do the work go home early doesn't
bother me none seems like whenever someone gets a manager type job they
think they call the shots and it was like no you're at the mercy of your
workers let's let's not get it twisted let's not get it twisted are you doing
marshmallow later yeah of course I'll do marshmallow more than happy to I would
I'll do it when we do when we go back to the fish because unfortunately the
winds require a lot more and like fast clicking every time I move to the left
I need to do and I'm getting nervous now not to be a minger but when I tried to
go to toilet but nothing came out and I'm worried I'm gonna have to go toilet
in the middle of the stream but I don't want to go toilet I normally take a
shower after I fell off my most thought what time come in here oops I will do
marshmallow it's not problem use your gamer bucket please do not ever type
again gamer bucket now pee bottles I can tolerate gamer bucket like Eric
Cartman style ma'am ma'am I need to use the bathroom ma'am you gotta go for a
job eh the birthday girl my team leader in quality assurance didn't sell their
their premiums since months because the workers are more made and didn't get
trained properly literally just because you in the manager position does not
make you a leader
magi playing runescape into 24 without a refunds you know the gamer bucket
yes yes on a scale of 1 to 10 how jealous are you of men's ability to use
gamer ball I I don't think it applies to me because I have acidic like main
stinks actually I probably should have mentioned that to the doctor he forgot to
mention it what was that also if you try to do a last night name fletching your
wrist would die after a few minutes unless you learned mostly I don't have
that kind of mouse I have up and down on the mouse that's it good dinner ruined
sorry okay I think we're gonna have to swap back to the sort the swordfish just
for a little bit because this is like one after the other your mace your face
melts off kind of acid yeah mouse keys are button presses oh I don't have that
that's it how about we just bought the levels and I'll just commentate over oh
my god you leveled up congrats I'm kidding by the way we're not born I don't
know how bad the box are in runescape I heard they're really bad in World of
Warcraft but bots apparently keep prices low and cheeky runescape so gamer girl
uses P-Bollies more long I'm already in trouble by YouTube actually should check
out wait no I'll check it when we're doing the fish not well this is being in
the way I will check it after I've done this batch of wines which I just know
some people say like oh the reason why the box are actually good is because they
keep everything low price because they're like trying to fight over the same
resources type thing and I was like honestly that is actually valid
feedback right we'll go down to five thousand water and then I'm gonna swap
to fish just to like use up all the fish because it's just and and I'll read
some marshmallow Q&A's if you want to say something say something sorry I know
I'm not doing that the good way but they there are bots that kill some of the
hardest bosses in the game in the tens of thousands yeah but keep runescape
economy from hyper inflating mmm can't believe it capitalism wins again even in
my video games and I can't escape didn't they just catch some box and wow by
placing a single rope oh wait I seem to remember something like that I think
you're right also just gold farmers who are boss they just sell the money later
on oh yeah you can like buy like in-game currency with like actual money so like
you get given the money or something because of the there's like a Venezuelan
meme so the Venezuelan Venezuelan economy went to shambles and and
basically it became profitable for those individuals to play runescape and sell
the in-game currency or something yeah my brains like can remember that they sell
on a third-party set for anyone which is against us oh okay okay okay I get I
guess it's against us on World of Warcraft as well that could be wrong I
don't know Azura has gone live okay if there's any bleeding hearts or any
reeflings who are needing a break from the winemaking Azura Dooley has gone
live she is playing a game called stray and she's a cat and I'm not a go so if
you want to see Neco Azura you know where to go
mods I give you permission and thank you for linking my gen mates when they go
live because we love my gen mates. I think Azura might actually hit 4k you know
that I think she's about to teeter over 4k she's teetering whilst I am on her
teetering thank you I'll be here all week that's absolutely awful I'm not I was gonna
repeat it in order to do that bruntz but no that was absolutely awful and I
should be ashamed of myself truly
yeah she's at 4k oh that's fantastic soon Ace will be 4k as well and I'll get
her to make some more adorable little shorts and I'll put some money in it and
she can celebrate her 4k as well. Gen mate love, Gen mate love.
Oh no this has put me to sleep this is a terrible idea my room's getting nice and warm and
RuneScape's so soothing and the reeflings in the back are so hypnotic hold on a minute
you guys put me to sleep hold on a minute I've just had a tea which has caffeine and
cola has caffeine in it as well oh but it'd be so nice to sleep we do a nap in
stream you guys come nap with me actually I wanted to Bob isn't I'm gonna say it
Brian you're ruining these TTSs Bob thank you for the five love strong is my
mommy wait and she has she has boing boing boing boing boing boing boing boing boing
oh so please think of the fermented wine I'll mess that up again
wow
you didn't know I could do that my mom so hey hey hey have a basic toggle it's for it's for when
I do hot tub ASMR okay it's hot tub ASMR relax cheeky hot tub I am back spitting on the beat
mmm but yes I am suddenly feeling very tired I think I told you guys my sleep's been a bit
hairwire but I finally got an eight hour sleep last night but I woke up 30 minutes before stream
and I tried to did a brick cutting fart and then nothing sorry and then nothing happened I went oh no
did it pop I wasn't paying attention sugar it popped oh no I'm sorry where were we oh we're like
getting pretty close though oh this is so much faster though
hot tub stream should just be me and be me and a fish tank honestly that's actually pretty creative
I might steal that uh oh okay we'll get to the next level with wine and then I'm gonna have to go
swordfish and marshmallows because I'm I'm I don't know why I'm getting hit with a wave of
sleepiness but I'm getting hit with a wave of sleepiness I'm sure she's the other I put the
heat in on I have made a greatest error ever I'm not gonna make it I'm funny oh yeah that's what I was
saying I would absolutely love to do like one of those sleeping ASMR streams the problem is I fart in
my sleep so it's not gonna go down well all the amaranth mute I think amaranth muted in her sleep
streams but I don't know how these vtubers and that be doing like live sleep ASMR I'd be I'd be
farting up a storm I'm I'm been I'm being so real like you're brapping your sleep so how are these
girls doing like sleep with me ASMR streams and stuff I'm like how do it anyway no because what
happens if it just sounds really bad what happens if they don't like my toots
we all have her special sleep condition I love biological weapons during my sleep my weapons
of masters but I don't think anyone would complain brah I ain't no woman here
yeah I don't I don't know and like I talk in my sleep as well my mom used to get really freaked out
with it I actually freaked out my grand one time I had a sleepover at her house and apparently like
I sat up really quickly and and my eyes were like wide open she said but I didn't remember any of it
and and when I woke up I was like I don't know why I'm so tired because I felt like I slept really
well because I when I have sleepover my grand we just shared the bed and and she was like
strongy you were sleep like you sat up and you're it's not sleep is a sleepwalking if you
don't move anywhere I was sleep sat up basic clown
be extra tingles added on
um but yeah like I did it to my mom as well and she doesn't like it um
but that didn't I don't know maybe you got you maybe you talking you'll sleep too
and you don't know if it's sleepwalking if you're awake but you're asleep okay
the walking is just more obvious version okay we're learning well then they'll judge your
while you sleep and when you wake up it'll be rooflings only yeah get filtered get filtered
get filtered get brapped get brapped get brapped um
I just think I sleep badly no talking or walking yeah I never remember my dreams but because
I have an alarm set to make sure I'm awake for streams I seem to violently like wake up in the
middle of a dream um we're just a rather cutey it's almost like it's rather cutey
over 20k xp drop created in wine already can you oh there's no like statistic for it though we're
gonna lie
mm-hmm I don't know why Roon Lee isn't tracking my wanes but tracks everything else
stinky
2xp per wane over 100 wane already oh okay okay I'm starting to get it now
did you ever have sleep paralysis I have never suffered from sleep paralysis once
I've had people explain it to me I've never had it in my entire life they say it's when
your body is still asleep but you wake up and your mind but because you're in a certain phase of
sleep things become really scary um and like you realize that you're paralyzed and so
um so it's rather oh I shouldn't have put the heating on I'm yawning again
put on me flings you're making me so comfy and go fall asleep
am I allowed to fall asleep while playing my scoop
scrawny dutch ovens are re- brav ain't no one gonna click on that I mean they might
add a donut sound reward which is me doing an outtake lost recording in audio
oh I was too late on the fermentation but wow 74 okay we're gonna swap to swordfish
and I'm literally I'm snoozing I'm missing the fermentation time sorry but 74 we've already
blasted my 70 prediction out of the water which is so good uh right we'll pop this away for now
and then we're gonna finish off the swordfish batch I do under wait this is E hold on a minute
uh up here oh my god there's 5000
oh no I know I don't don't you don't need to tell me
uh so it's 10 to
okay right let me open up marsh mill because I actually have time to read chat properly now
there's marshmallows there that's a lot of marshmallows
being aquatic creatures do we reef flings when you need to be moisturized asking for a really
important time to pick a question I don't know I feel like we just kind of like hydrate instantly
when we enter the water again like we're fine to be out of the water but it's just where we are
the incoming
the incoming pregnancy is more in lore about how you gave us the girls really gets the
enjoyer and me going but are we going to get a dedicated audio for it I like how viola
felt like our breath of fresh air both in industry and in my roster of each of us love me
oh yeah no I can probably do an audio base around that um it's not a problem at all
I'd just be like give me five babies no more no less that's all I asked
I wrote a little thing on my alternative Twitter only 59k winds to go
brah brah
I'm I'm touching my tentacles and right now I do it out of principle but I ain't even saying
anything that's like good
uh hold on I need to read this one um hi strongy a few things I wanted to say and ask
most of the questions are for later than the line so feel free to disregard them if you need to be
first I wanted to say you and other girls really helped keep me sane last week it was tough but
you made it through oh that's fantastic congrats I don't know if you're a wiefling so I won't call
you wiefling um would you ever consider opening a PO box I am so sorry however um I've discouraged
all girls uh from a PO box opening due to the fact that um air trackers are I think no I'm not
accusing you of putting an air tracker in it or anything like that uh the safety reasons just
completely outweigh the fun that could be in a PO box I do apologize what is a box a PO box is
like a setup location where you can send packages and and I would go retrieve them but for safety
reasons I can't have any of that so I am so sorry but thank you for being interested in sending this
stuff um have you ever considered making a music playlist of your fave songs through wieflings
can listen to offline um if you thought something you guys won yeah my current song that I'm addicted to
is by Eust who's Dutch and the song goes
that's what I'm addicted to right now I like smashed out like five a some more collabs to that song
I just had it on repeat I'm so sorry if it's not your kind of thing
uh but yeah me completely forgetting all the things I have learned oh no I think my my
love of bread is moving in my insides which means I might have to go for a break very shortly hold
on need a hydrate really quick if it's going to come up
oh I just taste that blueberry muffin
um question three not sure if you said you're interested in magic
gathering ah I want to get into it once uh a good place to play without having to pay a
bunch of money on their official app it's an app you can download on the computer called
cockatrice it's every card and you can play in lobbies okay okay okay
uh thanks for answering the questions also love the ASMR can't wait for girlfriend begging to slip
a finger up your arse ASMR ah honestly I wish I could get away with that because that's so funny
and we could definitely see myself doing something oh please please please you've got prostate for a
reason no no the back door it's mine
oh my god didn't you put my tinfoil hat on
for this question I think I do on the topic of black rock like you wanted earlier they're also
deeply into propaganda in the media oh yeah even in gaming and all their head honchos funny enough
for members oh me and riflin on the same wavelength okay I can't read this out because yeah but
okay tinfoil hat gang gang gang gang gang
hi stroney after the comments you made and stream about your
butt today I need you to sit on me and leave an imprint on my face I don't think you'd be
able to breathe darling I think you'd I think you'd need to tap out so I can you know stand up and
not suffocate you all right we'll do it in the ASMR booth how about that convention premium
pass going wild okay you get 20 seconds and if you're still somehow conscious after it you like
get a special prize or something sacrifices mumma
hey stroney you said gen 2 is cooking does that mean we don't have a chance and there won't be
additions oh no sorry uh no when I say gen 2 is cooking it took a year for concept art model
assets emotes all of that it takes a year to do that kind of stuff we're at the stage of going
all the way back to the start all the way back to one paragraph about this girl all the way back to
write what are the names all the way back like we're all the way back there so please don't there's no
one um I said in the exposing viewer stream no one got a call back um there is no call back
there is no me um take off your clothes gen 2 fan here no it is um we're all the way back thankfully
I am not on the heavier side of um development when it comes to names or whatever but it's like
we're now going all the way back um especially like the lower art I need to think of the story
but that's what I mean when I say we're all the way back to gen 2 um
um
or did you just mean characters then models and niches and such yes that's what I meant sorry
to scare you no I will it'll be the exact same pro there's no date there's no date I'm which I'm
so freaking glad there's no date because making a deadline is horrible and I don't ever want to have
a deadline like that again um the announcements for that kind of stuff only will come out when
things are ready and as I said the generation one will be up for a year before gen 2 even like
yeah it'll be at least a year like after do you know I mean I don't know if that makes sense
good night I'ma turn in please rest well sorry I must have too busy rambling sleep well those of
you who need to sleep um but yes uh it's it took a year for development it is not quick it's not
easy it's not fast um and especially when you've got artists that love to go over deadlines um
it makes everything an absolute nightmare um I kind of said a wee bit of it on the
Assassin's Creed Brotherhood stream I had planned everything to occur within certain months
and then everything went to because artists all unanimously went over deadlines so if you're an
artist that works with us look I'm not mad at you everyone did it so you know you know it's fine
but uh everyone went over and it made everything happen in May when May was supposed to be
where I fully focused on getting stuff done for the girls and like we're still kind of
picking up the pieces like I'm doing stuff I shouldn't really have shouldn't be doing at the stage
like it was supposed to be handed off or there's supposed to be something else in place um but it
just a nightmare nightmare nightmare how many marshmallows do you have 850 on the dot actually
850 um yes I don't even know how I got on that rant hey well I still have two ideas for a gen two
what would you want to tell us which one two things that I think would be popular a lollipop dragon
there's no lollipop dragon feature bros curious to get to do it after the pandora on anything
also I think an insect girl in the style of a traditional Japanese geisha who uses her own
self to make her clothes would be popular that's unique I've not heard that not a bad idea
uh I think I need a job I think I need a mute and go hold on it makes me still mix going
hold on a minute refund uh I've a hydrate and then I'm gonna go for a few minutes
I think there's a loaf of bread in the oven if you know what I'm saying hold on any open up my
other bottle of water to hydrate you need hydrate to make it come out like easy
unmute so we can hear you screaming from the bathroom you scream when you take a job or
I'm so sorry I can like feel my my my bills shifting about and I'm like I don't
okay let's do one more bank run and I'll start cooking and then I'll mute because the toilet is
like right there um and obviously I don't want any I don't want I don't want that out there okay
you know I've got big heavy dents you know it's like a big plop I don't want my plop.mp3 out there
you know what I'm saying so I'm gonna go make a loaf of bread I'll be a minute or so I don't
I don't really know how long it's gonna take um but please enjoy I apologize for this interruption
to your usual broadcast
um
You
Are you squiddling me right now?
Plop
You
There was no loaf of bread to be had but to it again
I'm also ovulating like crazy
Just thought you should know
The amount of ink that just came out of me
Holy shit
So I don't mind talking about this cause it's got hands on
Check
When
When whamming ovulate
You get a clear ink that comes out of you
Produced naturally
And I just had that and I was like what?
And I'm ovulating so I'm like
Well
Now is the best time to send any bibbutes
I had no idea
But that makes sense why I'm tired cause
I just want
You know my body wants one thing
Huh? Briefly? Huh?
I have over 2,000 burnt pork, bitch
That's so cool
Good to know
I made my new one
Bro I wish I could have shown you that
Honestly I was like what on earth
Yes
I
I I I
I don't know what's happening with my butt
I need to go number 2
But nothing's happening
You like receiving bibbutes?
Go
I am down atrocious I volunteer
Hey guys you wanna make gen 2 right now?
I'm ovulating
Oh my god we can just say that
Every time I'm ovulating I'll be like gen 2
Come on
I was a dino chicken
Humans are just monkeys with fanfare shoes though
Oh thoughts
Not quite close enough
But a few more evolutionary factors in there
Multiple reefling
Producers, feature, activity
Sorry I'm starting
Well we have over 200 volunteers
I volunteer
We did it we're in the
We're in a million XP
God wines are so fast
We were
I don't even think we were like
I don't even know what we were at the start of the stream
But we're already a million XP
That's fantastic
Seriously we're making
I think the wines really is the vehicle
Aw someone said thank you for existing
You're so awesome reefling
Thank you for existing
Aw
I don't know
Someone is currently anonymously editing for the girls
But they don't want any credit
But we are gonna upload the videos
You don't need to apologize for not subtitling it
Subtitling don't take long on
The videos are like 3 minutes long
So
Are the gen 1 models quintuplets
I like to joke
That I had the girls in my stomach
For like how long
12 months
Yeah I guess 12 months on the dot
Nearly there 598
Oh my god I owe you guys so much
There's some more videos I'm not even uploading the first one
I think I'm gonna be too tired after stream though
To edit and upload the
First one
Oh my god problems are being an overachiever
For now
Have you ever played Metal Gear Solid?
I don't think I've played it
But I've definitely heard of it
Game suggestion
Mad Rat Dead
It's a rhythm platform game on Nintendo
How odd
Creaks
It's a puzzle game with a rare art style
The storyline is decent and you can use it
To interact with chat if you get sucked
I do it like when chat holds my hand through game
How'd you mention SteelSeries during the collab
Hopefully it works well for you
No whenever Azura talks to me
I don't know if the other girls can hear Azura
Whenever Azura talks to me via discord
Her make always cuts out and can't handle her
And I'm like Azura get that noise gate off
And she's like I've not got anything on
And I'm like what is?
Cause I can never hear her
I think the other girls can hear her
But I can never hear her when we have a collab
On discord or anything
And when she gets excited it cuts into her even more
But I don't know if she has discord fillers on maybe
Which is why I'm like ah Azura are you in that SteelSeries
Cause I've said to her a few times now
I'm not annoyed or anything
It's more like a meme where I'm like ah SteelSeries
Someone has sent me a cat box
Should it open up?
Fuck it I'm feeling risky
What is it?
It's a picture
Whoa!
Okay!
Yep
That's the picture alright
Okay I'm not gonna open up any cat box
Links
Well I'm true
Okay
Okay swordfish
Swordfish yes
Share it with a class male
Hi
Would you be okay with me using this whole smegment?
Smegment? Oh my god
I've got cocks on my mind
What the fuck
So small segment of the clapping audio for a meme
Yeah sure
If so would you rather wait now
Now you can post it it's fine honestly
It's cause it's gonna be publicly posted
It's not really an issue to make any of the content a meme
I'm so sorry
Ah frickin
That was
That would poke your eye out
That's what I'm saying
That's what I'm gonna leave out
That would poke your eye out
Um
Oh she's so damn bad just like us
Keep being that lovable goofy gibber you are
Oh thank you Reefling
Strony
Reefling
I listened to the girlfriend begs the whole day tomorrow
I remembered you apologizing but no editing as much
I think at least in this case less editing
I think added to the quality
I'm so frickin glad you agree Reefling
I have been enjoying like not doing scripted stuff and try hard in
Um
Like I have been enjoying recording ASMR
That isn't scripted and I'm doing it off the top of my head
Wait what do you say
There was one part where you seemed to accidentally say
Let me hold your fireman
Then wait let me hold your hose Mr. Fireman
It felt so natural
Cause of how frantic you were becoming
Yeah cause I did it all off the top of my head
Um
I don't know if it was scripted but you also yawned at one point
If it was intentional or adlib it was so natural
No I've been enjoying doing like non hyper edited
Super production of the wazoo
I've been enjoying doing like such casual
Um it's been so lovely
I've been enjoying it thoroughly
I really hope you enjoy the first like thank you for 1000 subs
Cause it's just me meemen
Um
I'm back from work
Okay but how many scrawny hands big was it
I mean
There wasn't a ruler in the picture but
From the glance I got before I closed it
It was pretty
I laughed so much in that part
I don't know if it was scripted or not
But if any of it was scripted
That kind of reinforces my point
So much of the audio scripted
Or not felt natural even the mistakes seemed
No no that was just me
That's just me being unable to read
Unable to read
Unable to formulate my thoughts
Into our proper sentence structure
I know it was just the meme but it was really fun
And good I think it would be neat
To do the natural style more
I freaking agree
I 100% am doing natural style
Open natural style
A
Six a lady
What
It was too early sorry
Okay we're all
As I said we're gonna finish cooking all the swordfish
And then we'll go back to wine
Just cause wine is so demanding
Um
If you want to help hold the hose
During a number one does that mean
I get to hold you up when you go number one
Bruh
I would go everywhere if you did that
Um
Strony
I felt it's imperative to let you know
There's a fortnite skin called Tropical Punch Zoe
That looks shockingly like you
I swear to god if I look like a fortnite character
If I look like a fortnite
Ahh
I can
I can cane to see it
I know what you mean with the bows on our heads
I get it
Yeah I get it
No that's not bad
Thankfully I don't look too much
Like
But I get it
Would only need to ask once to hold off
By the way the subtitles were actually fun
But why didn't you
Make someone else do them
Well when I do all that stuff
There's like
No
Subtitling takes so much time
It's just such a waste of money as well
Cause not everyone reads subtitles
To like outsource that work even further
Is just like
I'd rather just save the money
And spend it on the girls type thing
Because I could have sent that to an editor
And I could have sent that to a video renderer type thing
It's just like
I'll just do it myself
You know
Ooh I've got 14 more questions
Don't mind me
Or is it even a question
Let me know what you think of that in people
I'm not doing live reviews right now
Are you joking me
You guys are gonna like start hearing yourself
In the death of audio
On the topic
Conspiracy series
One game would be a hit to what you play
Disco Asylum
It's basically a spruced up visual novel
Where you play as a deeply
Schizophrenic police officer having a small
Solve a murder while constantly arguing with the voices
All that's interesting
Hold on that looks like nice and niche
Let me give that a cheeky go
Oh god I was preemptive again
We're at 4.8 on our
But nothing happens at all
Okay I can't open that on stream
But you know what you've sent
I love your long streams
I can do my thing
Even go to sleep when I'm back
And you're still there
Thank you for your work
Oh you're more than welcome
I'm glad I can help you
Get ready for working stuff
Listen to me in the background
And then I'm bing-ching when you get back
The kicking sound in old school
Runescape is printed
Oh do you want it off?
Do you want it off?
Or do you want it a little?
I can't even hear it at 2%
You know that 4%
There
I'm gonna like blast your ears
The voices in my head stop
Thank you
Wait why do you
Oh I like them
Ah please
Wait why do you guys not tell me so much earlier
I'm sorry I didn't mean to subject you
To such
Fallacies?
I don't think that's the correct word
But I'm glad you're trying to use words
Outside your comfort zone
Hey Strone
Just wondering when you plan on sitting on my face
Right now
Lie down
Since AI is blowing up
Right now
Any ideas of implementing it in your content?
No
And do you even want to implement it?
I
The only
I wouldn't put
AI content
Like monetize it
I don't think that's right
I don't mind like AI memes of myself
Or something like that
Like that's funny
But like
Actually AI content
Like I wouldn't use AI content
On a thumbnail
And then earn money from it
Like I don't think
I don't think that's very nice
Because as a content creator
Like someone can literally
You know yank your voice
And then make money off of it
And it was like well why would I do the same
To someone else
Like that's not nice
You know
Can you hold it?
Do you think you can handle it?
And
Have you considered trading a chat box
From your stream?
Absolutely not
Are you kidding me?
That all that thing we'll see is
Use the other hole
Refling
Other hole
That all that chat box is going to say
I don't really use Marshmallow very often
If someone wanted to send you a bibliote
How it says
Oh you do
What's called a cat box link
And then you send me the link
And then I look at the link
And the rest is history
Hmm
ASMR Booth Hypnoscript
I've already recorded the
ASMR Booth
Plot
Which was funny as anything
I haven't
Done too much
Hypno
Because
Of Patreon's restrictions
But I do have a four part series
That will go up
On the alternate Twitter for free
Because it's not welcome
And the replacement audio
Is going to be my honey cup of tea
Oops sorry
I'm losing it
I don't know
I don't know why I'm like so sleepy
After eating
I thought you were supposed to get energy from food
You lied to me
Will you permanently scramble my brain
Pretty pretty please
Aw I can't do that
You're supposed to
Be having a good time
Just
Pinching
Hypnosis as a concept
Make great hypnotic focal point
As you sway back and forth
And burn yourself and down
Have you seen
The derriere VTuber models
That you can get
I wouldn't mind that honestly
I think that would be good
Hey mom
Congrats on the second week of debut
I'm one of the newer Mifflin
Hi
Hi Mifflin
I must say
Your constant chatting has become a daily routine
In my life
And completely infatuated with you
Mostly with you
And your girls
So thanks
Oh no thank you
Thank you for being open to
A new like line of content
You made me really happy
In this vacation
And I'm excited for the Lord of the Rings marathon
On Christmas
Oh and
If there's a question
When can we expect your membership streams
Membership streams start next week
You will see it on the schedule
That I post publicly
That
Will go live
After
Buckshot
Roulette
Is when it will go up
There are three member streams
In the first week
And we'll take it from there
And see how we're doing
How we're doing
Remember vibing
Actually no idea
What this is
I need
I think it's called like cat box
Litter box
Or something like that
Is for long enough
Asking for a friend
Replay
Did me mentioning ovulation
Get you all riled up
I was going to show
On
Bansley
Some stuff later on
We're hired wired that way
More than enough
I need to cut the booth
Keep doing that early
I'm not max
A burnt one
Brave
I burnt a swordfish
Who am I?
Who do I think I am?
Just wasting
Litter box
Is time for a cat box
Is the three days
Why is this website Japanese?
I can't speak Japanese
Can you speak Japanese?
No
Why did you pick a Japanese website then?
I thought you were the gamer of the six
Not a weeb
I still love you, you dork
The other websites that offer
This kind of Q&A thing
Are very broken
Cat box
Curious
Cat
Is very broken
So however
This Japanese website
Called Marshmallow
Isn't broken
It's actually very highly functional
Other than the filters
You have to be a smart level
Refling
And bypass the filters
Have you thought of more games
You can play in stream snipes
With the whole chat
In the future
After you get 99k
Absolutely
Every week
I plan on doing
Some version of a stream snip game
You burn swordfish
Until 80 on a range
And 86 on a fire
Yes, no
There's plenty
So Elden Ring
Is our next stream snip game
That we'll be doing
Tons of
November
I know it's quite far away
Definitely lots of Isaac
And
I was going to do
Drunk Apex
But everyone rolled their eyes
At me at the same time
So maybe not Drunk Apex
I don't know
Some sort of drunk multiplayer game
I think Valorant
Also gets shot on as well
And I'm like
But I can have
Four other
Reflings in the lobby
But you
Ugh
How do we
I guess
So sleepy after I ate that food
I don't understand
I had eight hours of sleep
Uhh
You didn't answer
The question
How BB is four enough
Yeah
Don't be silly
Of course it is
Are you going to have
A password set up on Elden Ring
So you can only summon
Reflings
Yeah, of course
Maybe call it shell
Or eyes
Because I hypnotise you
With my
Eyes
But yes
There'll be two
Good reflings
And one bad refling
Like an invader
So we can
We don't get a bonsai
Bonsai
I thought you needed ten hours
Maybe that's why
A big
It wasn't even a big meal
I literally had a muffin
In a nature valley bar
A cup of tea
A cold-out which I've not even
Finished in some water
And my brain's like
Okay, let's go down again
I'm like
Bro
We're not even halfway
Through this endurance stream
So I heard
Mummy was ovulating
Ambient refling
Cicero
Cicero?
Refling
Did you take this correctly
Or did you take it so fast
You didn't
You didn't check
Your spell
And now I can't read it
Because I'm too dumb
Women are EP girls
I can't believe it
Someone said
Plop plop plop plop
Get pregnant
Yeah, you want gen two?
Johnny
I can't wait to be permanently
Under your influence
Oh wait, I already am
I can't get over this trance
Love you mumme
Love you refling
Someone says
I want you
Good thing I'm ovulating
I want you too
Refling
On your my fire
It's gone
I distracted the refling
So much we forgot
To keep up the fire
Thank you for the fire
GGs
That'll be well lasted
Even the runescaper
Is there one handed right now
Why do you stream at 4am
And why is this the time
You wake up to stream
Is it just a spay
Be in particular
No
Also thoughts on Aussie
AFL
Very violent
I've seen some slaps
I've seen some slow mo
Nox
Or the AFL
It's pretty scary
I want to go see a match
Like in person
Just to be like
I'm a real Australian citizen
Wink wink
Why do you stream at 4am
I stream at 4am
Because I'm normally
An endurance strummer
Wait, I'm not cooking anymore
And
If I need to go to a doctor's appointment
Or if I need
No DOOM
Refling
Or I need to
You know, go shopping
Or I need to go
See my Chinese grandma
At the shop
I look squid in mirror right now
Wah!
Oh, Brian doesn't read it out
Don't worry, I'll read it out
KFP Spidey says
Thank you for the stream so far
It's been great listening
While I pack for my move
I was also the red guy
Dancing at the saddle too
Thank you, Brian
And thank you
KFP Spidey
For the five
I appreciate it
I'm sorry, I can't do Brian's voice
I'm so sorry
I tried my best
My sister
Pleased in the AFL
She's messed up with a bump
She too
It is so dangerous
Like the head trauma
You can get
Or like cauliflower ears
If you get blunt force
Trama to your ears by the way
You get a condition called
Cauliflower ears
Where they like spike up
Spike up?
Did he spike up?
Is that right?
But yeah, thank you so much
But please do not feel forced
To hang about
If you're getting a bit tired
Azura Dooley is currently playing
Meow
A bit of stray
A bit of meow
Oh wait
No, not on the ashes
On the fire
Don't be silly
Scottlefish
What is Arsonist Rufland in?
The Wayne certainly helped
With the burn rate
Down to 13.7
Actually, yeah, you're right
I thought you were a meme in there
You said that
But no, I do not stream
At 4am to spay any Aussies
I do it because
I'm actually a knight
I will
Buy default
So it's actually quite helpful
That I stream at this time
If I were to stream at 10am
Because that was the other slot
Imagine being an Aussie at like
Oh no, shock of behaviour
Imagine getting granted citizenship
Wouldn't that be crazy?
I say that as if I'm not going back to Scotland
You know that
Fuckin' spend how much money on that?
I'll say this again
If you ever want to run a business
And you're either
You can do it in the UK
Or you can do it in Aus
Do it in Aus
You will make
You will get to keep a lot more
Of your money
Because of tax purposes
If you set it up in the UK
You're just
Getting absolutely blasted
Brian should now work
On those super chats
If you want to replay
Wait, hold on
Can I replay?
Thanks for the stream so far
It's been great listening
While I've had it for my move
I was also the red guy dancing
At the start of the stream
Yay, Brian works though
Okay, I do apologize
To any super chatters who didn't
Wait, hold on
Wait, I can replay the super chats
Are you squinting me?
I love Stronee as my mommy wife
And she has boing bully
I wear her
Okay, these are replays
Wait, what?
Are you squinting me right now?
I love Stronee as my mommy wife
And she has boing bully
And she has boing boing
She has boing boing
Thank you, Brian, for your...
Oh, no
Is camp log refling gone?
Paramount camp log?
I can't believe it
I can't believe
My poor refling has things to do
Do you have a VR headset?
I don't
Not yet
It might be plausible
I'll be getting one
Because I think...
75?
Oh, my God
Members can now cook
Rock-aids fish
And
Bats
Are you squinting me right now?
Guess who's back, Stronee?
It's me
How are things going here?
I'm level 30
Sorry, I have numbered dyslexia
I was going so well
I'm at 75
Jack
Thank you for the two
I appreciate it
Wait, where the heck did that one go?
And tiny spain-ee
Tiny spain-ee
Thank you
For the...
Sorry, I'm a bit...
I'm not flustered
That's the wrong...
I'm just eating food at the bank
Sorry
I'm not flustered
I don't know why my brain is telling me to shut down
Right now
I'm literally in the middle
I'm like, I'm...
Can you not?
I'll tell you what
I'll order food
And then I will automatically stay up for that food
Because I'm like...
By the way, this is...
Oh, my God
I'm gonna say this in stream
The scriptmaster has just messaged me this
If I write something about Brocon
But
They do not specifically say Big Bro or Sis
Wait, what?
Or Big Bro
But make reference to the same...
Mother
Is that against the rules?
Yes, you can't say that
Yes
You can't say that
Try rephrasing, please
Don't worry, the scriptmaster has your back
That's all I'm saying
He knows the interests of the pinpals
And we're gonna try our best to...
Be up at port
But there you go
Strani, what if you want to get comfy in bed
And then get...
Oh, my God
Are you seeing that meme that's like
When you're...
What's it?
When your sushi roll is sad
Just take your sushi roll
And
Deer her down
Base script...
Bro, the script quality is gonna like
Go up dramatically
After the three month mark
You're gonna know when the scriptmaster came into play
Because you can tell it's like
Not me writing that shit anymore
You're like, oh, God, finally, Strani's not doing it anymore
I say that as if I'm not writing all my own stuff
But I want to write my own stuff
Because I'm passionate about it
Not to say that scriptmaster isn't passionate
But I quite like writing my stuff
Because it feels...
It feels more intimate
When I can like do it between me and Beefling, you know
And we do it together
And I have you in mind
You are my muse, Beefling
You are my muse
Feed the fire for Mumme
Thank you
Oh, that's it
When your girlfriend is sad
Lira in a blanket
A ruler
Yeah, yeah, yeah
That's the one
Sometimes it's nice being a little bro
Well, little bros are for zero
Big bros in me
Yours are exceptionally good
Aw, that's very kind
I like...
I did have the option to hand over
My scripts to someone else
But I like doing it between us
Really need this fire
Making XP for real, for real
I imagine you and the other girls
Write their own stuff
There was a handful of girls
Who wanted to give their hand at it
I absolutely did not expect it
Because it's just more time
And I don't want the girls like
Stressing out over that kind of thing
But yeah
I just don't want to stress the girls out
If they want to do it of their own violation
Violition? Violition?
Then that's perfect
Did I just hear them?
I guess she's not happy
I fed her
Oh well
Day 10 of eating celery daily
It's so bad
Oh no, don't put yourself through
Celery for that
Celery is nasty
I've never enjoyed it
I'm sorry
Doesn't matter how much humus
You put on it
Violition? Violition?
Did I just say it funny?
Volition
Volition!
There's no I
Okay, we're getting there
Stopped to fluster us
Exactly
Oh my goodness
Violation
Oh no, now you're getting me confused
Yeah, I love your scripts
On Patreon Strony
Thank you!
I did them off the top of my head myself
I'll be very curious to see
What the donathon results in
I have
I imagine the week after the donathon concludes
I will be having very short streams
So I can focus on the rewards one at a time
I know some agencies had a bit of problems
Trying to handle streaming and getting rewards out
Obviously, because I'm such an unbelievable
Bad workaholic or good however you want to
Good for people who like content, content, content
Bad for the actual workaholic themselves
Because they just non-stop keep going
But I think I definitely am in a position where
I can get stuff out relatively quick
Whether that be an audio, a collab audio
Yeah
Maybe those are good if you want your money from birds
I have a huge backlog of willow logs from doing forest streams
Short streams, like 10 hours instead of 12
For me, a short stream is 2 hours
Which I think someone said
That's literally what the regular stream time is
For the average YouTuber
And I'm like
2 hours is me doing stuff in the background
I'm not being funny
If you look and you see I've done a 2 hour stream
And nothing else that day
That means I am doing so much work in the background
Type thing
Is that these strony culls?
There's only one of them in this world baby
Time to cook through my 3k swordfish
Literally that's what I'm doing
Just getting through it
It takes her 2 hours just to start playing the lamo
Management got me there
Hydration check
Hi strony
In the most loving way possible
I want to bury my face in your butt until you pass out
While you hmmm yourself
You're too hot
Just your gentle talk is enough to get me going sometimes
When you talk about other hot things
I need a moment to calm down
Oh my god Rythme
Got me blushing and shit
Stop
I'm glad I have that control of you
That power
Makes me very happy
I'm a bit too happy
I think I take a little bit too much
Pleasure from such a thing
Is that terrible?
I'm sure do have powers
Terrorist to boot up
What is this a Windows 95?
No cause I want to stop yapping
I love to eat sushi
I could do it for hours
Oh yeah
Is that because I'm a cutlery?
Oh I keep wanting to freakin make that
What does your Oshii smell like meme?
Because
The reason is
What's the reason?
Oh because I use a lemon scented soap
I wanted to post it and be like
This cutlery comes pre-seasoned
And then I think there's only one other girl that needs to do it
And then everyone knows what the whole revealer smells like
6,000 subscribers reached
What?
We celebrated 5k
Oh my gosh
Fish
Ah
What?
I'm really excited
Why is it getting so hot?
I'm so confused
It shouldn't have been
Statistically yet
It should have only been pushed to 5k people
It's bizarre
I didn't expect that at all
Are you squiddling me right now?
Yeah
Thank you for the tip
Milk Cadmus
Any milk cadmets?
Thank you for saying it
I'm so confused
I'm like daddy you make a tweet and be like
I can't believe it but under 24 hours
The one thing, I've mentioned this in another stream
The one thing I do not like about being a VTuber in this context
Is you have to play the numbered games
And you have to play the
Oh thank you for this
In terms of milestones
And it's a hard one to navigate
Because if you don't say thank you thank you
You look almost ungrateful
But if you do say thank you thank you
It looks like you're counting and waiting for the next milestone
Just so you can spam thank you thank you
You don't have to say thank you
Well the problem is
I'm trying to get like
Gratis on 6k a moment
Thank you Luthe Reefling
The thing is
It would be really good to get on VTuber news
Or any kind of source like that
Because it brings more attention to the girls in general
Which is why it's like
I don't want people thinking I'm counting
But what I'm thinking about is the probability
That it could gain new eyes to the girls
Because I want nothing for them to succeed
I've got everything I want right here
I've got my Reeflings
We're freaking meman
We've got member streams
We've got multiplayer games
We've got ASMR
The Wazoo coming out
I've got collabs of other VTubers
That are willing to interact with me
Like I've got everything I need
I'm so freaking happy
I want the girls to achieve their dreams
And the truth of them achieving their dreams
Is one to have enough money to be a content creator
Some of them are looking to move out
Some of them are looking for upgrade equipments on their own
You know, Emmie was fantastic
She's already designed her 2.0 model
Because it feels more like her
That kind of thing
I want the girls to have it
Some of them wanted 3D models
I wanted them to get it
And the truth of the matter is
In order to get these things
There needs to be eyes on the girls
So I can help them achieve their 3D goals and stuff
Although someone said that
Someone was like, what do you mean by the 3 year mark?
Whenever I mention the 3 year mark
Congrats to whoever leveled up there
The reason I say 3 years
Is because statistically 3 years
And you're done
You're persona, you're whatever you want to call it
Emmie Bezos
Oh my god, you really look like Emmie as well in games
The reason why 3 years is this mysterious number
Placed on someone's head
Is because that statistically
If you do find success
By the third year
The success goes unless you make
You change your content up dramatically
And the reason I say 3 years
Is because
Before you're like wait
So Strongie's only got 3 years
Relax, stop doing it
Relax, no
No, that's not
It's very possible that Strongie and
Like once we're all satisfied
Like I won't stop until you guys are ready for me to stop
Like please don't
No, don't do it
But please don't think I'm just going to abruptly stop
Overnight
Like that's not the reality of the situation at all
It's very likely
I will want to focus on hypnosis
Audio is like way down the line
It's over
No, so never
No, if you don't want me to go
I'll be streaming in my little retirement home
Doing my thing
I've got an end in stamina
Like seriously this is
Just it took so long to get here
And everything worked out in the end
And it just feels so nice to be
I don't know, I just
Like to be accepted
To be just having fun
Folk want to hang out
It's just casual
It's none of this like
You know
Art say fart say like
Oh this VTuber is giggling their head off every two seconds
And this VTuber is like
Putting on this like
Horrifically fake personality
Pina, thank you for becoming a member
The first year is an introduction
The second is establishing and third is plateau
That is quite literally what it is
That is what most people experience
If you've ever been like
Why did that one in the VTuber
Go on a new account
That's basically remaking a persona
Because you plateau
And it's perfectly natural to plateau
There's no issue
Only 155 more
Thank you Peter Everingham
For becoming a member
I appreciate it
I'll be honest with you all for a sec
Let's see what's up
Question mark
What's up
Or does this refling share with us
We will
Strony until we die at 99
Because it's part of our little heart
I fart
Okay you're done refling
Deeply departed
He came and he farted
Damn you and people can't just do the same thing successfully
Without ever needing any variation in their content
I haven't seen examples of that before
Yes
I really like the behind the scenes psychology
About it all
Monster girls
Please
Thank you for becoming a member
Is that you asking for gen 2 designs to be monster girls
Oh boy you're in for a treat
Um
Yeah
There's been 2 designs that have been accepted
Lololololol
Um
Mods take some of his pennies
And scatter them across his home
Wait that's so specific
Oh I don't know
I feel like you feel happy streaming
I can see that
I can't imagine mome
Without this
There was obviously
Right actually I can tell you something behind the scenes
And you're not gonna like it but it's no longer the case
Because I got script manager in
If and when gen 2 came around
There was no way I could keep up with the daily streaming
And trying to organize all the script stuff
Um
But thank you to script master for coming into play
Because without them
Being there
With gen 2 starting
I probably couldn't daily stream
So
That's the honest truth
I was gonna stream my ass off for an entire year
Like non-stop back to back double streams
On some days doing like endurance this
Endurance that
But thankfully that's no longer the case
Um
Obviously
When
Gen 3 were to occur
That's a lot
Of girls to manage
And I'm not sure how realistic the daily streams
Will be at that point
Is my only concern
And the thing is none of us have a crystal ball
To look into the future
So I can't tell
By 0 by 0
By 0 every day is a blessing
No don't cry don't do him don't do him
We're not even there we've not even
We've not even got the first model of gen 2
Literally we have fucking 2 approved concepts
That's the
Don't burn out in spite
See that's the thing spite can get you very far
Maybe I will
Spite everyone and just say
I'll stream daily and you guys weren't ready for it
It's so jovert nyo
Less than 6kxp
For 80 million hp
And I'm just chillin here
Banned from shame
Braptuber allegations have not been been
No
The future in the game background is making me feel more
Okay no no no happy thoughts
Happy thoughts
If you can do this
In not even 2 weeks
I can't imagine what you're gonna do in a year
I mean
It's not really gonna change
Sorry
This is
Me having happy times
We do have some monthly events planned
Um
Type things
Going on got ASMR collabs planned
I think ASMR is like a bread and butter
Please
Please consider ASMR
As a bread and butter viewer
Some people kinda get annoyed when ASMR
At ASMR
VTubers dabble
In ASMR and don't always like commit to it
Fully but no it's bread and butter
I think everyone's gonna be participating in it
Juicily
Can you spit on us
Yeah you want me to spit all over your face
Open it
Open your mouth
Let me spit on your face
Um
Yeah don't
Don't worry like
Ah frickin you know how open and honest
I'm gonna tell you what it looks like
And what things are like and you know
People who do watch you can get little
Tip bits of information
Early access information
VTubers ASMR
Finally someone combined two of my favourite things
Well I actually got a lot of feedback
Where people were like
I am so tired of like VTubers
Blue bowling
And they'll participate in something
And then withdraw
And
Because they never really had a thing for it
And I was like oh my goodness
Aren't we hitting the
Hammer on the head with a nail
And the nail on the head with a hammer
Wait other way around
Finally hitting the nail on the head with a hammer
Because
It's quite literally
Like all of us are completely fine
Thankfully things are coming
A member
No refling
For the tip
No I'm not freaking leaving
Like I'll tell you the plan
I'll always tell you the plan
What the deal is
Like when have I freaking
I mean I'm only hitting like what
NDA content
Even then what NDA content
Have I got left behind at this point
Oh a hydration
I'm gonna have to drink some water
Need some water
Water from my bottle of water
The farm is the real plan trust
Trust in the farm
Someone says where should I eat
I'm getting Mexican
I've ordered it
Hold on let me check
Let me check where my Mexican food is
Hmm
And before it's sitting outside
Oh wait hold on
Wait scriptmasters asking
What are you even
So the sentence mom says I'm in charge
Is way over the lane
Yuck
Yes
Because that implies
Sorry you guys are getting correction
Yes come on please
Okay there we go sorry scriptmasters
Trying to really help out the pinpals here
I'm trying to tell them like
You need to skirt the patreon to yours
I don't know
Boring inside yourself
Okay
We will have a castle
And I'm gonna let it out a little cafe
Okay
That sounds like a scary
Oh a spicy script
Very much so
Azura's four part series
Got finished main
My four part series is now gonna be
On Twitter for free because
It's not allowed
So I'll need to think of another four part series
Maybe
He's feeling a cheeky Chinese
Takeout honestly
Chinese and Australia is amazing
It's so good
Have exciting
Bye bye I have to sleep
Have an ice stream
Thank you so much
For anyone who needs to sleep
Or I need to get a few things done around
The house
Or you need to get some water in you
Please don't be afraid to go do so
Keep yourself as healthy as possible
A succulent Chinese meal
Oh I should do a Scottish dub of that
What have I done wrong
Just enjoying a meal
A succulent Chinese meal
Dubbing
Dubbing memes
But I'm Scottish
Video
Honestly
Maybe that would work out
I feel like that's got potential
A wee bit of potential not too much
Get your hands off
My tajer
This
Is
Democracy
Manifest
Get your hands off my
Cuttlefish star
Honestly maybe we might be onto something
A little funny ha ha series
I can go there
Unhand my hose
Hell nah
I've got to stay and see the end of the day
That'll be AAM
That's so unhealthy though
You should sleep
Only I can do such endurance things
Cause I'm a big girl
If there's anyone lurking
Who is perishing
Azuriduli is on
Stray
Azuriduli is playing Stray
And Mercy Modest
Is playing Harvester part 2
Azuriduli is live
Mercy is live in T-minus
1 hour 30
I repeat in T-minus 1 hour 30
Modi
Mercy Modest is live
Wow someone levelled up
Congrats
Ah
I see you know judo well
And you are ready to receive my
Limp
Just like the blue
Scottish Power Ranger
Honestly
Pick the memes right
And it's probably got a lot of potential
I thought about doing like
Reading the most bizarre
Reddit stories
Cause there's a really famous one
Where this guy broke both his arms
But I can't say the rest of it
But I wanted to read it
Cause I thought it was alright
But I'm not sure it would work out
Maybe it would be like a twitter series
I guess
I'll be like oh go subscribe to my youtube
My youtube
Time for work unfortunately
Have a good stream
No you have a good work day
How dare you
Please remember to hydrate and look after yourself
And remember
Boss makes a dollar
You make a dime
That's why you take a big job beyond company
time
Please make sure that any stress levels
Are
At your pay grade
If you get paid minimum wage
That's not your problem
Should have paid you more
To care more
Damn
Get back
Oh is that
The arm where he gets some help
Read the number 15
I bought blue bed
Burger king foot lettuce
I've already forgotten the freaking
What the frick I just said the B version of the meme
Burger king foot lettuce
That's the thing you want in your burger king
Burger king
Boot lettuce
Oh my god what
Do a 5 part audio where you're getting paid
Prego we each door
How would I do that though
Oh yeah give me a broken
Oh no
That's not gonna work
Maker ginger
Maker blue hair but no
What
We can't make that
I've got a sea queen
Audio coming out
Where I share you
With all my daughters
And
I always take a hmm first thing
On my shift if you're good at something
Never do it for free exactly
The Joker was a kitten
That's what food coloring is for
Didn't you get
With all the girls at the same time
In the ASMR booth with the eyes covered
Yeah basically that's how it happens though
But yeah I've got a sea queen audio
I think it'll be a donut on reward
Like cause the girls
Are all gonna like help each other out
With their donut on rewards like
As a
As a like yeah let's go
Sea queen that's the only way we can
That's the new saying
POV all the girls are fighting over you
The one human left on earth that hasn't
Decided on which girl
I thought about
I see an Emmy doing something like that
Where they're fighting over
Where the ink goes
Or who the ink goes to
Sea queen
Yeah I mean that's pretty creative
I'll give you that that's pretty creative
Yeah I see an Emmy with a hundred percent
Fight over it but I find it really
Hard
To do that kind of
Seven
Five hundred swordfish and I burned two
K of them I burnt so much swordfish as well
Don't worry
Where the ink goes yeah
If Emmy and I see ever collab like that
I would be so happy
I mean they already got a collab audio on the way
Of that nature
But it's a bit
Different
Do you want spoilers or do you not want
Spoilers I don't mind doing spoilers
I think it's coming up
Is it August the collab audio start
Of I think it might be
It's got to be really hard to do
I want spoilers
No spoilers
Oh no you guys are split
Go hard with spoilers
So in the plot
Close your ears if you don't want
Any spoilers in the plot
AC and Emmy fell out
And you
The listener
You can either be a pin pal
Or a snowberry
You force them to
To make up
By
Using a massage gun
To relieve their muscle tension
Because their muscle
Tensions the reason why they fell out
Hmm
Okay
Then me and Mercy have one
Where we're
Nurses that shouldn't be qualified
Because of what we do
And then
Azura and Sheeby's one
I don't think the masses
Are gonna like it
I'm not gonna change it
Because I like the script
I like it but I'm not sure the masses
Are gonna like it
Can Sheeby
Catch you in public
Um
Cross-grossing
And they m-word you
And I don't know if it's gonna
Go down well or not
It's a very unique scenario
But please
And before you're like oh my god I hate it
Oh my god Strony I hope you die in a fire
Because you wrote that
Do you honestly think they're never gonna do another collab audio again
Don't be so silly
The first one that I gave
Yeah it was pretty sp- it was pretty
Out there I don't know it's just the
Inspiration I got to write for them
Till I wrote it and there it was
And they what
Holy moly this is spicy meatball
A massage gun yes
A massage gun I'm excited for that
It's spicy
Oh boy that one does sound very uh
Yes uh
That sounds like something
Patreon would get no they don't
They don't care um
I know what's uh good
To go and what's not good to go on Patreon
So damn y'all really pretty
Yeah
There's a few things I wanted to cover um
Having the freedom to explore a
Bunch of scripts
Is something the scripts have
Yeah like um
It's just different things were hitting along
The way like as I said
I kind of said it from the start
I'm not pigeon
Holding any girl
Into a particular
Category because doing so
Will limit their
Income source and their income source
And longevity are related
To their success of the allure
And I do not want
To kneecap anyone
That's not fair
It is what it is
In spaces scenarios compared to anything else
I've seen this is some top two content
Yes and
Literally when the girls do collab audios again
They still have three other audios
Going out that month as well so it's not like
You know not everything can be for you
We live in a society
Of burnt fish
I like to try different stuff yeah
Literally just give it a shot either
You'll listen to it and you'll be like this isn't for me
Or you'll be like okay
I'm reacting
Smile
There's only two outcomes
It's either no thank you and turn it off
Or I'm reacting smile
We'll get
We'll all get something at some time
Yeah basically literally everyone
Is here for
It's not possible
For a creator to come out with something you love 100%
At the time it's just not possible
Unless they do the same thing over and over
Again but then that is like
Really pigeonholing and it's
For the success of my girlies
Okay
They gotta succeed
Or what's gonna make them wanna sign their
The second year of the contract huh
Can't wait to find out
What it is I love
AC and Katelyn so much
Aw I'm glad
Thanks
Thanks for reading it
Anyway
They just misspelled
Something that said it wrong or something
It's okay
I'm not into feet but I like curious
Oh yeah
I love everything
Viewers done so far thank you
You know I had a year
In the making and
Just everything has fallen into place
So beautifully
I spoke to
I'm gonna butcher her name
So badly
The beach of her obaque
That's definitely not how you say it
But
She was talking about a project
Finally coming together and
You know I was like oh I can completely
Relate to that so I replied to it
And I was like
When the puzzle pieces finally arrive
And you can start slotting them into place
It's so satisfying
And
And I felt that to my very core
Obaque
Yeah it's not obaque
There's no way that's how you're supposed to say it
Sounds like I'm trying to say tobacco
Obaque
That's exactly how you say obaque
Oh wow
Not me
Accidentally being smart
I can't believe it
Obaque
It is the first try
I'm so smart with the heck
Yeah she put up a tweet
Saying her projects are finally coming together
And I'm like oh I can relate to that
On such a deeper level
And
When we succeeded to be
Five moods ahead in her main chess game
I can't wait to
One be one years in chess actually
I'm not ready
Tobacco stream
No, no tobacco
I can't smoke
I can hardly drink
To the life of me
I get one beer in me and I'm gone
That's why I wanted to do drunk apex
Because we can all do Salt Lake city server again
Because no one's in it other than us
I don't know what drunk game
I wanted to do drunk game
But I don't go offline until we win
Type of thing
But I didn't know what game to do
If I lose
I get to see discord route
What?
Wait
What if you lose the one be one chess
You get to see the discord where we all say inappropriate stuff
To each other
Say no in that one chief
I've been a lazy reflin
You haven't
Have you not checked any of them out
Actually the highlight
Reels are from debut
Or right around the corner
I think there's one more girl that needs to be made
And then the debut highlight
Things can be made
Can be uploaded
Check them out
What opening do you use in chess
I call it the twat move
Because I don't know what on earth
Is my opening move
Probably the
Second pawn
Just shove them out by two
Have a week go
I don't know nothing about chess
All I know is that I want a one be one you guys
In chess and I'll put classical music
On in the background
And I'll see if I can even win against
One refling
It'll be interesting to see if I can win one game
I can easily recommend girls
Like a shopkeeper
I have a secret conspiracy
Strony allows a small handful of fans
Into the discord every month or so
To be grim by the girls
Then makes them forget and kicks them out
It's actually quite funny
No I assure you
Absolutely nothing goes on in the discord
Mercedes ASMR was a banger
Is there meme ASMR
No I didn't upload it
Her actual ASMR stream got
25,000 views
Which is insane
Insane in the membrane
Can you drill my dad
I'm terrible at chess
But he plays it daily
Are you joking me he'd like smoke me in one
You can play checkers
And connect four richest people here
What in runescape
Play checker
What play connect four with me in runescape
Right now what
How'd I do that
Is that real
At the grand exchange
Hold on wait let me finish
Doing this batch of fish
We're going to the grand exchange like right now
Hello
Where's the grand exchange
A little to the right
Oh there's a bridge here
We don't have the fricking tunnel at the grand exchange
We're going to have to go down in our wall
What we can
Fricking 1v1 each other
Right we're going to the grand exchange
To play connect four I'm not even kidding
I'll empty my inventory though
I don't want to go filthy
Stranny I'd feel bad about beating you in chess
Oh no that's the thing I like losing
You know
Dom loss and all
You see you know if I lose against you after you said
You have never played would be such a sad and depressing thing
I would need something to feel happier
Get plopped get plopped get plopped
There you have it
I'm joined listening to you
I'm playing Overwatch in the meantime
Oh god how is Overwatch these days
I know a new character came out
Venture but
Um
Folk weren't happy about or something
I've nothing
Apparently she eats rocks
Lamal
Here
Right
Right we're going if any
Reflings want to follow me just follow my character
And then
We'll go down to the grand exchange
To play connect four
Any Reflings want to come
Right okay
We're going to the grand exchange
To play connect four no I'm not trolling
We're doing it
Oh wait I should walk because that Reflings walking
Oops
No no no we got the Reflings caught
Oh no wait hold on we need to help this Reflings that stuck
Okay there that worked
Yeah it worked okay we got that Reflings
We'll walk around these borders until we're out
And then I think it should be okay
Going to the grand exchange
Four in a row
Me also me
It's going to take me so long to get 99
Cookin also me
Let's go to the grand exchange
Just so we can play some video
Well we already are playing video
We've got all that raw fish that needs to cook
As the grand exchange of the trading hub
It absolutely is
Oh wait we can follow
We are following rabbit
There's an entry to the west of the grand exchange
Wait I thought it was blocked for members only
I don't have any agility though
Yeah
Isn't this
Huh
Playing video on a video
Opening in the wall
We're learning to
Thanks for being in human history
Oh no we're playing chess
And the loser must be the winner
For the day oooh
What's going to happen
It's annoying tanking
Is but
Oh right okay
Okay where the heck
Are we playing connect 4
How do we do it
This
No
Talk to who
Talk to them
Wants to play a ranked game
Of runelight
2 minutes per move
Oh no
What does this mean
Uh
Ranked
Wait you have ranked
Chairs in runescape
Uh I'll be
Green nature rune
Challenge
What
Oh no
I didn't mean to place it there
Okay well I'll put it there then
Uh
Oops question mark
Wait we can like
Straight up no
You're not supposed to actually win against me
What the heck
Uh
Uh huh
Oh no I'm going to lose
Wait they can go like that
Oh no
What have I done Franklin
What is that
And then that
Oh no wait
Oh no I messed up
I lost
Okay
Wait okay you win
Does it end
I'm so bad at this
Did it win
Okay it ended
Let me try again
Oh no my rank went down by 47
Oh no right
Next reflim play me
Uh
How do I send a request to reflim
Or do you guys send me a request
I don't know how to send a request to play
Uh
I don't know how to play either
Okay you
Send me
I've not played drew yet
Right I'm being
I'm being green
Did I get to go first?
Okay I do get to go first
Yeah well take that then
You stinky
Okay
Uh
Take that
Okay
This is terrible
Wait what are you doing
I'm trying to look at what the reflim
A block them there
Oh this is awful
Oh no you guys can see my thought process
Oh no I lost
I can't put one in one here
So how do I win
Put it here
Oh no
You guys can see how dumb I am
Wait what does that mean
Okay I need to go up here then
Maybe like do this
No I'm just gonna do that
Oh
I don't know
Oh no you're gonna ruin it for me
Both of us don't want to play
In these ones
Well I don't want to play because it's gonna get blocked
What are you doing
What happens if you go there I don't know
One two three
Uh
I don't know how to do this
This is terrible
Can I put one here maybe
I'll put one there
Oh no they can like win again
Replayings this is so hard
I don't think I can win
I can't put any here or I lose
Or here
So I'm basically just stacking
Them to the ceiling
Until we can anymore
And then do
No
Wait what
You guys are cheating right one more
New refling
New refling this is so
Bronze connect four
No right refling do it again
Okay you
Surely I could win one
Uh
Right
I'm gonna go in the middle
Surely
Surely I can win
Okay I'll go above you now
Um
Okay no you're just
Mimicking me
Um
Yes
Are we just mimicking each other
Oh
Uh
I'll put it
Here
I don't know why I'm putting it
Wait why did you
Wait could I have one there
No I couldn't have
I'll put one here
Oh this is hard
I'm like touching my face
I don't think I can actually
Win against any of you guys
Oh I could have had it
One two three
Maybe
Maybe if I stack
Here
I can do like this up here
Uh
Is he gonna try and go up there
Did you let me win
I can't tell if you let me one
Wait
Wait you didn't mean that
Did you not see that
Huh
I can't tell
Did you mean that
Are you at the restaurant
I didn't see that either
Oh a little distraction
I have not played
I've not played tiny
Calls
Let me be green
So pretty
Okay
Okay uh-huh
Oh yeah uh-huh
Check that
Okay
Okay this is drivers at the restaurant
Okay okay you're gonna do that
Better oh I'm gonna preemptively
Strike
Okay
Using them cosmic rings
Flash your opponent to distract
Okay let me get the bikini toggle
Oh
Okay we'll do this
Unvented
Uh-huh
Yeah
Um
We should do like speedruns
We just have to slap them down
Okay
Uh-huh
Uh
Oh no
Wait have I fucked up
A little bit
A little bit but I'm allowed to mess up a little bit
And if I put it here
Oh no you put it there
Wait I'm putting it here then get rigged
Mmm
Oh my god
Reflings why are you so smart
Reflings
Why are you so high I can't
Thank you
Uh-huh
Oh no
Oh my god
You stress me so
So much
I don't know what to do
Shawnee go in the third column
No
He's gonna win
If I go in the third column
He'll go there
And he gets four in a row
None of us can play the third column
Cause if he plays the
Wait why did you do that
Why did you do that
Uh-huh
Did I distract you
Wait why did you do that
Did you mean that you win
You're right I'm blind
Uh-huh
I think you guys are just letting me win now
I'm gonna be honest
No matter where I went
You would have won
Oh really
Just Yummy I've not played you
Uncle Green
Ah
What's this
What do I do
What
What is this
Oh no I don't know how to play checkers
Can I just mimic what he does
Just to annoy him
I don't know
I'm not playing this game
Wait
How did you do that
How did you get there
Yeah
That's right Reflin what are you gonna do
I'm gonna mimic you
Get ready Reflin
Uh
How did you do that
You went back up here
Right
I'll change my pattern
I won't cheat
I don't know what I'm doing though
I think we're just playing
crisscross apple sauce
One of the coolest games ever
Losing all the rank and honestly
Yeah you actually played well
intentionally or not
Wait actually
Oh god
You know what I think about
I'll go here
Wait I'll go here
Wait that's not how it works
Is it like the
I'll go here then
Oh no here sorry
More of them went green
I didn't even mean that
I don't know what this is
I'm having fun
Are we drawing Pipi
No
Did he do something here
That was juicy
Whatever that did
Okay Reflin made a move
I want to make a move here
Oh shite
I'm losing at me
Oh no what did I do
Here
No I can't
You know if I just click the board
Oh there we go there we go
Something changed
Taking mummy out of her element
Mixer here
I'm so dumb you're all gonna know I'm so dumb
It's not your turn
Okay
Shaisa
Shaisa yeah
Oh no it's my turn
Can I go here
Can I go here?
Okay I can go there
Let him get open
Mmm
You have to signage the pieces to rent the player
Oh no what did he do
I wasn't paying attention
Can I go here? No
Oh I can! How did that work
I don't know how I did that
I'm warning you now Reflin
I'm taking this entire route
Fuck you I'm taking this route
How does this work
I don't know
This is the most confusing game
Oh it's my turn
I didn't even see what you changed
Here
Oh that was a terrible move
Here?
Okay that was a good move
Uhh
I'm not sure
He made that right up there
What does that mean for me
I don't know
Can I do this?
I can do that
I'm just clicking on the board
I'm going to be honest
Stony can you hear
your thick accent for a little bit
I'm dying to hear it
Oh you can't
Oh no
I want here
Okay thank you
I got here
Uh
Is he
your turn
God this checkers game is hard
Oh I think I messed up
I maybe shouldn't have played that
Oh no
Umm
Who's with us at night
I don't even know if this Reflin
knows what he's doing
If you are this cute when playing
Uhh
Oh that love heart solo
Corners are power spots
When playing I can agree on chess and during stream
I'm too dumb for connect 4
Is it my turn yet? Oh no it's not
Okay now it's my turn
Yeah get rekt
I see you still winning son am I
Oh no you two back
Wait how do I take it back
No give me back give me that
That's mine
Stop you're taking
Oh no
That didn't do anything
I think I'm losing
What does that do
Like this
Does that do something
I don't know what I'm doing
I think I might
I think we have to admit defeat unfortunately
Oh I'm getting ruled
Everything's getting taken
I don't have the strength
Reflins I'm doing so bad
Uh
Connect your pieces
Oh corner someone says corner
I'll play the corner
Oh sugar that didn't do anything
Oh no
We are
Okay green green I see green
Green
Uh but that turn green
A little bit green
I guess it's like splatoon where you want
Everything to be your colors
Oh that didn't do anything oops
I think I just threw that
You lose the board just filled
Oh no that was so hard
That was confusing
Uh maybe we
Only do the other one
Oh Amy wants to play yeah sure
Amy will play
Amy's turn
I have never played it before either I'm dumb
Right Amy you're getting ruled
I'm going here Amy
And you're not going to have a clue
What's going to hit you because I'm so good at this game
I have the peeler
Uh here
Here
What are you thinking
I'm trying to get in your head
Or actually you're a pen pal
What were you doing pen pal
Are you trying to embarrass me
Oh shit you're about to get that
Oh what
How did you do that
I never even saw that
That was like my fastest freaking law
Pen pals are ruling me
I never saw that at all
I was too busy focusing on my little right side play there
You've not played against you yet
I'm going green
Your turn first
Uh okay I'm going here this time
And then here
And then
No you're not supposed to do that
You're supposed to let me win
Um
I'm
I'm in shit
Cree
I'm going to just do this
I think I've already lost
We didn't even start to do it
I think I lost
I'm not supposed to see my
MLG pro moves
I don't know what I'm doing
Oh no
I lost
I never saw that
Womp womp
Wait you didn't see that
Oh no you can win anyway like double time
Yeah I was going to say you already won
You could have won down here
Wow this is so hard
I don't know how people play this
Anymore of these things
I want to play
I'm not playing you again
Oh wait I might miss that
You can't do that here
I'm sorry I need to like come in the area
Sorry
Hold on try that again
I'm not playing you yet
Right
Maybe
You win
Another player resigned
Did you mean that
I don't think you meant that
Do you want to try again
Okay there we go
The other player is busy
Wait what
Alright let me be green
You try again
Okay my turn
I will go here
Sugar
No you smell
Stop it
Stop it you smell
Okay I'll go here then
Hmm
I don't know
What are you doing
What are you planning
No what are you planning
What does it mean
I don't know
How do this
No you're not supposed to go there
This is hard
No don't win
Don't be selfish let me win
Don't be selfish
Let me win
No I have to put it down
No
I don't want to put it down
Stop it
You're teasing me
Stop it no wait
No
No I want to win
I want to win
No
Come on
Why is this game so hard
Why is it so hard
This is terrible
Alright cool again
There has to be one reefling in here that's called lower IQ than me
Come on
I've not played through yet
There has to be a reefling
That has a lower IQ
What the heck is this
What do I do
Examine
What
I don't know what to do
I click it
Wait it's not let me do anything
Huh
It's not let me do anything
Hello
Examine board game piece
Huh
You move and jump diagonally
Oh
Okay okay
You hold it and then drop it
Wait I'm getting pranked
Why
Why am I getting pranked
What what what happened
Wait
No
What
I think it's a bit laggy
Can I just start moving them everywhere
No
I'm sorry
Okay wait
I can't move them
No
So I move you
What the heck
Then you block me
So I block you
What
Huh
Can I go back
A legal move
Bro I don't even know the rule book
I don't want to get jailed
No
And what
Like this
No I can't
Can I maybe
I don't
Wait what
Like this
Okay that was a load
Why are some things loaded not
Oh
Uh
In the name of the checkers board
Wait I can't do that
Hold in the name of the checkers
Hold in the name of the checkers board
What
This is crazy
I'm sorry my little brain can't
Do this
Maybe we just play the four in a row
You can only move one tail
If you're jumping over an enemy
As many times as you can
What happened
Something happens
You can only jump a tail
So here
No
It's not your turn oh sorry
What and then do that
What the heck
Am I accidentally winning right now
I might be
It's plausible
Oh you can't go back you can only go up
Okay
Wait they didn't do anything
Can you be like gridlocked in this game
Yes
Uh sure go up there then
Wow what am I doing
I can't go back
If you reach the end of the board
You get knighted
Oh
Oh no he won
I lost again
Reflames
Oh my god
I don't know what I'm saying
No he won
I can't go back
And won't let me go back on him
Right okay what can I do
I can't even go forward or anything
I just did that
Game ends when all the pieces are taken
How can they be taken
We can't go backwards
I don't get it
I'm so confused
He's not won yet
What
I don't know what's going on
Wait so if he comes here
I can only jump forward one
Oh
This is too hard
Oh no what happened
Something changed
I don't know
So I can't go backwards
I can only go forward
Well then I might as well push forward then
Surely
Surely that's how it works
Okay
And now then I take you
No I can't take you
You're too far away from me
Then I push you forward
To play
I guess
No I don't one at a time
Sorry one move at a time
Apologies one step
Oh this is so hard
Oh no my guy got taken
Wait how do you
So I can only go one way
Then that would push
What that pushes him there
And then I can't push up so I need to do that
Oh no that blocks him
Oh I didn't mean to do that
What does a knight do
I don't know
I'm not sure
Can he take everything now
And then can go backwards
Oh wait
So I just need to move him forward
Like here
Okay I'll push him forward
Oh he got taken
Wait hold on I'll push him forward then
Wait am I going to perish
I think I'm going to perish
I don't think I can win
And then you move up
Oh no I didn't mean that
And then I push up
And then what
What happens then
In the head
Yeah I'm not winning that one
Okay let's try again
That was
Yeah that was
I wasn't sure about that one
I'm not sure about that one
Run Riefling
I don't think I've played with you yet
Okay surely I can win
Oh it's not my turn yet
Oops
Okay you
You are getting
Blyat
Can't handle it
Block you from doing it there
I'll take you
Oh no this Riefling is thinking
You're not supposed to think against me
Monka
What's this Riefling thinking
I don't know he's taking his time
I'm getting nervous
What he's planning
I don't know what he's doing
I can't see it if he's doing something
I don't see it
Here
I don't know what Riefling is planning
Riefling is planning
I'll take that then
You're not getting a 4 in the rule of me
I don't know
If I do this
No
I block you
Then what
Riefling
What the heck
No you weren't supposed to see
You're supposed to be like
La-dee-da-dee-da
Strawny is too dumb to figure this out
Okay
So now what
Are you gonna put it there
No he's gonna put it there
Wait hold on
1 2 3 3 3
So if I put it there
He has to go there
Will she finally get the dub
I have no idea
There has to be a Riefling that's lower IQ than me
Wait you block me
Oh sugar
I wasn't supposed to do that
Oopsies I foiled my own plan
Literally you don't even need to
Counteract me I counteract myself
You already beat me
Strawny my IQ is too low
This is hard
You're kicked
It's so bad
Wait we'll have 1 2
4 you can't
So never
No
I'm so confused
Are we both playing the same game right now
We're both scared to play here
Cause I win if he plays here
Oh no
Oh I wasn't freaking
Bro what is this game so
Freakin hard to win
Honestly
All of us
Literally
How are you all smarter than me
This doesn't make any sense
How are you so freaking smart
Bro how is this game so hard
You could have won
Just placed it in the middle
No he was gonna block me
No
Surely I can win one
Surely freaking temples I can win one
One faking
Round
Of this this is so hard
It's cause we're
It's cause we're men
Riefling you can't say that part
That's supposed to be the quiet part
Breed and honest I was barely screaming
Bye my brains fried
Bro I'm like fainting this so
Freakin hard
Like I'm gonna get rekt
I'm gonna get rekt
No
You see me
Hello Miss Cuddles how is your Friday night
It's going good but I'm getting
Freakin rekt I'm getting rekt
I was gonna do something here
Wait
Did you
Did you let me win
Did I win
Okay hold on I wanna do that again
See when I win I get serotonin
When I don't win I get
Here we go tiny Cuddles
I've played you I haven't played you yet
My take away is here hold on
Give me one minute I need to go
Answer the door
I'm getting rekt
Hold on
My bets like Gimli's about to complain
Give me
Are we ready
I'm ready for Friday.
Okay, I'm going to be eating and doing this at the same time.
So you must forgive me if I'm extra dumb.
Thank you the tonnethou for the two.
I'm currently getting wrecked at RuneScape.
It's not looking good. How do I counteract this?
I need to go here.
And then I need to stop you from making a four over here.
This is such a big...
I got a chicken wrap with sugar.
Why are you so tall?
I feel like I'm going to lose this one as well.
You feel like I can't do it?
Oh my god, I'm eating chips and it's so good.
It's so yummy.
Chicken wrap with sugar?
Wait, is that a thing?
No, it's just a chicken burrito wrap.
Oh no, this is a lot of red.
I don't like it. I see red, I see red, I see red.
Here?
I don't know what I'm doing.
I'm too busy munching.
Delicious.
I said sugar. Oh, I said oh sugar.
I said oh sugar instead of oh.
I'll stop you right there criminal scum.
I'm not going to mess this up.
No, you're going to play there.
What? How do you not play there?
No, you smell my fricking connection.
I don't really want to place it there.
I wasn't even paying attention.
No, come on man.
Come on, I'm getting rolled.
Are you squiddling me?
Who do you please me?
Please share, mama.
Oh, you guys not Ian, thank you for the tip boy.
You guys not Ian, you want to go ah?
I'm not pleased you.
You win.
Oh, you didn't mean that.
Sniffer, sniffer Ian.
Everyone's are going to starve because we're getting so distracted trying to win.
Why did I not work?
Here. Oh no.
I'm blue.
Abba de abba die, I'm blue.
I would be off a guy.
Now listen up, here's the story.
I found a little cuttlefish in the deep blue sea.
Everything was blue and visited the minimum.
Yeah, nobody to listen.
I knew I would meet up a guy.
Wow, it's cold on my hands.
That guy literally.
Hold on, I'm getting my burrito at my weebops.
I can't do that.
I need to do that, don't know.
I do, I do.
Oh no.
You're not supposed to do that, I'm going to hear them.
Yeah wait, far.
No, you're not supposed to win against me.
Okay, I'm opening up my burrito.
My burrito with no cilantro.
Because we do not like cilantro on the top.
Wow, oh yeah, hold on.
Oh no, what is this?
Mmm, oh my god, it's delicious.
Oh shiisa, shiisa.
He's doing that, he's gunning for that.
I can tell Riefland, I can see right through your thought process right now.
No, I was going to put there.
Wait, why can I not put here?
He puts here, I put there.
No, I put there, he puts there.
I win.
But why would you do that?
One, two, one, two, three, he wins.
Reh.
You could have had it, spare.
Here?
Oh wait, oh no!
Oh no, I did, I remembered like literally as I put that down.
Oh my god.
Bruv, I literally just threw that game, I could have won that.
Bruv.
I could have won it, Grimble.
It is too hard, it's so freaking hard to win Grimble, thank you for the tip.
Literally Hypnosis is the only reason I can get away with it.
Have I played with D-Riefland?
I don't think so.
Go again, boom.
No, my turn.
A well deserved loss.
Okay, look, I have room temperature IQ, I'm trying my best.
Right, no, don't do that.
Mmm.
But, I think you've played them all at least once now.
Yeah, go away.
Our darling low IQ Veeche bar, honestly.
More like our dangerously low IQ Veeche bar.
Hmm.
Oh my god, this is like a wish.
Yeah, I fucking love pepper.
You know what, chicken is the MVP, I'm not even playing.
Oh no, that is a good one, two, three, four.
What if I go here then?
I don't know what happened if I do for them.
Ah, I freaking love chicken sauce, it's like the best meat sauce ever.
Girls are cute when they're almost reeflings.
Wait, is that my turn?
What did you do?
Thank you for the game, strong.
Oh, you're welcome, you don't have to take me for that.
I have no idea what you did though.
Oh wait, this reeflings the end.
What did you do?
Is there something here?
I think I'm having something here.
Papago?
Alright, what happened if I go here?
I don't know, maybe I need to go down here?
Alright.
Here maybe?
I don't know.
If I go here then I'll lose, I hope not.
One, two, three, eh.
So eh.
Eh.
Ah, it's a fucking thing!
I have a fucking way to stay, it's so hard.
I don't even see it.
I literally can't even see it at all.
This is so hard though.
Is there any reeflings I haven't gone against?
I haven't gone against everyone here.
That's so hard.
Right, have I gone against everyone here?
I may have, you know that.
Are you a reefling? All fans?
All fans?
Maybe they're just confused why there's so many people here.
Does anyone want to go again?
Because I can play while I eat.
I think we're on run two, I think everyone's having a fair share.
Eh.
Look how all of you guys have numbers and stuff now,
because you've been beating me.
Hold on, eat, eat.
Um.
I'm eating my time.
I'll pass, I've been meant to do it in that one.
Mmm.
Yeah? Yeah.
That's the best counter in location I pay out.
Mmm.
You're shooting both of them.
The same thing is, you actually could have won three times
if you weren't placing tails randomly.
I'm trying to think ahead of my moves, okay?
It's hard.
Oh my god, this is delicious.
Reeflings, do you want me to baby barge you?
Because I'll do it.
Mmm.
Uh, don't like the look of that.
I'm getting nervous, I'm getting shaky.
I'm trying to do that then.
Get ready.
Oh no!
No!
Why do I not see it?
Why do I not see it coming?
I'm being so for real right now.
Right.
The next one I am not losing.
I don't care what happens.
I am not losing.
I am tryharding so much.
I am not losing this one.
I'm so serious.
Are we bimbo max?
I literally don't see it.
Right, you've placed it in the middle.
That's fine.
Is it?
I don't know.
We'll place it next to you then.
That's fine.
So I'll counter you from doing four in a row on the bottom.
And then I'll do this.
Alright.
One, two, three.
So you can't go anywhere there.
But I can progress by going here.
And that's fine.
You're allowed to do that.
Right.
Did I do it?
Oh, wait.
I thought I won there.
Wait.
Wait, why did I not win there?
Like this?
Did I counter them by going that way?
I will redeem myself.
Oh no, right.
One, two, three, four.
So drop it here.
I'm tryharding.
I'm looking.
Alright, if you're there,
one, two, three, four.
Fuck you.
Wait.
One, two, three, four.
What are you trying to do?
One, two, three, here.
So I can't put it in this column.
Right, you've put it up there,
which is fine.
Oh, fuck you.
You've blocked me.
Uh.
Wait.
So what happens now?
What did that do?
No, you're getting blocked.
I don't know what you're doing,
but don't do it.
I don't know what you're doing there,
What are you doing over here now?
That's fine.
Whoa!
Get wrecked.
Get absolutely wrecked.
Oh my God, I did it.
I was like trying so hard.
I was trying to see what you were trying to do.
I was playing two characters at once on the board.
Oh, we did it.
I have lower connect for IQ.
Okay, let's try again.
Hold on, let me take a bite of my food.
Oh my God, I had to try so hard for that.
Mmm.
Okay.
Oh my God, that was so hard.
I don't know how people play logic games all the time.
I feel like my brain just gets so tired.
I'm like, oh, I'm done.
Mmm.
Mmm-hmm.
Here, here, here.
Oh, shit.
Oh, this is not looking good.
Mmm-hmm.
Am I going to throw?
I don't know what you're trying to do.
What are you trying to do?
Don't feel bad.
My brain is still at nice capacity.
Oh, no, what did you do?
I wasn't paying attention.
Right, you get blocked.
Mmm-hmm.
Oh, fuck!
Oh, for fuck's sake, it seems so hard.
Bro, when you go back to cooking swordfish, this is so hard.
How?
I never see it.
I, like, physically can't see it coming.
Until I hear the...
Bro.
Girlfriend is pouty and frustrated and upset.
She's got destroyed and fucking...
Not even just destroyed and runescaped.
Destroyed and runescaped, like, side player gate.
Oh, God, I'm first. Sorry.
Wait, how did that double down there?
I didn't even need to...
Oh, fine, I'm tripling down.
Mmm-hmm.
Oh, so I'm choking on my burrito in anger.
Because I'm so bad at this game.
Mmm-hmm.
I don't know.
No, you're gonna win!
Oh, look how freaking low my score is!
I started on a third.
Oh, my God, you're so good at winning.
What are you doing?
One, two, three, two, two.
I don't know what I'm doing, either, to be honest.
Ah, Saishayuma.
Ow, what are you doing?
Stop.
You're stressing me out.
This refland's gonna win.
They're, like, genuinely stressing me out.
Right, get blocked.
No! Oh, my God!
I hate...
Wait, we're going...
No, I'm sorry.
We're going back to Edgeville.
I'm actually fucking done.
I'm actually...
I'm done.
We're going back to Edgeville.
I'm not even kidding.
I'm not even joking.
We're going back to Edgeville.
I'm so done.
We're going back to Edgeville to cook
freaking swordfish.
This is so hard.
It's a surprise exam.
Get to fuck.
I've got the lowest IQ in the...
Freaking lower than room temperature water.
Oh, my God.
Why is that game so hard?
Freaking...
To no one's surprise,
the 1v1 chess stream has been delayed
due to the fact that I'm probably
gonna have to actually watch some chess tutorials
because I don't know how the rules work.
If she starts speaking...
If she starts speaking German,
she should really stop playing.
I respect your dedication
not to apply mind bullets to them
to gain a victory.
Is that what it should have done?
I should have done.
I should just start taking the bikini off
and all that.
I was so hard for no reason.
Take the random event.
Oh, is it good?
Sorry.
Hello.
Yeah, sure.
I'll find soon an exam.
Right.
What's my...
What is this?
Ah, it's your skullfish.
You've been slacking in your studies.
It's time for an exam.
In some case, Johnny,
once gay players are built different.
Bro, they are.
Thank you for the tip, boy.
They literally are, though.
There are two types of questions.
One requires you to find the next object
in a pattern.
And the second,
I will present you with 15 cards and a hint.
That's so specific.
What are we doing?
What comes next?
Shoes, shoes, shoes.
Shoes.
That's correct.
Next question.
Pick the object that should come next to a pattern.
A banana,
a dookie,
a pineapple,
a slice of watermelon.
Finally,
a apple that uses her brains.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Sure, sure.
These are gardening tools,
so we need a rake.
To the exit.
Okay, we did it.
We did it.
Please don't fail.
Imagine if I did this.
Oh, my God.
Did you hear that?
The burrito just kissed me
from the way I bit it.
What's the book of knowledge to do?
Ah!
Fishing?
It took him.
Wait.
Oh, that wasn't cooking.
Oh, my God.
Just when you think I couldn't get dumber,
I just put XP into firemaking
instead of cooking.
Bruv.
Can this get any worse?
I don't think it's any more obvious
how low my IQ is.
Holy crap.
It's even a miracle I can breathe
and eat at the same time.
Oh, my God.
Reefling's about to get jealous
over a burrito for real, for real.
Did you not hear?
Did it come up in the make?
It literally went...
when I bit into the burrito.
It's fine, you're a fish.
You are the goofiest of goobers.
We love you immensely.
The firemaking will warm up your IQ.
Small brain after all.
That was so hard.
I don't know how to play this.
Ah, jealous of a piece of fish.
Shawnee out here looking like process.
Bruv.
That was terrible.
I literally rage quit.
I'm like, no, I need to walk away.
Thank you very much, Reefling,
for making the fire.
Any arsonists?
Absolutely.
Let me keep eating this burrito
before it gets cold.
Are you squidding me right now?
Strowme, we're hungry.
Can you get back in the kitchen?
I mean, level in cooking.
Love you, you goofball.
Thank you, anonymous.
Love you too, little Reefling.
Yes, I will feed you well and good.
That was...
Thank you for the tip.
Oh my god, my hand's covered in sauce.
See, I'm not afraid to, like,
sauce off after Reefling.
As I choke on a piece of corn,
I can't talk and frickin...
...eat at the same time.
Oh my god.
That was so hard for no reason.
I've never played Connect 4 like that
in a very long time.
Bruv, I suck at anything logic-based.
Oh my god.
Is there Connect 4 championships?
Could you imagine?
You know how you get a rank in chess?
Can you imagine?
It was fun content, though.
Strowme gets absolutely destroyed by...
...viewers live on stream.
Rage quiz.
Mm-hmm.
Wow.
I almost finished this brutal.
My hand is covered.
I don't think I have a napkin.
Reeflings, do you want to come lick my fingers
and call me KFC?
Cause I'm finger-licking good.
Oh, hold on.
Cause I'm finger-licking good!
Thank you.
I have to lean over with my other hand to do that.
It's like a call offering.
I want KFC not to imagine that almost.
Cuttlefish pounded from four angles.
Yeah, that could be the title of the stream
cause I played that frickin...
Connect 4 more like...
Connect my shite.
Right, we'll finish the...
We'll finish eating.
And we'll finish the swordfish.
Snippets, 20-minute warning for Mercy.
Azura, I think, is still going to be live on stream.
Cause stream is a six-hour game.
If you're going to do emotes,
you should do questionable ones like this.
Is that questionable?
Oh, maybe if you're like under the table.
Then, yeah.
Yeah, Azura is still live.
Okay, that's good.
I'm eating.
Architect bros winning.
And do you want to know the calorie count
of my meal, Architect bros?
Just the thought of my stomach expanding
with all that food and sticking out,
going from a flat stomach
to all big and engorged...
Architect.
I'm sorry.
I don't know why I'm just talking about that.
No, Architect bros.
I hate it now, I'm teasing you.
I'm teasing your pickles.
I do not judge.
Don't be sorry, we enjoy it.
I should get a hydration.
Well, I'll say hydration as if it's not cool over.
Big burp.
Maybe a big burp.
We burp, we burp.
Not much force.
Not much fist room.
Dah, behind that burp.
Pause.
Yeah, we're now munching on the leftover chips
because I finished my burrito.
Some of the filling of the burrito spilled out,
so I'm like...
I'm using my chip as a vessel
to spoon it into my mouth.
Not the in-game rate in a mubbock.
Strawny feeds everyone equally.
That's why she's queen for it.
Your interests are my fascination.
Your curiosities are my challenge.
Chicken or beef?
Chicken.
I struggle to eat a lot around me
and then I wonder why I'm so ill.
It's literally got all the iron in it that I need.
I'm always a chicken boy.
I'm a chicken boy mubbock.
Do you know some Gomez person?
No, sorry.
Am I supposed to?
I love vision.
I think I've ever had vision before.
I'm heading to sleep at 6am.
Oh my goodness.
Please rest well.
Is that 6am America?
Must be.
Because it's like midnight in the UK, roughly.
Are you good?
Oops.
Who goes there?
I identify yourself.
No, it's only 8pm on the west coast.
Oh!
Sorry, I can't stop burping.
Good night, EU.
Thank you for absolutely reckoning
decking me on Kinect 4.
I live in Turkey.
Oh, okay, okay, okay.
It's 6am.
It's 11pm for me and I'm Midwest.
Yee-haw!
Nah, it's 4am in the UK.
Sorry, I'm still really enjoying my food
so I apologise if I'm not talking too much.
I'm trying to eat as fast as I can.
I keep doing that.
I'm just going to click on the booth.
Let's go to the booth.
Am I dumb, but can I ask what munkah means?
Munkah.
Munkah S is a twitch emote
where Pappy looks really stressed out
and he's like, oh, like, like, nervous.
And I reduce it to munkah.
Munkah!
But if you type in munkah S on Google
it'll just show you what Pappy looks like.
He's all stressed out.
Almost 4am and I'm slowly losing it.
Please go to sleep!
Oh my god.
Please don't worry about going to sleep.
Like, seriously, I don't want you guys, like,
risking your health to watch me stream.
Like, I'm literally stuffing my face.
I just got wrecked and connect 4
and I'm going straight back to cooking.
Like, you ain't missing out on too much, I assure you.
Time for a hypnotic slumber.
Sleep is for the weakest weekend now.
Sleep equals exp wasted.
Oh my god, really, really close to level.
I'm not next batch.
I don't know what level.
40.
Eh, 74?
I hate arching on mobile.
See, we've got like a billion different things to click to do or anything.
And...
Ah!
76!
Oh my god, how much did Wine Boosters?
I thought we were selling like 72.
Wine is faster, but I want to use all the fish that the reeflings gave me.
Because I don't want it to go to waste.
I don't want it to be, like, rotting in my bank.
Four more levels and you can cook sharks.
I have a good night.
Please rest well.
Wine got me 72 at 65 in, like, under an hour.
Only power...
Only power to bring me back to this Godforsaken game is like cute fish!
It's a good game, but...
If you've got stuff to do, it's not the easiest game to, like, keep up the excitement.
I think RuneScape, I would say, is probably similar to, like, people say,
like, when you start up a Minecraft server, um...
Pardon me, and you play for, like, a week and then you all get burnt out and never go on it again type thing.
Wine got you from 69 to 70.
It feels good, man.
Nooo!
Not cooking and doing your species.
There's plenty to go around in the RuneScape economy.
More than enough, actually.
In fact, the waters are so infested with shark, they're everywhere.
Thank you.
Uh, boi- boi!
Can I say thank you and I'll miss for the other tips?
Love you, you're good for all. Love you too, love everything.
Or love you too, uh, Anonymous.
I don't know if I'm supposed to guess, I'm supposed to call you Anonymous or everything.
A rainbow fish!
Okay.
I've almost finished eating, I'm so sorry if it feels like I've been chewing for ages.
I was too busy getting- oh!
That's how many times have I done that now?
No, stop eating!
What are you doing?
Jeez, Louise woman.
Okay.
We've almost finished...
the...
the fishy.
Oh my god, sorry, I can't think I'm just too busy eating.
I've almost finished eating, I promise I'll finish eating soon.
How did you take so long to eat?
Walked into an eater's room, thank goodness I'm not late.
I'm gonna have her.
For the architect bros, this one's for you.
I order two meals because I have the second meal the next day,
so tomorrow I'll be eating my next meal.
So I'm gonna go put it in the fridge, in the-
and wash my hands because they're covered in grease.
They're covered.
She knows about that.
So, when Azura got released,
I read up a little bit and people were like,
oh my god, architect chocolate, and I'm like,
wait, I thought you were-
and I was like reading, I'm like,
oh okay, right, I get it now.
Why architect is such a random word for it though?
I still don't get the origin, but hey ho.
Anyway, I'm gonna very quickly wash my hands
because they're covered in freaking grease from the burrito.
That was absolutely inhaling and getting rolled on.
I'll be literally a millisecond, I don't need to do anything special.
...
I've just stood up and I'm aware of her fill my bladder
because I'm gonna go pee.
...
I have six set, where does my head start, I've lost it, okay, I've just sat down and
I need a two, damn you, I'm gonna do it, I'm gonna do it, I'm gonna sneeze actually, okay,
what a wake up, okay, you're done, am I getting sick, I better not be, I am not
getting sick when I've not even done a month full of streaming yet, I do not tell
tolerate any sickness, I haven't even done it a full month yet, I'm getting sick, damn you, the
taskmasker, for me, no not for me, for any, maybe better streaming hours would help you,
what, you mean don't do 12 hours naturally, what are you talking about refling, don't say
such nonsense, are you trying to upset me refling, you're trying to make me feel it's
because you left us, okay, I won't feel sick anymore, you're laughing but I have separation
anxiety with you guys, it's been getting better but I feel an immense amount of anxiety at the,
before I click go live and then it goes away when I am live, I'm not sure what that means,
I mean I had it last time, wink wink, and then it subsided and it was back again so I don't
have to plan as it's going to subside over my body so sooner, we love you too, hey,
scrawny, when are the Elden Ring Streams, when the DLC releases, you've been playing for a while,
consider taking a break, do you insult me Jagex, do you think me some prepubescent child that can't
handle a little gaming session, Jagex please do not dare interrupt my flow, do you ever
get anxiety when it comes to ending streams, I get nervous about ending the stream because
of what I'm going to say and I know that seems silly because it's like well you say the same
every time like I say like I'll see you tomorrow, like I love you reflings, a few kisses on that
but I get worried about it and I don't know why, I think it's because I am saying goodbye and it's
like I won't see you until the next time I'm up, you know, and too much of a grimoire you somehow
groomed yourself, hear a veal or you don't grimoire, what a slogan to have for a, every time I do
that, what a slogan to have for a visa reasons that, I can't believe I said that out loud with my
fulche, ain't that true though, yeah, oh when I was lurking someone mentioned that they didn't
realize we both have a nicotine patch on us because we're addicted to each other, it's not
for the reflings that are addicted to each other, no, refling and strongy aren't addicted to each
other, I can always ramble and procrastinate ending streaming calls, those are so awkward doing so,
mmm, well like when we reached the 10 hour board mark on that other stream, I can't even remember
what it was, the entire ending got caught but I was like trying to say so much all at once just
because like I wanted to, you know, and I wasn't expected to be groomed but I'm glad you did,
oh that sounds terrible when you write that out in a sentence, I'm gonna be honest, it makes me
sound like Chris Hansen, take a seat moment, yeah, kind of true though, I think pre-stream
anxiety is normal, you're talking to an auditorium worth of people, I actually don't get nervous to
stream in that sense, it doesn't, I don't look at the numbers like I don't actually know, it's not
like on display for me, it's just me and reflings playing multiplayer game and that's it, like that's
what it is, it's not like I'm nervous because I'm gonna have to go perform, I don't have any kind of
imposter syndrome, I don't have any kind of like I'm not good enough, I just like straight up have
separation anxiety and that's it pretty much, like I don't get nervous to stream, I don't get like oh
my god what happens if they don't like it, no, I'm just like just getting nervous, I'm like oh god
I don't feel well, like I feel sick, like my stomach feels ill sometimes, but like I've started
up streams and I've said to you like oh guys it's not gonna be like a long stream today and then it
ends up turning into like six hours type thing um when I only had the intention of two because I
wasn't feeling well, but as soon as I start streaming it's like I get a second burst of wind,
like I'm super energetic, I'm super engaging, like I'm having like so much fun, I'm enjoying myself
like right now we're looking at pixels over and over again putting, pardon me for being so rude,
it was not me, it was my food and like I'm having so much fun, like look at all the reeflings that
are in the bank with me right now, like all of us goofing off and like uh Mack, mackerel or maker,
Mack maker, thank you for coming to Memba, um it's just like, it's like me with social anxiety,
I don't want to go out but when I'm out it's fun, yeah it's kind of like getting over the hump
if you will and and like I especially enjoy my endurance streams, like I kind of spoke on it the
other day, um one time I was having a really bad time and reeflings were just hanging out with me
and this isn't now, this isn't now, this is like way in the past, um and we played a song and it's
called Mr Kitty, um and it's like a really depressive song or kind of slow tempo song
and I heard it and I was listening to it and it made me feel a certain way, it made me feel
quite negative, like it was quite a depressive song, Mr Kitty After Dark, yes that was the song
and I listened to it and I typed and I said is this what you guys feel like all the time?
because of the way the song had like resonated with me, it felt as rough as I had felt in that
moment because I was feeling rough because you know stuff was going on behind the scene, um
and it kind of like made me realize like if me hanging out, having a carry-on, rambling,
coming up with all these like silly little ASMR ideas and like all these collab ideas and elaborate
stuff and all of that and like it makes you not feel like that when I stream, like how blessed
and how lucky like we're on this timeline, like you know you can feel, I don't know, like accepted
to just like do your own thing, like I always say the phrase you can be at arm's length, you can be
attached at the hip, you can be on my head type thing, it's completely up to you Viflin, um
but I do remember that night because I was like you guys feel like that, like when
just in general like you have like such a rough time and then you come
on stream and like you come and you you make me laugh, you make me giggle, we tell terrible puns
while going like and we're just hanging out type thing, you know it's like even when like you feel
so rough you're so willing to like come to me, be so accepting of me, like say such nice things to me
and encourage me to do stuff and all of that and it's just like it's such like a nice way like
hopefully, I hope it's like a positive feedback loop where you make me giggle, I make you giggle
and like we just have a fun time for what it's worth and sometimes you need a song like that
to marinate in your thought, yeah like I don't listen to what I consider like sad music in the
dumps music or emotional music, like I listen to Atarashi Gako and like Tokyo Calling, Tokyo Calling
um like I listen to Hatsune Miku, I don't even know what's happening half the time when I listen
to Hatsune Miku but like the music's so upbeat, it's so up-pop, like I never listen to anything
depressive, like like goofy, like literally I'm listening to a Dutch song, I have no idea what's
being said, other than the lyrics suck ma, type thing, you know, I love that thing
thanks for the stream strong, I'm off to watch Mercy, yes any snippets, Mercy Modiste is live
and she is playing with my willy, she's not, maybe in another life
um
right hold on let me check, Hatsune Miku has become a legendary figure
of Mickey and homework, right hold on what is Mercy playing, is Azura still live, Azura is
still live, she's playing Shrey live, Mercy Modiste, Mercy is playing Harvester part two, I already
knew that because I said that earlier and yeah I forgot, see you brain, see you brain
I got a comment on the new the ASMR video and someone's like why is this being recommended to me
hey hey hey hey hey you can't resist the ASMR
the most I felt like that after dark was when that um
when you go in member to a members world, I don't know if we need to do a members world this stream
and maybe next stream we're doing members world unfortunately although wine isn't members is it
no maybe not, I don't know if we're just doing members all the way to the end
if we're doing wines all the way to the end, people say wines is faster
literally get algorithmed, honestly what did you miss I stuffed my face and then
uh let uh let the architect bros know I've got them in the back of my mind
um yeah hold on, hold on
the begging ASMR is peak ASMR honestly, wait what does it say now
uh it's still going, oh my god is that 23,000 views, that doesn't make sense
architect bros eating good just like strongy honestly what does it mean architect architect
is a terminology used for people who enjoy bigger body types or eating type of content
or gaining weight type of content but there's different levels to it um so Azura delays
body type because she's not like the default skinny malinky I keep opening this freaking
collection box um VTuber so she would get referred to as someone for the architect bros
look at all the swordfish they're so purple
they're so purple
uh architect bros specifically vtubers I think
she shuffled herself in the ink yes uh again Azura Duly is live with a stray
hopefully her pc doesn't explode um and merci mondice is playing harvester part two
which she never told me there was a part two because I'm getting a highlight reel of part one
which isn't going to make any sense if I don't get a highlight reel of part two
I love strongy I love reeflings what you're gonna do about it huh you're gonna kiss me on my
lips you know let me hold your hand actually I have something to ask the reeflings are
you guys are like small enough to fit in the palm of my hand basically do you guys like that
you're smaller than me or would you like a mascot that's like bigger oh my god why am I struggling
so hard with this bank system um like you're so nice and tame yeah smaller than you is better
what is my size um I don't even think I have a reference artwork I can use that isn't tall
spreading small is nice yes you're if you didn't know secret hidden lore for the reeflings your
tentacles can grow as long as you like so you can interact with things as much as you need
um you have very very long tentacles if you so desire but they're just nice and cute and
stacked together whilst you are in oh my god the crisscross salmon the salmon are going upstream
look they're going upstream what we are growers not sure it's exactly hmm almost like a previous
lore strange it small means when you cuddle as we feel you every yeah I can put you in my mouth
in my tummy we can go explore strony in the first thing
share a blindfold reeflings but let your tentacles do what they want
bank boost I'm not going to mess up this time
oh wow how do I do the fire huh okay there we go
strony subtly mentioned war oh I don't mind it no okay I like giant tests like war um
what else do I like um
I'm trying to think of other things that are considered like not regular
hmm spelunking me no I can't escape that word it's like mongolian frozing in it's everywhere
it's everywhere can't escape it no spelunking what does it even mean
you can't even tell me it's not related to the bedroom spelunking I can't wait to go spelunking
with the reeflings oh I can't wait until we go into a tight dark damp cave and spelunk together
like bro whoever named spelunking spelunking you knew exactly what you did
I mean cave exploring yeah literally spelunking
you've ever heard such a more ridiculous word how dare they make such a word
oh my god you're still doing absolutely wakey wakey sleepyhead
good night strony send luck to my country tomorrow I have no idea what your country's
doing tomorrow but please don't perish if it's bad good luck to your country and rest well for
anyone who do need to sleep please don't worry we are literally just going for another three hours
and then uh we'll redirect into a streamer I don't know who I don't even know who's not online
normally at this time but we will find a vtuber that is live that we can redirect into
the euro cup fit ball is on the new all right okay right good luck uh I am down for some spelunking
right now uh plunging is another fun one plunging please do not plunge me that's not abysmal
spelunking in the cave of a giant earth I don't know how to how far to go with the giant earth
and the zero I might not make her do the weird side of things I might do the weird side of things
but yeah
no plo no plunging not even a little
you can plug me up whoa wait hold on I was like so direct my brain was like oh this will this is
fine this is clearly beating around the bush nope no it's not it's absolutely not I just straight
upset what what I uh sorry you know actually I can tell you something that was really terrible
so if all the development issues hadn't occurred I actually fully was going to
are you squinting me uh hold on I don't know what you think
giant s for content one day totally
um I'm freaking happy to make it anonymous it doesn't bother me like I like it I don't
mind at all um I don't like the you die ones I don't like that I like the ones where you just
kind of appear on the other end all fine and good maybe a bit moody because you accidentally
got swallowed or something like that um she's letting the intrusive thoughts went honestly though
this is terrible so if all the development issues didn't happen all the girls were posting
like all these audios on twitter and I was like oh I should probably do one as well but like
after debut and I thought wouldn't it not be really terrible if I may or may not have been
um
plug uh during like debut and after and then once the stream ended I would go record and like
do something with it and then finish and then post it and you know so that was my idea but
obviously that all crumbled apart thanks to development issues um but yeah I thought it would
be pretty good but that would have been amazing unfortunately it's not possible it's not possible
um there was so many developmental issues in time and I could absolutely strangle some people but
that's just what happens like literally um oh sorry there was a refling that messaged me that
apologized for criticizing the company for saying like oh it'd be better if the girls could make their
designs please don't feel bad I absolutely completely get where you come from um just for
how do I keep doing that I'll give up um please don't feel bad about saying that like you said
it in a nice way we had some negative criticism that was like oh premade model actually one of
the most bizarre criticisms we got um was what was it it was like oh they don't even have talents
ready when we opened up auditions and it was like yeah you're fucking Egypt we didn't have talents so
we're opening auditions like every other Vtuber agency but when we do it it's bad but when
everyone else does it it's fine and that was like what it was the most bizarre thing I had ever read
honestly um we have plenty of time for future fun literally opened up auditions and someone was like
what's she be 2.0 look like this I mean she was getting an update to our model I don't know how
much she said I'm not gonna say anything if she doesn't say anything I'm not gonna say anything
hey thank you for the tip as well anonymous sorry I almost forget to thank you um I won't say anything
until she be said something but yeah ghetto outfit she said outfit
right I'll I'll leave it at that if she's not directly said what it is I'm not gonna say
she said outfit
we don't have workers because we're not open yet many baffled honestly it was bizarre like I remember
reading it actually there's a reflin it must have been a reflin it must have been a reflin
because you made me he haul my arse off and I can remember the quote because I used to quote it
because someone defended the agency they must I think they're a reflin or possibly just someone
who's enthusiastic about the girls in general so someone criticized the company because they were
like oh another agency where you have to give up your model to work with them and get their
premade models or whatever and then someone commented and replied to them and there was like
no one wants your ugliest sin model like that was to the quote your ugly as sin model oh
I wish I could have interacted with it because it made me he haul so badly
is that no one wants your ugly as sin model oh my god I literally was like getting so close
to printing that out and putting it on my fridge because it was just so hilarious to me like it was
so hilarious um like I just oh my god um uh vin miss vin san vin san vin sin vin sin
vin sin thank you for becoming a member that took me so long to figure out I'm so sorry
no not sin sister it was just the terminology the guy used because someone was like oh I don't
want to give up my model type thing and I don't want this I don't want that like basically complaining
about the agency and it was like rub one you've not even applied two you're not interested so
three shut the fuck up and then some reflin or just someone who was a good fan come swiping in
and replies what I was basically thinking no one wants your ugliest sin model and I'm like
it's so good it's so funny anyway so you made my day whoever whoever like came
sweeping under to defend the agency you have made my day um hellscape thank you for becoming a
member I appreciate it the membership stream start next week uh you've got plenty uh it's a bit warm
not gonna lie a bit hot in here yeah a bit bit sweaty out here surprised the bank hasn't caught
on fire honestly um I forgive her she's tired and forgot how to read oh no what did I miss me
oh what are you yapping about scrawny is she be cooking so I think she has allured to something
which I'm more than happy for her to um but I don't think she's fully said what it is and I don't
want to ruin it because it's quite a nice thing I think it's quite a nice thing and it's like the
most basic common courtesy thing um allured she'd be allured to it there were some abysmally uh stupid
to take from a flume it's just the way the guy typed the message I just constantly remember the
phrase ugliest sin model I like oh my god talking about like catching straight like oh my god I don't
think I could recover if someone was like your ugliest sin model ah oh my god love it love it love
it love it um mommy you have broken youtube we are going for 6.1 subs oh my god the video what is
the video honestly that funny I'm like I'm second guessing myself I'm like what's the video truly that
entertaining like I was just kind of saying please a lot by the end of it and started like
breathing in the mic really weird I only know one agency that lets their talents pick their models
literally I've only heard one other agency do it as well um but I'm quite happy for the girls like
to design their 2.0 like Emmy designed her 2.0 like I'm more than happy if she wants if that
makes her happier and all that then jeez what am I gonna fucking say about it nothing oh guys as
long as the girls are happy they're happy um I made mommy ink herself has my whole life been a
mistake is this peak content for you from uh also the amount of people that could not read oh I felt
so bad actually we had one Japanese girl um apply and I felt so bad because she had such a lovely
voice but she could hardly speak any English and I was like it's not gonna work it's such a shame
she had worked for a previous agency um and I think google translate was helping her through
the page and she inquired on the website and I felt so bad being like bro you can't speak English
I can't have you there is actually a Russian person that reached out as well she was like I know you
I know your agency's English but can I stream in Russian and have a Russian audience and I'm like
ah yes let us the English VTuber agency come out with talents that where I can't even like
moderate what you're doing or saying like what some folk had like don't get me wrong we're lenient
but we do have to say like that's not even possible like what you're asking for isn't even possible
um that was a shame I loved Amy's 2.0 design I'm glad I'm glad I think she had a lot of fun
designing her 2.0 um so yeah how good was good as application what good is still a thingy
oh you want to trade with me hold on let me put my swordfish away I'll trade with you what's up
what's up low leaflin maybe oh it's so what is this are these donuts to put around your
disc of returning disc of returning yellow boots yellow gloves what
what have you given me what does it look like activate
you can only enter thordor's black hole from the dwarven mains are you sitting literally I
thought this is a weebie ring as well are you giving me your weebie ring am I putting shoes on
okay I got shoes on I've got gloves on oh now I look like I really work I think it's a helpful
tool that will come in handy later that's so ominous this is a helpful tool that'll help you later
what do you mean that's so ominous what am I supposed to do about that
I I get you miss 100% of the shots but some people just don't get it it was a shame like I felt
really bad for the Japanese girl she was nothing but polite well mannered um and like obviously I
can't say too much of the message but basically she'd worked in another agency before it didn't work
out and and she was like really excited at the prospect and she already had all the experience
type thing but she just couldn't speak English and I can't be like given lead script examples where
she mimics what I'm seeing because then she's gonna end up just sounding like me type thing when it
comes to trying to mix it was a shame it was a shame because it would have been a very interesting mix
you can stack donuts on it Japanese branch when no there will be no spin-offs
absolutely no spin-offs at viola um I am I am three gents and I am done I have nothing else to
produce or give to this beautiful world I will give my daughters um my gen one my gen two my
gen three and I am done I cannot handle anymore I am I'm at capacity there is too much lights off
a plappening happen I can't keep up with you as refluence I can't keep up with you as
and someone was worried about a male branch I assure you that male branch idea is dead in the
ditch I am not even touching it with a ten foot pole um someone asked I did get a few inquiries
on the website saying are you interested in doing a safer work branch um the answer is no
I don't mean to sound so blunt with that but the answer is no you might as well go to any other
agency go apply to any other agency if you're if you're interested in the safer work the reason
why you don't get such a good cut in other agencies is because they're greedy cons but that's okay
though because you know is what it is no point in no point in beating around the bush no point in
beating around the bush um safer work branch kind of defeats the purpose literally like at that
point might as well just start like a whole different agency and all that jazz um but I am done I have
experienced it it's been fun um Veeler is my child and so are my daughters and the reeflings
are the father and I'm also pregnant with the reeflings for that asmr and I forgot to commission
that art I've still not done it I don't do it shouldn't Veeler too electric boogaloo but
strongy with enough power you can reignite even a dying star no latin american branch no I cannot
do any uh alternative language speaking branches because I don't speak the language and I don't
have any trusted advisors that I could overwhelm with the amount of work it takes um like the split
couldn't be as high if I needed someone on call 24 7 to translate what these girls are trying to
like it's just it's not possible it's not possible or it's not possible for me possible for other
agencies not yourself out but after three gents I am done I am helping the girls achieve their
dreams as much as possible at that point I have no interested in trying to infinitely expand and
have a billion talents out of once and no that's just no it's so disrespectful as well to the
to the girls um just being like oh but we're already throwing out the next gen some mailers
oh wait sorry sorry reefling was trade I'm sorry reefling hold on let me trade let me put this away
oh sorry
no reefling branch what is that what even is that
uh moles like wait why is that a million what are you doing
the drip the drip other players accepted wait you're giving me a million dollar
million gp freaking what is it oh oh emmy's not gonna like that
emmy's gonna have a word with that oh those are awful do you want these back
I'm gonna be honest chief I think you can have these back here let me trade except trade
wait how do I go back on the trade how do I get you flip flops wait how do I give it back I
don't want them they're scary emmy's gonna be mad do you want to back where are you I can't see
are you on me oh there you are here you go you take them back oh no you're busy in the bank
just sell it for more way in
honestly vealer has me really wanting to become a you're cool and I wish I could do the same sort
of stuff um if you're a guy unfortunately I don't have much of you but do you really not want these
back where are you trade give me take these things back
definitely just sell it I have like four of them vealer is on I can't uh no hablo espanol mate
eh you know mi casa y tu casa
Johnny la chanta es de muy loca right I've yanked the shoes they're mine now sorry
never give a minecraft hole your diamonds or she runs away with your mold shoes and runescape
ooh you're still streaming why are you sick of me already
ay ay ay mios dio
la pantheon la pantheon
pantheon
Nico to sleep please rest well yes anyone who needs to sleep please rest well
we are doing a cheeky endurance today so if you think you can hold on for another two hours then
if not then sick from how sweet your streams are too much sugar make tommy hurt
yeah I was like la chanta es de muy loca
boop boop boop boop boop boop boop and then there is that other one free those rats
which oh no free those rats there's a me oh she's shaking her hand at us
why I order looking stance
at least it's 30 minutes left for me maybe not much more though
go to sleep go to sleep
go to sleep my dear
before
I'm going to sleep
you're gonna have to use hypnosis wait I don't want to sleep though
but it's good for your health but you can't do it it's evil
fuck you you tangled me I tangled you that was an ASMR that was just me man
singing a little lullaby
strongy was streaming when I came to bed now I wake up and I continue continue watching hell yeah
all of a sudden I feel super hyper well after the lullaby my favorite saying apologies if I
bit you it oh as if I can read that
they really said loose lips sink ships I can't believe it you almost got me
it was lovely though oh your whispers can tingle alone
and I bet you like my whispers I start saying you just get ready to go to sleep
yeah normally these ones I'd stay up go to sleep or just play summer escape a little without
the hypnosis then just made me imagine you gengar
yeah gengar the hypnosis
might be the lullaby or the two kilograms of cocaína just no no I'll sleep when mom
sleeps just so lovely thank you mom oh thank you uh when the stream ends
emi and ac's memberships are gonna go
live because I'm gonna put them live because I'm such a good little streamer
such a good little streamer streamer no this doesn't make me a streamer
manager no I'm a little manager I just do the intern work and it keeps the stress off of them
as long as the girl's stress levels are low and I will I will be very happy
the point is to consume hypno content so much it conditions you it will work eventually
taking over a decade from when I became interested until I felt my first vision
mmm it was drowsy
yes I will my bedtime is 5 p.m. actually it's 1 p.m. right now and we've still got another what
two and a half hours yeah so then that would take me to what four p.m so I have one hour
basically to do all the stuff that I'm supposed to do and then I pass out and then when I wake up
I prepare for stream with a cup of honey tea and then I open up crash bandicoot warped and make
sure you guys can hear it and see it and then we go again and I believe tomorrow is eight hour
stream it's not endurance to finish the game it's eight hours would it be mean to let you know
you're 10% of the way to 99 what 10% of the way
I thought I could get it finished this month I don't think so
10% there oh yay oh no do you want to know the amount of exp required
it's 13 million oh I'm 10% of the way that so every million is like I guess
what 1.3 percent every million wait every million is 10.3 percent surely that's how it works is that
how math works break it down into chunks um 98 to 99 is like 1.2 million oh my god
peanut the forest is here you should be able to do it
every 1.3 million is 10 percent okay so we're just over 10 percent now okay that's not bad
we'll finish the sword fish I think we can finish the sword fish before the end of the stream and then
we'll tackle wine I'm going to buy a bunch of wine stuff and we're basically gonna watch a movie
while we do it so we can all giggle and laugh at movie um I think we'll do John Wick
this is perfect zatsu content and rambling yeah I did look at marshmallows I don't know
have many more marshmallows a lot of the marshmallows I can't really read for obvious reason
because refillings are a little okay let me check if there are any more
marshmallows oh okay definitely a few more marshmallows hold on let's go uh
oh no are you guys berating me because I lost four in a row
uh
uh I was split between giving my veal or membership uh cherry to emmy or to mercy
because each of the girls are intense young dairies and don't want their fans to flirt with
other girls then I remembered all the good times from hanging in your stream and I saw the third
option you me no you're supposed to support my daughters strongy sometimes during or after
emmy's membership opening I'm going to make a decision you're a strong prick I won't overlook
you when deciding refling or or pinpal or snippet whatever one you may be um please always support
my daughters over me if you can only support one at a time um please pick either daughter if you
struggle to pick between a daughter pick the design the default design you like the most
that's the easiest the most simplistic way to do it because your brain will either go I like this
design the most or I like that oh my god I thought Gimli was in the room there I had a heart attack
I always get nervous about spiders uh I don't like them um mostly there's a spider like a
working in the room can we add pictures or videos to marshmallows um you can via cat box um
if you want to show me something but you have to do the link and you have to make it easy
just remove the dot and put dot in brackets because if you do it any other way I'm too
pepega and can't open it off it's literally a logic puzzle to open up a link with when you
don't give me the link it's okay strongy we'll comfort you after this losses there there
head pads good girl hey wait didn't did you want us to help with those frustrations
would you like to be on whoa I can't read that whoa I can't read that
okay
can you read that you know that's kind of read that you know that's uh that's a offline
that's a offline one you know what I'm saying that's that's between me and offline
uh right let me let me scroll down to the next one uh hey strongy just wanted to thank
for all the fun streams you're welcome reflin I've especially enjoyed your ASMR streams your voice
and accent are just so pleasant to listen to I you like that I bet you do I also look forward
to the fun ways that you plan to main break it oh it's coming I hope you and the girls are having
a great time and go far with your content bro we're all in cloud nine like all of us are so happy
and our monetization streams are about to be done me and mercy are done I see and Emmy are next
then it's she be then it should be a zero whenever it gets granted I feel like it should happen now
I'm sorry strongy but I choose you you speak to me on a whole another level I love you cameo she
no you can't call me cameo she
well you do more twitter mosaic responses to the marshmallows yes I've been wanting to do it
and update it terribly terribly badly for a long time because I really enjoy writing the scenarios
to you guys like when you guys give me like a little prompt or something and I just take it way
too far it's my favorite thing to do uh yes I will definitely be doing that again soon it's just
every I say this every stream as the dust settles and all the little mini side projects get pushed
out the way then I can start to like really catch up because like whenever I do those two
other streams I'm catching up and like I'm literally going to the doctors after buckshot
roulette and then I'll be healing up for a bit um so ASMR with the viewer viewer beats you in a
board game a bunch till we let you win and then space you time to celebrate the victory honestly
that's quite funny um you being so silly not very bright and cute at the same time makes me want to
run and tackle you under the bed and cuddle you I would hug you and roll around under the covers
and never let you go where's can I explain how much I love you you're my sunshine oh you're my
sunshine are you playing uh you like when I'm dumb you like when I show how unbelievably
braindead I am yeah is that what you like sorry but you're being hard locked as my wishy-dus
we sure do oh allegedly why is it so hard to play freaking connect four
I don't know why it's so hard
she be just woke up and said I woke up a bit ago dizzy but wanting to be ravaged okay she
be she's doing better with her migraine you are more of a mother to me than my own parents and
I hardly even know you you are welcome well I didn't mean you're welcome like that but um
um sometimes it's a bit sucky but some people might not necessarily be the best parents
and sometimes it's easier to just take a deep breath and sigh and say they did the best with
what they had at the time with what they got and sometimes it's not easy to swallow the truth and
be like oh that really wasn't as nice because you know when you watch media it's like oh the loving
parents they they're so supportive they're so this or so that sometimes it's a hard pill to swallow
to say that you drew an unlucky hand and that might not necessarily mean you don't still share a love
for your primary caregivers um but there are some phrases in the English language that's like
the blood of the covenant is thicker than the water of the womb which basically just means the
connections that you seek out in life that are outside of your family can be just as valid if
not more loving than family because you don't pick family you don't you don't pick these aspects and
sometimes it's just easier to it's not easy to swallow the pill but sometimes it's easier to
just take a deep breath let out a big sigh and be like okay that's just how it is and I hope you're
doing okay yeah it it sucks but I'm I'm glad um you can feel a degree of motherly love um
you know I don't think anyone should be embarrassed or uh what's the word kind of like it's only human
nature to crave um to crave attention to crave love to create to crave these positive reinforcers
that show that you're a part of a community that you're welcome that you're wanted so don't ever
you know don't feel embarrassed about that just you know if you're needing kind of a way to to
put it away uh deep down inside you just let one big sigh and say yeah you know what that's
fucked that situation's fucked but I'm here I'm doing it I'm crushing life you know I've gotten
through the worst days of my life every every worst day of every experience yet you're still here
and you're still trucking along a little reefland and you're doing body you're doing a body good
job you are so don't don't worry about it all right don't worry about it you're doing great
doing fantastic
um will you for lack of better words recycle scripts with slight adjustments for the other
girls uh I no longer am the script master but the answer is no they're all being like created
from scratch um now they now it can it makes like some of the sentences might be the same but there's
only so many ways you can see give me that um um give me that schwan's um there's only so many
ways you can see it so uh there might be some repeated sentences but yeah thank you strong
now you
for sure in german you say schwan's schwan's conningen oh my god
ink for me written 500 different ways give me that give me that fire hose
say strongy nothing lid here i can't donate become a member or a preacher and just want to say
thank you for your streams and the content you provide it's a fresh take on vitro bin it's been
so so entertaining everything from the wholesome to the unhinged just sharing random things you
know watching you as a whole has given me so many laughs and that is so desperately needed in my life
especially the meme ASMR oh yeah you're like please please please let me hold it please please i'm
beggin
oh i didn't expect that 77 77 we're getting there 70 freaking seven i thought i was only
gonna finish on 70 today oh that's your man okay uh sorry let me let me continue um watching you
has wholeheartedly given me so many laughs that i so desperately especially meme ASMR
i wish you and the girl success of your dreams remember to take breaks ah
you are so funny remember take breaks
oh you're pouring one out for my tonial thank you pour one out for my tonial lived a good life
what a good life did right and did did me good well um 77 you're now at my level and i played for
like eight years what there's that saying it was like took four years to do this vtuber does it in
one week took four took this man four years vtuber comes in and does it in a week i say that as if
reeflings didn't like hand me all of the fish and everything laughs and i can do
got that pop-up answer my question guess that pop-up answer my question you can now cook
blood runes or can make haggis
get this woman on rune crafting absolutely not we are not touching rune crafting when a 10 foot pole
hmm wow let's see where we're at yes please don't ever worry about not being able to
donate give money all that jazz free content always coming brov life is freaking hard especially
economically in these times um where greed is just everywhere hold on that tinfoil hat's coming
back hold on no go away tinfoil hat just in times like this it is much more valuable and much more
much more valuable much more important that you look after yourself that you look after whatever
situation you're in if you have debts you pay them off if you need a sweet treat you indulge in it
if you you know after work you need to play video games to de-stress make sure your internet
bill is paid and make sure your electricity bill is paid so you have access to these abilities to
de-stress to handle the work day to handle the workflow or to handle any life stresses that you
might be going through um there are just countless situations where people are just going through
hell on earth on the inside and on the outside they look perfectly fine and you'd have absolutely no
clue what on earth is going on with them and you know the last thing people want to be dealing with
is um just this stress that builds and builds and builds and builds and builds until you pop
people pop people have burnout people have breakdowns like you can pop so easily so make sure
and you know you're looking after yourself first because at the end of the day you are the most
important person in your life and that's the fact for everyone's pov right now you are the most
important person in your life it's the way it works okay and you have to look after yourself
first you have to make sure that you're feeling good you have to you have to enable yourself
um to be on your prime like i'll wipe out mazl's hierarchy and needs right now do not think i won't
do it i will start a psychology lecture right this second i will put my teacher's glasses on
and it is very important to meet your needs first before you ever try and meet the needs of someone
else however the exception is that a the stupid sentence i've heard is uh love yourself first
before you love someone else or something like that shut the fuck up that's the most nonsense
statement i've ever heard everyone can share the love to any degree and that's my take on that sense
um you can share love at any point it is simple to share a little bit of love glasses toggle
no not glasses toggle i never got glasses on my model uh this is helping me procrastinate my
final oh no that's not good damn i fell asleep for 13 hours and you're still screaming yeah do you
need iron supplements sleeping for 13 hours indicates low iron you might want to get that
checked out or just start taking iron supplements go for it have fun you can only take one dose
a day anyway cooking was my first 99 in old school rinse game are you gonna end up making
wine it's expensive but the fastest yes we are doing wine i stopped doing wine reeflings gave me a
ton of fish so i'm cooking all the fish first wine it requires a lot of focus like i keep missing
the fermentation period for an xp bomb um i used to sleep when giving a ton of blood and they said
i had high iron oh i don't know high iron would be how much red meat do you eat i didn't actually
you just still stream for such a long time oh okay uh comprehend i understand
if you want the truth anything that might take you away from us
makes me want to cry but i'm not what can take me away from you
motherfucker i am veiler nothing can stop me other than an internet connection that's about it
you know you don't have to worry about me going anywhere nothing nothing can perish me and we
already know what we say to death we say to death not today motherfucker i've got reeflings okay
and they've got me and we've got a lot we've got a lot of time to make up for okay um got another
dim post i don't know what i do without you don't panic reefling i'm not going anywhere
don't panic stop panicking
the deadly tone version do you know how that's how bob marley passed away apparently he rejected
penicillin because of his beliefs and bob marley that this is love this is love this is love that
i'm feeling that singer passed away because he rejected penicillin
why do you keep opening that i don't even know how i'm doing that um yeah like sauce i'm snorting
penicillin for free like you don't have to tell me twice if i need it
at that a modern modern tag and don't take it bro she's gonna reject pen no i'm not other than my
dad's allergic to penicillin um
mommy i need a countdown please let me ink uh i don't know if you're on the patreon but there's
a new patreon audio with that in it uh unending stamina good i didn't try that uh yeah i was freaking
i was clapping i was clapping without my hands asmr and then right at the end of it i was like
oh i was a little cheeky kind of thing might as well i'm allergic to that stuff yes penicillin
can be incredibly deadly for some people which is crazy um i'm pretty sure the guy who discovered
penicillin did it by a complete accident as well which was rather interesting uh it was just a
complete accident it casually discovers something that saves literally millions of lives can't uh
you know just get a little casual probably in the billions as time goes on easily a billion lives
saved because of little accidental petri dish discovery um truly fascinating fascinating
should maybe go into the lore of biology uh no should go into the lore the start of modern
the wonders of modern medicine now i'm mercy
how many things can you take out of time i don't know refland should we meet up at the convention
and find out would you make us a hypnosis to to get as hard just by hearing oh why i didn't
mean to say that part out loud sorry sorry i'm forgetting to censor i'm forgetting to censor
i've been streaming for a hot second now sorry i didn't mean to say that out loud sorry i'm
sorry i'm sorry i'm supposed to censor what i say
okay let me try gas my not my not say so we should we're on a list um would you make us a
hypnosis session to get a the tentacle giving a standing ovation uh just by hearing your voice
and have the strongest ink when we hear you ain't that's an interesting one i wouldn't mind giving
that a tackle um i'll see so the four part series is one of the first attempts i have ever recorded
it is not very good i'll just say that right now it's not go away chat when he's my wife now
um i will say that the four free to access audios are my first ever attempt i'm not very satisfied
with them looking back on them already even though i only produced them like a month and a bit ago
and so do give me patience to kind of learn what works what feedback i get um i'm very shy but if
you wanted me to in the middle of a crowded city in broad daylight i would do it that's how much i care
about you break the law for me do you know it's against the law to do that stuff i would when
you break the law mommy i haven't inked in days because i've been spending all my weekend hours
watching veiler boy i can't help but support the girls because they make me so happy and i don't
well livestream it i'm so pent up i need mommy tell me what to do do you have any of the girls
patreon or if you're a pin pal emi has a really good funny kenta i don't think i have a i don't
have a full audio yet that's accessible wow just ink into the void what was it yeah oh did that
do it for you yeah you like that i swallowed it all and then and then did a big old burp at the end
you
day ten of eating celery no wait have i said that did i say that i think i might
read that one already stop eating celery for me it's terrible it's it's just like better water
in a solid form
congrats on hoover little dude
these sucky five bucks asking for a friend
stony i'm really sorry i tried very hard but i just couldn't i watched live streams and
and listened to audios none of our daughters do it for me i keep coming back to you hope you
understand you're my kamyoshi i'll stop i don't know how you're gonna kamyoshi i still support
them however i can forever you're beefling all beefling thank you for you know thank you for
giving them a shot i would say shivi is like incredibly close to me like mentally and personality
pretty close unless i'm like completely like misreader but i'd say she's probably the closest
uh personality wise and easiest to consume
uh i would love to share some fanfics but i don't know if it's appropriate even a lot do you
can but if it is weird us of metal uh i think you can do pace bin links i think those are safe
hi strongy hi refling did you know the term architect and features and comes from the irish
actor pierce raw brosnan who is rumored to have intentionally made his wife gain 100 pounds over
the course of 20 years the term itself is from a quote made on the architects of peace home page
a world without wheels it's too terrible to imagine he did not write a book and call it that
stop is that why he did wait is that from a book he wrote
oh my god that's outrageous outrageous but really funny
i like how ic is sweet and emmy is false to the wall insane
i will continue myself right now go to sleep
hi strongy your way of gentle talking is one of my favorite triggers i think if you did scott's
it'd be amazing is there a way to control my well on stream on youtube funny you mentioned that
have you considered using uh bitmosis to plant suggestions that are wholly positive and affirming
for the viewer something to encourage them when they're down to give them that little push when
they're low don't don't want to do the dishes strongy would want you to don't want to cook and
just want to order out strongy would want you to cook strongy would want me to live my best life
that's interesting i'm wondering if i could do a putting you to sleep asmr but it's secretly
hypnosis and then after you've fallen asleep then i would do like that kind of
in in in planting you've got me thinking a lot of each one you've got me thinking the cogs are
turning you got me at help you go to sleep yes i think you could do it if you establish triggers
outside of youtube and use of any issue asi is way more insane i thought emi was uh having fun
asi's just yeah she doesn't like sharing of g fog sand sands or something that
has been sent somewhere else she doesn't like that that would be perfect imprinting on me oh my god
hypnosis is
what is deceit too
i'm about to get pranked when i look off on us
bank the banker
why do you do that i'm getting pranked
so
the c2 has just released its free to play update so i'm making an updated guide for it as there are
many new things around the map whether that be players weak points below about 50 sanity one
grab from a terror will kill it is it where wait if i'm getting chased by a werewolf the streaming
gonna end good that's on something honey soaked am i getting chased by a werewolf in that game that's
terrible all of us are gonna be freaking mail on stream me oh sorry i'm looking at a how to play
deceit to full gay 2024 my apologies sorry um all right that was loud oh i'm sorry my bad my bad
i was just trying to see what the gameplay was about there's werewolves
bro sounded nice though i mean we've we've been through the comp
it was just loud my apologies didn't mean to jump serious
we're at 2000 swordfish can i do it do we have enough time
cutting it close cutting it close i think it's possible are you squinting me right now
science is a wonderful thing like the scientist fritz harba who with carl bosh invented the harba
bosh process to synthesize ammonia since then it has been possible to supply millions of people
with food and toxic gas and chemical warfare i'm sure the government would never poison its
citizens on purpose no that's it give me the tinfoil hat back on i'm about to tell you what american
have done as people thank you iron reaper for the 20 my goodness you sure you give a lot of money
you sure everything's okay um you got figure out who the infected are and either kill them
or do the task and escape without dying you either try and betray your friends could be cool i'm
addicted to this hmm well if i'm getting chased by a werewolf whatever happens i'm gonna just let
it happen i strongly you're gonna get all logged out in 52 minutes unless you hold wait actually
i need to like purposely time out
but why why can't people be addicted to games i'm an adult i consent to being addicted to old
school runescape and playing with reefing you can log back out in as well yeah i'll probably go for
a tinkle break in an hour and make a cup of tea just for my throat um unless i don't know
carl bosh not to be confused with carl bosh you want some madness fuel look at the all all the
times america has stuck its nose into um but did you ask her overlords i know i never asked
overlords for permission silly me silly me silly me streamer
sure then you can just look back and i bear or i bear or i do more
what
what is a paste been like oh hey oh sorry this sorry this is what i said it's my accent you
can't it's not your fault it's my accent the website is called paste bin
off to bed rest well yeah for anyone please don't be worried if you need to say hey ho i gotta go um i
um i'm gonna keep hey strongy day nine of keeping my tentacles off myself thank you for being you
gonna keep going unless your your audios do something for me you're just having an effect on
me that i want to do better myself i even think my mood has improved and i haven't gotten angry today
uh but flash out so again thank you love you have you too recent
don't you get frustrated though oh i think i would get frustrated the goodest boy around thank
you for becoming a member what a nice thing goodest boy around jack of blades 399 thank you for
becoming a member and supporting the channel thank you for thank you for smashing that like button
that's it's cool but yeah i'm not really good at doing that part never ask a woman to meet her age
a man his salary or a country about the warm crime they come in literally that would be a
really interesting thing uh stream as well talking about all the you know the one story i really
don't like is the the guy they kept alive that got covered in radiation and they kept him alive
and his body couldn't accept painkillers
they couldn't give him morphine and he was alive for like another two weeks just radiating away
oh trade sorry sorry sorry my bad sorry sorry bruv sorry bruv excuse me pardon me
meds bad is your name isn't that dangerous
what is this a bird are you giving me a bird and a biscuit a wooden shield and a shoulder
stop can i wear that on my shoulder
reefling you're you're a cockatoo wherever these birds are called a toucan oh my god reeflings
you're a toucan reeflings are a toucan you're so cute i got a little birdie on my shoulder
parrot no you're a toucan oh my god they're so cute wait you want more or am i going crazy
no oh wait sorry sorry sorry i thought i said i wanted something wait you want more
trade accepted no i'm so cool every time i learn something nice from german history it ends and
yeah pretty much never ask why a vaults wagon is so popular such a successful business whoa what's
this loot chest how have i not seen this i've been here for how long you do not currently have any
wilderness loot keys okay well excuse you maybe some of us don't want wilderness loot keys
our fanta what was it was it portugal no not portugal
um it was like oh why i randomly have like german ancestry and i'm argentinian and it's like
bro the chest is for loot killing yeah we are now here to pk argentina or hugo boss or coco chanel
yeah who is it that made the uniforms and they like never talk about it
me when i met my argentinian friends great grandfather i let it to like oh hello
yeah don't be scared
einhorn start repeating random german words that unknown phrases
yeah every every company have been doing a little naughty naughty are we the baddies
isn't there like a whole town of is there that's news timmy
uh i don't think we're gonna get 20 by the time the stream finished i got two hours
we're cooking up the swordfish honestly the swordfish ain't that bad 140 isn't that bad
perky swordfish i'm not mad at that i know wine is a lot faster and i understand wine is a lot
faster but this i'm i'm binkering danjuma binkering i have to be up early for lab yes please rest well
anyone who needs to sleep or you've got commitments or you gotta go and do stuff please don't worry
you're more than welcome to um to what to go rest or go get stuff done i am literally cooking these
and then doing wine until it's time to until the vod is ready to explode and if mersey is still
playing harvester two she might be we might get a successful redirect into mersey or i don't know
if a zero is doing a part two of stray or she's gonna try and just stray in one run and
um
i thought it was less than two yeah no it oh well it's less than two hours now
boo youtube vods fix them so i can do 14 hour streams
boo youtube youtube remember to sell old cooked swordfish when you're done
we'll get pretty penny
night night cuddles rest well sleepy heads
and rest your little head
rest well
24 hour stream no if youtube's vods didn't break on 12 hours i would definitely push
14 hour streams um can you convert them into bank notes it kind of looks like you can only
sell in stacks of 20 yes you can make bank notes in order to make a bank note you go to the bank
don't do why click there you go to the bank and then it says withdraw as and then you've got no
and then you click on it no all and then i produce a note so you have to do it via the bank
via withdraws item because i'm currently wanting to interact with the items that i'm pulling out
and but that's how you do it and you can sell them all at one time so it'll be easy
and don't worry that you didn't know because you don't know until you know
enjoy the rest of the cooking stream love you strongy love you replay
rest well sleepy heads you're allowed to you're allowed to go to sleep
but how what how did i what what are you giving me
is that splodge of cum be honest what is that what did you just oh what even was that
it looks like a piece of an alien or something what did you just give me
did you just give me ink
is that ink oh it's a wolf clock dumbass what on earth that looks like ink
wow oh my god i'm like kidding out the wazoo like i'm getting so pimped out right now
i'm not being funny i'm literally getting dressed up to go like to valador and like
hoon myself out honestly oh no it takes off my parrot oh i can't have both no i need a
rifling on my shoulder do you want the wolf back i'll give you the wolf back where are you
trade here take take the wolf back i can't have it
i can't have the wolf you need to take it back because i need to have the rifling on my shoulder
all yours thank you
oh that's raw swordfish
maybe 30 minutes i'll make a cup of tea because my voice is really starting to
what do you mean talking for 10 hours straight means my voice gets tired
whoa that i've never that's ridiculous that's ridiculous i've never heard that before
hmm hydration drink
wow yes i think i might make a cup of tea in the heat should hopefully help my vocal chords
but they're starting to feel it mr crabs seriously how frustrating
i think they say like one of the worst things you can drink is like dairy and fizzy juice when
you have like long vocal activity i'm like ah yes the two worst things that i consume constantly
i have fizzy juice every day and i have a honey tea every day
i finally got my painting desk cleaned off time a pain oh my god
we should do a bob ross stream oh the wolf caught me down the floor
okay boom we're at 1.8 for the the fishy uh i guess once all these fishies are done we'll sell
them and then i'm just gonna buy a ton of wine strongly doesn't like my wolf go no i do like it
but it removes the rifling from my shoulder i know it looks nothing like a rifling but i want to be
hot
i'm just working on cooking on my airman oh some of them go
yeah those are the two literally you're not supposed to have any dairy and i have like milk
honey peas and then we compare paintings by the end honestly i'm down for that i saw a tweet where
someone had to do vocal warm-ups like a thing oh you're supposed to go like
like i got carried with my friends my i'm out of stamina i'm out of juice vocally i'm
who goes there i'm out of stamina i saw yeah
why one interesting number of marshmallows literally 9-11 i'm curious
why did this day please hold on your
uh
have we just gained a far anon
did i read this out loud or is this gonna have everyone saying wtf
i think we've just gained a far anon
please hold in your fars until it starts to get painful and then blast them onto the mic
close-up so we can hear your cheeks clapping beneath the the basic burst of breath
actually did she be far in a stream did i don't know if someone told me she be my
vaginal is suited in the middle of one of the streams
i mean i don't judge but i don't think i need you to do that
look we don't really we don't kink shame around here okay she be and eme both did wait
wait and i've not clipped it stop please tell me you guys clipped it so i can turn it into a short
for some reason hiccups burps and fart clips of v-tubers get so many views i don't even care
if it embarrasses them i'm like i will get you your play button one way or another and i keep
farting down that make young lady oh yes strongy um for some reason hiccups sneezes any normal
bodily function when when vtuber does it hilarious views and i'm like what it doesn't make any sense
strongy milk in the clips literally though i wonder why
rap was actually when i got that so so bad
the eme one there should be a timestamp in the comments for it oh thank god thank you
timestampers you helped me cut my gen mates no the buraptubers no i think we're i think peeler is
definitely what we're at hi strongy i just want to say i love you and i think you're perfect
stop it refling you're perfect see i kissed you that's how perfect you are you can't deny the
allegations i'm done okay ah my tummy's rumbling but i think it's digested not rumbling
pee holding stream when are you a pin pal are you the one who convinced eme to do that on her stream
it must have been you it must have been you pin pal i can i can smell you a male away pin pal
got my stomachs making me realize this i've had the 3d on my gray now you would have heard all of
smell a pin pal
i can't believe her wailed that stream once is it i've not seen it is it bad can you get
kidney stones from that i went to bed get up and you're still cooking these swordfish
there was five no there was 10 000 swordfish if i make 10 000 swordfish one stream that means
i can do 10 000 wine in one stream most likely if not more it means bod is back up actually did
she cut something out of it i do not know i've been streaming unfortunately
when i stream all day i have no clue what shenanigans the girls are getting up to in all honors though
so
wait that video is still getting recommended to people 24 000 views 2 000 likes i wonder if
because people are liking it strongy has the best boing boing azura has biggest boing boing
or do you mean rump i have the biggest rump
all the perfect all the all the better to smother you with three flights she's out
pealard anything that ever happened the audio after this it takes a day do you think you'll
feel accomplished when you get night and then cooking i hope so i'm in the trenches right now
on this swordfish
she accidentally played the clip on stream she forgot to turn off this
oh you can pass away if you drink too much water she actually uploaded it to me
ah
uh okay okay okay okay she already has a warning on her channel
Amy playing with fire but then again she is the pyromaniac of uh
veal or so right i'm right on par i can't believe i can't believe i found such a
lower friendly girl's smile
i have to admit i think i'm starting to lag a bit it's not looking good for me slowly
perishing i'm like dad make a tea but i don't think it's gonna wake me up but i think it's gonna
uh oh my stomach's making freaking weird ass noises can you hear that
what will come first heat death of the universe or full inventory no burn
honestly i feel like i'm getting so close to it and i'm getting although the burn percentage
is 9.4 it used to be 18.9 she cut it out from the vod we're safe question mark i'm firmly of the
opinion there's such a thing as being too big what's 99 after cooking no we're just doing cooking
we might do some questing together because i'm not familiar with a lot of quests um but that would
just be very casual um probably level up combat a little bit before that um once we've achieved
99 cooking um i am not 99ing anything else i have severely underestimated how much this is
a strong expect full to the kaboom if you ever do the cat quest you have to feed it when it's a
kitten or it runs away that's so specific i'm probably never gonna retain this information
i'm going to go for a full 99 account for the first time oh you're brave
and the other version of runescape levels go up to 120 did they take even longer to achieve
oh that's crazy sorry oh i'm having a wee on sorry
oh my god i'm in the money lads i'm sorry i really don't want to flex on you guys but we're in the money
oh
look ah whoa fill inventory no burn get ready get ready to ever said no burn
hold on hold on hold on so this is what it looked like a minute ago
so that was the last time i shared it with you 19.8 okay and the money didn't register but now the
money's registered are you ready to get flexed on where is it are you ready to get flexed on how
much money i made on that video boom that's right get flexed on to say that gen 2 has been funded
is an understatement that's how much money i've made what are you gonna do about them
it got limited ads so it probably would have been like 20 bucks if it wasn't limited ads
but you know what 10 bucks i'll take you you'll be logged out in 30 minutes make sure you move
to a safe area or log out now your mama right i am going to go make a cup of tea then if it's
going to log me out so i can come back in getting 120 is getting 99 about eight times
pass on that no thanks how do people make a living off of youtube oh it's much better than
this when you have like a a lot of ASMR videos to offer um you make like money generated in the
background right i'm going to go make a cup of tea and let this game log me out um i will be back
i would just take me about three minutes because you can't leave the world
they're in the runescape's uh gadebrook strongy
uh right i'll be yeah three minutes and i'll make a cup of tea please do stretch your legs
and all that jazz and i will be back in three minutes which i've said for the eighth time now
sorry i'm losing it well yeah i'll be back
um
You
Oh, it's actually quite a lot louder than in-game audio. Sorry if that like completely destroyed your ears
Hope no one's sleeping through this
Her account has gone too. Wait, who's the count? Look at that
What was I doing?
fish fish fish
I am starting to pass out. I'm not gonna lie. I'm getting very tired. I'm a throats way of sore
Which is why I need refling tea
Not just any kind of honey tea
Log out timer is five minutes
The music was pretty loud. Okay, man. I apologize. I've got honey on my freaking finger as well
I'm not the good- I'm not my refling honey. I need a special refling honey. The menu music apparently a separate set. Yeah
Monkey badness
I
Sleepy little refling because we're already snows together honestly. Oh, I'm I'm getting tired myself
Oh gee Hermes, thank you for becoming a member as a remainder
All membership streams
No
Next week membership streams start because I've already locked in what happens this week
Next week is very busy
is next week when
Uh
Elden Ring comes out. It's today next week Elden Ring DLC comes out. Okay, so
The start of the week is gonna be like a
multitude of different things going on. It's a little bit crazy sometimes
Refling tea you mean ink tea? Exactly. That's what my refling tea is
Passed it four times, but I got the tea
I bet oh my god
I love the stories where it's like my legs are quaking after a good session. I'm like, oh my god
Oh, no, that's not it is I can't feel my legs after
How hard I was beating in that session those ones always make me crack up
What's good
Uh
Was good. Uh, we're going 10 and a half hours strong. We're wrapping up an hour
In less than 30 because of the void restriction. Um, I am going to see if mercy is available
to read into or a zero
and
Oh, my tummy keeps making noises. It's because I need uh, did I end up going for a job?
No, it wasn't successful. I had an unsuccessful attempt at adjubi, which is why my stomach's making
Uh, bizarre noises right now. Oh my god. I'm starting to get like full cooked sword run swordfish ones, which is amazing
Do your reeflings want your money back? Am I undetected brieflings? Oh, no
Is there any runescape reeflings that I'm indebted to?
But I don't have any money
How will I ever repay you runescape reefling for all the things you've done for me?
I
Get wrecked and connect for apparently
Left for a bit and you're still going. Oh, I'm a tough cookie
Hard hard to get me to crack
When I say, uh, I need to make up for lost time. Am I I wasn't kidding?
I wasn't kidding. Uh, literally next week. We've got like four. Maybe even five
Oh
Well, please don't be getting sick. I really don't want to get sick. Oh, I'm not gonna make it if I get sick
I'm not gonna make it. I really don't want to get sick
Bless you. Thank you. He's on high. I accept ASMR's payment. Oh, yeah
Poor little
Needing something
One hour of agility treatment is payment because I can't be bothered
bro
I need to maybe get the agility shortcut wherever it is on the map. It's like 21 to do the grand exchange shortcut
We formally request snitches. Mmm. Thank you for being my sugar daddy on RuneScape
Thank you for making it super easy real emmy versus strony connect for
The real
Strony milkers warm and tasty strony milkies, please be hasty. Oh my god, that's such a good
Uh, there's a connect for minigame in RuneScape. There absolutely is. Do you want to know how I know?
There's a connect for minigame in RuneScape. Uh, I got absolutely annihilated by all the reeflings unanimously at once
Uh, the only reason I think I won I won one game by tryharding and I won a second game by mistake
Because the other reefling wasn't paying attention
And I was literally eating a burrito and I was like
With my mouth full of a burrito
If you're going to do agility there's a quest so you can skip a lot of it
I think when we do 99
Cookin will probably take a solid break from any RuneScape streams for a bit
Because there are a few other like multiplayer games I want to like focus on like Elden Rings like the next big
Like a thing we're taking on
and
I don't even hear my stomach
No, you can't the mic's not cover it is covering up
The stronies milk tastes like jelly. I even know what cuttlefish milk would taste like
Would it be gelatinous or would it be silky like ink?
I think it may be silky
Worthing
Love these 20 things
Thank you for the smoothies
Also need to be on a members world for uh
I'm blamed when it comes to board games. I lost fair and square though. Okay. Okay. Okay
Well, actually who's got the higher IQ reeflings or stronies clearly the reeflings clearly
Wow, we're at 1.4 on the swordfish we may be able to finish it
We might just be out of time, but honestly, it's not the biggest deal. However
You need to give strony the monkey not items. That's so specific
and
Eng would be salty if it's anything like squid ink. You've eaten squid ink before
You've eaten your fellow reeflings before oh, we're in 1.6k territory at 1.6 million monkey not 287
I blame all my eyes
I'm on are you eating your fellow reeflings? What's going on here?
See be honest
You were just randomly placing the pieces, but I wasn't law
I was trying to counteract what the reefling was doing. That's the worst part
I was actually trying to win and I could never see what the reefling was making
I was too busy trying to like get ahead and make something for me that I couldn't see what the reefling was doing
Is worse than emmy rip of my jeans what I listen to emmy stream and if I recall correctly my glass prescription is worse than emmy
Oh emmy cannot see oh my goodness bless her cotton socks. She can't see for
A reefling's gotta do what he got a scuba doo ba doo
Yeah, you literally saw what I was doing and then you forgot no because I was trying to like
I was trying to be like all the reeflings doing this the reeflings doing that right
So I'm not gonna place one here and then I'd immediately forget
I
Mods creases jays
You really want me to believe that? Yeah
I was like trying to think ahead
I believe I can't believe I made it 10 us always
Feels good, man
Wow
Okay, these swordfish are giving me like what
7k a batch that's not bad
Honestly not that bad. I know wine is more which is fine
But I think that's like 7k exp of inventory if I don't burn them all. Okay. Okay
Well spoke too soon on that one
I
Got some level up. It's time to beat on up on connect for strategy. It's like I'm beat strong the next time
What's my burn percentage? Oh, it's like oh, I guess it's not up to accuracy because I'm logged out
I got logged out against me will yeah, um
Right tomorrow's crash bandicoot, which is eight hours. So it's just a long stream in quotation marks
Not an endurance
Short stream is two hours. Um, which is buckshot roulette, but that's because I've got the doctor
And uh, I'll keep you guys up to date on what on earth is happening with me toe
But it's pretty much decided if you guys want to hold a funeral during buckshot roulette
You're more than welcome to pour one out for the toe
It's been a good run, but
I'm just no fussed for it. Does they make a difference to me?
To me
Riptoe
It's a great lineup. Yeah, I did um, I
Want or probably can't do it tonight because I'm going to be shattered
I need to go put emmy and icys memberships live literally as soon as I end this stream
So I need to
What do I need to do?
I need to
Do that
I wanted to look up baltro more because that actually looks like a genuinely fun game
I just need to comprehend what on earth i'm doing first
I don't know. Maybe I need to play it offline like off stream for a little bit just to get the hang of it
Or is it better if streamer plays it for the first time?
Like I don't think watching other people play it is cheating. I don't know
Rips a big gripper. You will be missed literally both of them. No, no just the one
Shawnee caught the da budus. Oh no, do you think I've got da budus?
Um
Oh my god
streamer tries american sweet loses toenails loses toenail within
one week
Diabetes hits hard on streamer
How many features do you see how many where we get no burns?
How many multiplayer games are on your to-do list multiplayer games are every week
Um next multiplayer game is elden ring for a while and then
Probably jellybean
I love my jellybean. I don't know if they've added more stuff to it
Um, we never gave dead by daylight ago. I don't know how that would work
I think I would have to add you guys as friends possibly on steam and then delete everyone at the end
I don't know. I wanted to give fortnite a shot, but folk were rolling their eyes at fortnite
But i'm like fortnite's actually know that bad
As far as i'm aware, they've like added in different game modes and stuff
um
I want uh, I would say mario kart but I suck at mario kart and it and
Like I don't I don't know how to do that new turn feature thing in it
Like we have to like turn left and right well
Call it momay win the jellybean game
It's a meme to hate fortnite at this point
It's just
Ever listened to rap city you want to sing it?
Is this the real life or is this just fantasy?
Caught in a landslide no escape from reality
Look in your eyes. I don't know the words and see
uh
No, no, no, no, no, no, no, no
So you think you can stop me and make me cry
So you think I'm just gonna lay down and die
Oh baby
Just can't wait to go just can't wait to go here. Is that the word?
I don't know. I don't know.
Um...
I was thinking about the in-game song. Oops.
My bad.
Where does- where does that go?
Easy come, easy go, little high, little low
Anyway the wind blows, it doesn't matter to me
I'm just a poor boy from a poor family, he's just a poor boy
Spare him his life from this monstrosity
Uh, how else does it go?
Galaleo, Galaleo, Galaleo, Galaleo, Galaleo
Oh no, no, no, let him go
Don't let him go
I can't remember how that freaking goes
What to unlock it so you can listen to it?
Though I finished these freaking swordfish before I fall asleep
I'm like so tired, my eyes are bulging out of their skull right now
I'm ready to snooze
Although I might level up actually, before I snooze
Best cover, let me go, we will not let you go
No, no, no, no, no
No, it's important, it's good
Best cover, oh yeah, did you enjoy that, me guessing all the lyrics of that entire thing
Cause I completely forgot how it works
That's like full level now
Wow, we're gonna be 78 by the end of this, feels good man
Feel good man
Oh excuse me for yelling
I'm so going to bed, oh my god
I'm just a perv, we fun, I need no sympathy
Wait what?
I wonder, I'm just a perv
Cause I have a mummy, mummy's losing the plot, that's what mummy's doing right now
I'm starting to get about H2O delirious up in here
There's a bird outside my window, the magpies are probably wondering why I haven't said them today
I can do it, I promise
I can do it, I can stay up, I'm totally not exhausted
But it's okay
I can make it happen
Yay!
I didn't get any seratonin but I think it's cause I'm so tired
There's no seratonin left in my system
You don't have anything to burn on the fire, I do so
Level 78, let's go
Level 78
Well now I gotta adapt the learn
Yeah eventually seratonin only comes from netting it
Man this game was rigged from the start
Reach for the start
Yippee!
78, well I definitely blew over my guesstimate for what we would be on
But I'm still back at level 62
That's fine
Maybe Wayne cost a lot of money though, that's the only problem
Are we friends? I can do it
I can do it, you kid
I could also cook and not waste exp, she's passing out, oh yeah
Oh my god I'm actually, like this sleep is really starting to hit me
I don't even have my tea yet
Can you hear it, can you tell them?
Wah, KFP with another 10
Thank you, my goodness
Are you squidding me right now?
Congrats to those who caught the membership with their faceballs
Oh I wasn't even cooking them swordfish, I'm getting so disheartened
I have my copper tea in my hand right now
I should probably go to sleep, I'm freaking ready to go
Are you squidding me right now?
But she doesn't know if you're playing for another hour or not
If there's any wee snippets that want to be a deer and pass on a message from Mummy
A big bug
Zero grapes in Vorkuta
Oh wait, sorry that's the boat from Black Wolf
Didn't make it sad
What's your take on levelling up without OO, only to your level?
Oh no, you can level up all you want, it's perfectly fine too
For me personally, I'm not going to level up offline
Thank you again KFP Spidey for the gifted mumber
Okay, that was a big stagger
Star, I'm very tired
I will drink my tea now
The gifted membership was what I was supposed to say in English
The royal monkey
Cooking on top of the strony
Mercy said that she will lately still be live in an hour
Okay, thank you snippets for checking that out
I can do it
I can do it, 50 minutes
Oh Mummy can do it, Mummy's just very tired
Do your reflexes
I'm ready to pass out, oh my god my bed time's normally 5 o'clock
I've got 2 more hours until bedtime and I'm perishing
I don't want to end early though, the whole point is supposed to be the same
I don't want to end early though, the whole point is supposed to be endurance
Oh my god, this is like whacking me for the sake of my head
Normally I don't do
Oh my god, please cooperate
My brain's not cooperating, oh crap
Sleepy beepy mummy
Almost there, almost there, we just have to hold on and replay
Please hold on with me, hold, we can do it
We just have to cook these billions swordfish that we were kindly gifted replay
Strani, what's your feelings about a you start sleepy time when your girlfriend just happens to
See, on me, no, me doing that to you, absolutely
I will discuss more of that in the member stream, maybe
Hold the lane, hold the lane, I'm holding
Okay, so far so good
Old school runescape is heavy due to insurance game, only game to challenge Strani this much
Literally I'm like so tired out of nowhere
I was supposed to eat that food and I was supposed to freaking help me
Get more energised and I just want to roll up into a ball and pass out
I'm like sipping honey tea, it's got caffeine in it, it's going to do absolutely nothing for me
A sugar crash, did I eat? Would that take away half sugar in it?
You can sleep early
Someone got a clues girl
Oh, on me, on you, a true Strani classic
Honestly, I feel really bad, but like I want to do like all these things to you, Rieflin
But you doing it to me, I'm like, I'm too scared
Or like I'm not, that's not really doing much for me
But me doing it to you, eh
Like the terrible ones that you're not supposed to speak out loud
I've written on some kind of sugar
Oh, sugar, sugar, bum, bum, bum, bum, bum, bum
Oh, honey, honey, mm, mm, mm, mm, mm
You ask my candy Rieflin
And you've got me, mm, mm, mm
Our bodies are ready, please
Always happy to be your guinea pig
No, it's good, I love that
No, I'll be fine, I promise, I'm fine, I'm fine, I can do it
Endurance, endurance, endurance, I will make sure I'm redirecting Mercy in this next batch
Because it's not going to work out
I'm feeling kind of tired, but I'm going to stick it out through until you get off
I'm getting off right now, I'm ovulating
Oh, no, my filter is going, I'm sorry, I shouldn't be saying that stuff
I'm sorry, I shouldn't be saying that stuff
Hold on, let me wake the frick up, let me wake up
Wake up, wake up, wake up, wake up, wake up
Grab a little makeup
Put the keys upon the table, something, something else, it's like a fable
Let's get Mercy's
Livestream, Old Skilled Rinskate
Customization, Direct
And it should have picked Mercy
Should have picked any kind of support
I'm sorry for saying that out loud
Mommy's getting tired
System of a Down Reference, yeah, chops away
She makes a lot of random base references
Should have gotten a Scotland Fender with
In your 20s, are you an OG-san?
There you make sure you're an OG-san, surely
Surely
You should stream more when you're both tired, and I'll be like
Sorry, I don't know if you know
I don't remember that till day they do it
Who does it?
The day who does what?
What does that mean?
But the game ends up going offline
Oh, like the game updates for patches
Yeah, there he tags that, there he won
So on death's door, no!
Witchy-sans are supposed to be fairies
I don't know, we ended up being...
It's all in four, your tears are what I live for
Cause you should have picked Mercy
Should have picked any kind of girl of your...
Yeah, my tummy!
I don't know if you can hear those internal farts
But if you can hear the internal farts
I'm sorry, I had to be this way
Didn't I see this stream this morning?
Kinda was, yeah, yeah, you did
I'm a wee bit addicted
I'm starting to lose the plot though
So you're welcome to watch my Descent Into Madness
My filter is also gone
Because I'm starting to see things I know I'm not supposed to see
They're kinda just coming out, just like your ink, you know?
Only so much I can do
We're actually gonna get less than a thousand sorbys
Internal farts? No, they are internal farts
Well at least something's digested
But this must mean I'm discussing
To make myself wealthy
She's slowly dying from my innocence
I came in at work quite tired and feisty
Wrote an entire world domination agenda on my calendar
Are we done it? Are we taking down the big companies?
Eleven hour grind set, interest of thoughts are in taking the wheel
Take the wheel
Man, really?
Oh, I completely started to do that
Man, RuneScape is really...
OG
Yes, old school RuneScape
RuneScape 3, which is the new one, I think
Not really played that at all
I didn't actually understand
When it came out, there was two different games
And I think I actually ended up playing RuneScape 3
For a little bit like a dummy
Because I was like, why is the game so different?
Why did they do that?
Or was it they made RuneScape 3
And then everyone was like, ooh, go back
And then they were like, okay, there's now two games
These are the golden hours
So this is the last bit
Uh, not quite, we've still got...
50 minutes, I could have sworn it said 50 minutes
50 minutes ago, but...
There's three?
I thought there was like RuneScape 3
Wasn't the new RuneScape called RuneScape 3?
It's really OG-san
Get it? Cause that's how I say OG
RuneScape 3 is the original server from that
Old-school RuneScape is them
We put in the old game back
Oh, okay
Cause they did a World of Warcraft do that as well
There's like an old world warcraft
Oh my god
My tongue is not even following what I'm telling it to do
Wah!
You said three batches before, this is a lot...
No, come on
Oh, almost just knocked over my cola everywhere
I really should clean this up
But what happens if I feel not...
Stop opening up the collection
And stop eating the swordfish
We're gonna sell that, we need that money
Okay, we're at 900 now
Wah
How big is an inventory?
4, 8, 12, 16, 20, 24, 28
Okay
By the 28, that's like...
4 for every 100
Refling on time
Play both just...
Wait, what did you say?
Just play both
It's not like this game is grindy or anything
Are you gonna disappoint us or not?
No, I'm not gonna disappoint and I'm freaking doing it
I'm freaking...
I'm cooking the swordfish
I'm cooking my ancestors and my cousins and stuff
Cause get it? Cause I'm a cultfish?
Are you refling?
You're requesting us to go open it
Wah!
Are you refling?
Are you even losing that ability to read right now?
I don't think you said that
Holy crap
As you're refling, you're requesting me to go open it
Okay, that looks more like English
Go to sleep... No, you go to sleep
Go to sleep when...
When something happens
Go
I'm gonna... I can do endurance stream
Literally, I don't want to lose my endurance title
Like 2 cent meters of playing the game
Wah
I'll only go to sleep if you come with me
Come with me
Oh no, it's the wrong one, it's that Japanese song
Stay with me
Ta-da-da-da-da
I don't know how the rest of it goes
I'll only sleep if you decide to sleep as well
Yeah
Self-hypnotism by exhaustion
This is working apparently
No
You've been streaming for 11 hours
Nobody's taking your endurance stream title from you
I'm just gonna eat this little cheeky
Cheeky swordfish on a Sunday afternoon
I don't even know what day of the week is
You know what day of the week is?
Stream day
I like it, it'll be more and more weekly
Imagine if I could swim
Oh
Then for that time I got hired to sing
Right, stop it, that's naughty
That's naughty
Okay, we're almost finished with the swordfish
You're beginning to feel very, very sleepy
Why are you talking like a vampire
Hmm
Stay with me
What are they even talking about, honestly?
I feel like I'm eavesdropping to see what they're talking about
I'll wait for their new message to pop up
And I'll start commenting on what the rooflings are talking about to each other
They'll never expect it
Oh, for goodness sake, I don't know how to keep them up
Boom, boom, look at that name
They're teak, no
Please leave it alone
She collected again
Oh, I'm not late to collect
It's because I'm a waman
My mistakes is I'm even in runescape
I'm sorry, that's not nice
You can just play the waman card whenever you want
That's kind of funny though
I don't know why you're right-clicking at
I don't know, maybe I'll right-click you
What are you gonna do about that?
Right-click is funny enough
Collect your ink
Look into the mirror, you're not giving
We're talking about time-spanning games
Is your rune-crafting world still up?
I remember the old rune-crafting
I don't know what that means
But thank you for your question
The answer is probably no, smile
I don't know anything about runescape
Good night, scrawny and everyone
I'm going to sleep
Rest well
Go
Twinkle, twinkle
Look for
How I wonder
What you are
Up above the world so high
Like a diamond in the sky
Twinkle, twinkle
I swear if anyone puts anything under 18
To that question, you're all done
Okay, we've got 45 minutes or something like that
Oh no, now we've got 50
No, we've got less than 50 minutes
We've got 49 minutes
Because the board breaks all of them
Should I write the girl's marrows as a prank?
We could do that
You pretend to not be me and write the girl's marrows
And say the most terrible stuff in there
Do it, do an extremely spicy one
Okay, who should we do for us?
Mods, can I give you permission to speak
So you give me the girl's links and I'll write some stuff
And then I'll wash my hands as I should
And
So I only mentioned things that only you would know
The girls aren't gonna know who we're doing
Azura, oh my god, okay
Let's go to Azura
Big, juicy, choco knockers
You are so beautiful
Your voice is so beautiful
Your personality so beautiful
Beautiful
You are a blessing upon my life and yet
You are the goddess who gives blessings
But I am already blessed
You didn't have to give me, you didn't have to give me the blessing
God, I love you
Chocolate milkers
Good night, Azura
You are loved
Okay, that's Azura done
I'd like to keep my message private
Yes, sent
Yes, okay, sent
We have done Azura
You'll never know it's me
More swordfish, I demand more swordfish
Give me swordfish
Okay, done Azura
Who next?
AC
Go to, no, open up AC
Go to say
Okay, I'm stressed
Wait, oh, where did you go?
You're so tiny and cute
Oh my god, I'm going to be an OG-san
I'm a self-identified OG-san
And my god, you're so tiny
I want to care for you forever
I want to do what I can to make you happy, little cub
I love that you call yourself cub
It's too adorable
My old man, OG-san, heart can't take it
As long as you're happy
I am happy, little cub
Let me make you happy with my OG-san
Oh, no, you can't say that
Let me make you happy with OG-san's body
OG-san's body
Okay, there we go, send
Okay, more swordfish
Who's next?
I'd like to burn the swordfish, please
Emi, oh, where'd I even begin?
I wish for you to perish me
Then laugh in my face as you raise me
Back and forth with your, with your what?
With your, your powers, your powers?
With your powers
I want to be humiliated
Oh god, she's going to notice me
Because I can't spell humiliated
I want to be humiliated by you over and over
I want to see that
Shit, shit, eaten, grin
As I disappoint you and take any punishment you deserve
I love you, holsys
Like three?
Yeah, three
I need to send one to myself
Where is that?
We've got mercy
Okay, I'll go, go to site
I can't wait for the day you break in
and catch me watching another VTuber
that isn't you
It's one big mistake, of course
but you can't help but become feral
at the switch of a button
No, you can't help but become feral at the site
and completely enraged
before you know it, we're, we're dancing
Before you know it, we're, we're, well
I don't have clothes, I don't have clothes
clothes on in this scenario
but you claim me as yours
and it went and we both had a good time
Thank you
I don't even think that's English
Okay, we're almost done
Okay, surface, a little more surface
Okay, one more
Shibi
Shibi, shibi, shibi, shibi
Alright, Shibi
Um
Uh
Well, I was going to be saying
I'm going to bed because
I'm so tired
Shibi, shibi
Mm
Mm-hmm
Shibi
Shibi's a bunny rabbit
Mm
Mm-hmm
Oh
Okay, we're done
I can't do it anymore
We're done
I thought I got a good sleep
I think I'm done refling
I can't take any more
You've outstaminated me refling
I think I'm done
I can't last any longer
I'm sorry
Will you forgive me for going to bed?
I need to sleep a little bit more
You've done enough surface maths
and go to sleep
I'm going to be like that for you
Okay, refling
I'm going to
I'm going to go
and sleep
Um
Thank you very much for hanging out with me
You've been a good, giant-ass Uji-san
that made lots of cake or whatever
Good night, refling
I'll see you tomorrow when I wake up
once in a while
Good night
I'll dream
I'll dream of us on the farm
playing Connect 4
and then I reach
because I'm so bad at it
Bye, refling
See you at the mercy
Okay
I'm going to go to sleep
Love you, refling
I'll see you tomorrow
Bye
Go see
Say hi to mercy
Yes, mercy modis
Goodbye, mercy
Good night
Bye, refling
Love you, muah
What?
Yes
Mercy time